Die Stimme der Jugend ist ja frisch vom Meer eingereist.
Vom Boot.
Genau, du hast ein Segelscheinchen gemacht.
Wie das ganz fiese ist, also dieser Schein heißt ja Day Skipper. Auf jeden Fall hab ich diesen fiesen Ohrwurm die ganze Zeit und denk mir, es muss doch schon mal jemand gegeben haben, der diesen Beatles Song quasi, also Day Skipper Song, also Day Tripper heißt ja.
Tja, wenn man mal die ganzen Lieder auswendig könnte, außer Jugend, ne? Dann wärs auch einfacher mit dem Entertainment. Könnt ihr noch alle Fernsehserien?
Nee, aber ich konnte die auch nie.
Deiner weißer Löse, wir sind stolz auf dich.
Und diese Biene, die ich meine. Ist der Kimba?
Bis ich kam.
Wurden da so ein paar Synapsen oder wie die heißen, kurz geschlossen bei mir und dann war es wieder da.
Ja, willkommen im Löwen-Zirkel hier. Ich hab ne etwas dysfunktionale Stimme diese Woche. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht geht es zu Ende mit mir.
Das ist unklar.
Das heißt, wir nutzen heute die Rolls-Royce-Battaste ausführlich, ne?
Ja.
Wenn sie denn gehen würde.
Zum Dauer-Royce-Battaste-Modus eigentlich.
Ich bin nicht mehr mit ins Bluetooth-Modul gekommen.
Du darfst den halt nicht rollsparen.
Keine Ahnung. Mein neues Bluetooth-Modul verhält sich erratisch. Es war alles total modern und neu, aber jetzt funktioniert das alles nicht mehr.
Sag mal, kurze Frage mal. Hier liegt jetzt irgendwie welches Dryad Meat rum. Das hatten wir schon das letzte Mal, als ich hier war. Und das ist etliche Monate her.
Der junge Herr war bei unserer unbezahlten Promotion ganz glücklich und schenkt jetzt regelmäßig immer so zwei, drei Pakete vorbei.
Schenkt uns ordentlich ein.
Weil das ist ja schon gammelig von Hause aus.
Das ist natürlich schade für Huckel, dem das so gut schmeckt, der jetzt gar nichts abkriegt.
Dafür sitzt Huckel gerade im ICE, wo die Klimaanlage ausgefallen ist.
Dafür.
You can't have it all.
Wer nicht kommt wird bestraft.
Schöne englische Wort für. Schadenfreude.
Achso, ich dachte Dayskipper.
Na solange kein Schaumstoffklotz auf den Schienen liegt.
Genau, heute geht es auf jeden Fall nicht ums Segeln, sondern wir singen Freak Show, Freak Show, sind alle da, Roddy ist da.
Hat diese Meta-Ebene eigentlich auch einen Notausgang?
Das ist das Fenster hinter diesem toten Kopf. Das ist der Notausgang.
Danke für einen Freund.
Der ist schon durch.
Ja, genau.
Und wir haben einen Gast, wir begrüßen Tomate, hallo. Ja, war es ja schon mal in der Meta-Ebene.
Das ist gefühlt 30 Jahre her. Stimmt. Also gefühlt, ja war ich schon mal, war schön hier damals. Zwei Stunden Podcast gemacht.
Genau, wir haben mal einen CAE zusammen gemacht.
Ja, nur zwei, ich hatte nicht so viel Zeit.
Ach, so lange ist das her.
Bei CAE noch zwei Stunden.
Da waren die noch zwei Show-Podcasts.
Ja, damals war Tims Aufnahmesoftware auch so, dass die nach zwei Stunden nicht mehr kamen.
Genau, das hörte es einfach auf.
Und über was ging die Sendung?
Da hab ich damals mit Tim über Telekomics gesprochen. Das war so nach dem Arabischen Frühling, die Zeit, wo wir Dinge getan hatten. Und da hab ich dann darüber erzählt, was wir so gemacht haben.
Seitdem ist die Welt in Flammen.
Aufgegangen und wieder gelöscht und wieder aufgegangen.
Naja, war auf jeden Fall eine interessante Sendung. Wer das vielleicht nicht gehört hat, mag sich das noch mal annehmen. Weil das erzählen wir jetzt nicht alles noch mal.
Nee, auf keinen Fall. Hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Aber so ein bisschen vorstellen müssen wir dich schonen, ne?
Ja, schade.
Das musst du aber jetzt mal selber machen.
Die Sendung wäre auch eher dann über den arabischen Herbst oder wie?
Ja, genau. Nee, ich bin der Tomate. Man kennt mich auf Twitter als HerrUrber. Nein, auf keinen Fall.
Was sich natürlich schon mal sehr speziell macht.
Absolut qualifiziert für diese neue Buchhaltungssendung.
Ja, genau. Ich mag Star Wars ganz dolle.
Nein, echt? Wer hat dich gerade drauf gekauft?
Dann bist du aber eher so ein Imperialer, ne? Wenn jetzt so mit Buchhaltung und so.
Na ja, kommt drauf an, ne?
Hast du denn die Finanzen vom Death Star schon nachgerechnet?
Ja, die Finanzen stimmt leider nicht. Da ist so eine Vollabschreifung plötzlich.
Unerwartet.
Ansonsten mag ich halt irgendwie Computer-Dinge. Ich bastel gerne an alter Hardware herum. Leider zu wenig momentan, weil ich es gerade nicht geschissen kriege. Ja, das sind so die Sachen, die ich so mache irgendwie. Ansonsten gehe ich mit meinem Hund raus und sitze in der Sonne und trinke Bier.
Sehr löblich.
Wenn ich nicht gerade hier sitze und mit dem Tim zahlen schubse.
Und wo ist jetzt dein Hund?
Der Hund ist zu Hause, damit er euch nicht auf den Sack geht.
Oder wie ihm.
Also es ist jetzt kein Hund, der einem generell schon viel auf den Sack gehen würde, aber ich glaube, das ist hier nicht so die optimale Situation für Hunde. Oder?
Nein.
Womit fangen wir denn an? Gucken wir doch erstmal in die Vergangenheit hier. Wollen wir erstmal über Republika reden? Das war gerade, dann haben wir das weg.
Wir können über die, ja, meinen dringend.
Wird ja auch sonst schlecht.
Wer war da? Clemens war dauernd da.
Ich war nicht da, ich war hinter den Kulissen.
Du warst in der Garantie nicht da, Dennis, oder? Und Rolli du warst da und hast gerantet.
Ich war da, war das erste Mal da und...
Er hat getrollt. Rolli hat sich durch die Stände getrollt, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Ich weiß nicht, irgendwie.
Warum warst du denn da?
Weil ich mir das auch mal antun wollte.
Ich geh nur zum Trinken hin.
Nach 18 Uhr.
Ja.
Auch vorher.
Also so ähnlich ging das dann bei mir auch ab. Ja, keine Ahnung. Ich hab halt so ein paar. Also da war so eine deutsche Autofirma mit einem großen Stand als Platin-Sponsor vertreten.
Du meinst die mal mit, mal ohne Stern, dieser Stand?
Genau, die sind von anderen Leuten dadurch betreut worden, dass jemand den Stern geklaut hat und aufs Vordach geschmissen.
Was? Aufs Vordach von was?
Die haben dann auf dem Hof Frisbee gespielt und dann haben sie ihn irgendwann aufs Dach oben draufgeschmissen. Und die besagte Firma fand es, was ich auch nachvollziehen kann, nicht so lustig, dass man in dem Ding einfach vom Stand abrupft. Weil ein großer ist jetzt nicht so ein kleiner, in dem man vorne von der Motorhaube abplonkt, sondern war so ein großer Ding und im Endeffekt ist er auch wirklich ein bisschen infantil. Aber ist okay.
Ja gut, aber Sterne abrupfen hat halt auch so eine Tradition. Ich glaube das gehört bei der Firma dazu.
Wenn man sich als diese Firma nach Kreuzberg begibt, dann muss man damit rechnen.
Das war bei uns auf dem Kaff. Da haben wir das auch gemacht in Mittelhessen. Also da haben wir auch Sterne abgerupft.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, in Kreuzberg war das eher Usus.
Erzähl doch mal Republika mit deinen Augen, weil wenn du das erste Mal da warst, hast du natürlich eine andere Perspektive als Dennis, der noch nie da war.
Also ich könnte euch ja meine Perspektive sagen, aber...
Warte mal, hast du eine?
Ja, ganz schwarz war's. War ja noch nie da, kann ja nicht sein.
Jetzt Roddy.
Aber ich hör nur Schlechtes, fast. Außer von dir.
Wirklich?
Also ich kenn sonst keinen, der da begeistert von der Republik erzählt.
Die Partys sind nicht ganz schlecht.
Ja, aber das alleine sagt's ja schon aus, oder?
Ja, man muss sich halt grundsätzlich dafür interessieren, dass da Leute sind, die da vortreten. Ich bin nur hinter den Bühnen. Ja, aber zwischendurch war ich mal in der Sonne. Und da finde ich dann so einen Roddy oder so oder so einen Tim. Aber jetzt sag mal, wenn du auf den Kongress gehst, gehst du auch in keinen Vortrag nicht, oder? Doch, in die Abschlussveranstaltung.
Ja, aber diesmal war ich bei ein paar Veranstaltungen. Und ich hab sogar welche danach geguckt. Aber jetzt wieder Republika, würde ich sagen.
Ja, was soll ich sagen? Also irgendwie, der Anspruch, der so gerne vermittelt wird auf der Webseite und sonst wo, ist so das. Was meinst du denn? Den die Republika von sich selbst hat.
Was denkst du denn, wie der formuliert ist? Weil ich glaube, da gibt's ja Unterschied.
Ich weiß nicht, wie der formuliert ist. Aber bei mir kommt halt so an, dass man sich als quasi die Retter des Internets und die Blogrebellen und die politisch Aktiven geriert. Und dann kommt man halt dahin und dann ist halt dieser große Autokonzern irgendwie Hauptsponsor. Und dann denkst du so, hä? Also meine Erwartungshaltung war so einfach eine andere. Ich bin vielleicht auch Kongress versaut, wo irgendwie es gar keine Sponsoren gibt und alles aus der Community kommt. Und dort war halt nichts gefühlt aus der Community und alles von den Sponsoren. Und das hat so eine Konferenz, die so einen hohen ethischen Anspruch an sich selbst hat, also von mir aus gefühlt. Das hat bei mir so eine kognitive Dissonanz erzeugt. Ich bin da so reingegangen und dachte mir, wofür hast du dir jetzt drei Tage Urlaub genommen? Ich wäre fast rückwärts wieder rausgegangen. Das war so, ich weiß nicht. Ehrlich gesagt hatte ich keine großen Erwartungen. Also zumindest keine expliziten Erwartungen. Aber irgendwie, das war es halt nicht.
Okay, gab es da irgendwas, was dir auch gefallen hat?
Naja, sagen wir mal so. Ich bin halt dann so ein bisschen durch die Vorträge, beziehungsweise es waren erstaunlich viele Podiumsdiskussionen.
Das ist die Krankheit überhaupt.
Und dann war so ein Panel, die haben halt über Zukunft der Mobilität gesprochen. Da war dann so ein Prof, der meinte, der hat so den Standpunkt vertreten, alles wird gut, wenn wir alle unsere Autos abschaffen und nur noch Carsharing-Autos fahren. Ach. Ja, schöne neue Welt. Ja, da saß noch so eine von BMW mit auf dem Panel. Die war dann ganz fürchterlich gekränkt, als ich den i3 als hässlich bezeichnet hab. Nee, die haben ja dann Fragen beantwortet. Und ich hab mich dann gemeldet.
Wir machen das immer wieder, dass sie Fragen stellen.
Genau, und dann hab ich da das halt gesagt und dann hat das ganze Publikum gelacht.
Was war denn da anders, deine Frage? Oder wolltest du nur mal zur Kenntnis geben, dass du das mal hast?
Nee, ich hab halt so diverse Bemerkungen gemacht, zum Beispiel, dass ich das mit dem Carsharing... Ja, das ist im Prinzip eine nette Idee, aber Carsharing kostet halt halb so viel wie ein Taxi und dann musst du immer noch selber fahren. Und so, das fand dieser Prof total komisch. Also, es hatte auch vorher keiner gesagt, dass in dieser Vision, die der da hatte, da waren so viele Brüche drin. Carsharing-Autos kannst du nur in der Innenstadt fahren und kannst nicht mehr rausfahren.
Wie würdest du sehen, dass der Aspekt, dass es derzeit ungefähr die Hälfte, wobei es ja auch teilweise weniger ist, als ein Taxi, dass das jetzt schon... Also, wogegen spricht das deiner Meinung nach? Also, es ist ja dann immer für Leute, die ab und zu mal ein Auto benutzen, im Sinne von zwei-, dreimal die Woche, kann das am Ende immer noch billiger sein, als ein eigenes Auto zu haben.
Ja, nun, aber er hat das halt so hinargumentiert, als gäbe es... Also, dass die Leute, die jeden Tag ein Auto fahren und das halt mehrmals am Tag, dass die damit gut bedient wären, wenn die ein Carsharing-Auto fahren würden. Was natürlich irgendwie dann auch kostenmäßig sich halt auch irgendwie überhaupt nicht mehr rechnet. Also, es war irgendwie...
Ich finde das übrigens hochinteressant, dass bei dieser Debatte jetzt du auch gleich wieder als erstes Argument Kosten eingeschmissen hast. Naja, ich hab die Kosten ja eingeschmissen. Ja, ist egal, aber das kommt halt häufig vor. Das wird halt bei dieser Diskussion, der ganzen Verkehrsdiskussion, wenn man mal so ein bisschen rauszoomt und jetzt nicht speziell, sagen wir mal, jetzt so was wie Elektroroller betrachtet, sondern noch weiter rauszoomt oder so, so öffentlichen Verkehr und so. Da ist als erstes doch immer die ökonomische Variante oder die ökonomische Komponente sozusagen mit auf den Tisch gelegt wird. Ökologische Komponente? Lebensqualitätsverbesserungen?
Als Ziele seh ich das natürlich auch klar, allein wenn weniger Karren rumstünden. Ja super. Dann wäre das gut. Man könnte weniger Platz...
Ja, weil deine erste Frage war, oder dein erstes Kommentar war, der kostet halb so viel.
Nein, ich hab ja nur darauf Bezug genommen, was er gesagt hat.
Diese ganzen Sachen wurden in dem Panel ja auch besprochen. Also ehrlich gesagt, die haben sich dann auch so sehr viele Softball-Fragen ausgetauscht. Das war irgendwie...
Die sehen sich ja jede Woche auf irgendeinem Panel.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Da war halt irgendwie dieser Ökostromanbieter, wie heißen die? Lichtblick. Genau, da war so ein Typ von Lichtblick. Dann war da die Frau von BMW, die weiß ich nicht genau, ob die jetzt was mit Drive-n-Out zu tun hatte oder nicht. Und dann war halt noch dieser Prof, der sich als Zukunftsforscher Mobilität oder so gesehen hat. Irgendwie, ja...
Ich wollte jetzt auch nicht tollen, diese Diskussion. Mir fällt's bloß gerade auf, weil ich in letzter Zeit häufiger mal rauszoome und immer mal so Sachen hinter, oder Diskussionen hinterfrage. Also auch Wertschätzung von Dingen zum Beispiel. Oder wie werden so Sachen eingenordet? Ich hatte neulich mal einen kurzen Twitter-Chat mit dem Ulf Burmeier, der fragte, ob ihm nicht jemand für seine Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte, die ja nur ein Neubüro irgendwo haben, keine Ahnung, irgendwo Mitte oder Kreuzberg, weiß nicht wo, fragte, ob ihm nicht jemand, ob nicht ein Carrier ihm einen Internetanschluss spendieren würde. Und da ist ja an der Frage erstmal nichts dran. Man befehlt zu oft, dass das halt so eine Haltung ist von vielen Leuten, die so, ja, Internet ist, ja, es muss irgendwie da sein, muss irgendwie umsonst da sein. Ich hab dann zurückgefragt, sag mal, spendiert der auch jemand die Miete? Oder spendiert jemand die Heizung? Oder so. Er sagt, nein, hat er mit einem deutlichen ja geantwortet, aber da hat er auch gar nicht nach gefragt. Er hat halt gefragt, ob jemand den Internetanschluss spendiert. Und dann fiel man halt einfach nur so auf, dass so diese Erhaltung da ist. Und ebenso ist halt eben auch bei anderen Fragen diese Geschichte, dass man eben bei solchen Car-Sharing oder wie auch immer, bei wie auch immer geharteten Verkehrsmodellen für die Zukunft eine der ersten Fragen, wenn nicht die allererste Frage mal ist, was kostet mich das? Die ist nicht unwichtig, die ist nicht unwichtig, aber trotzdem interessant doch zu sehen, was sozusagen die Priorität ist für die Leute. Die sagen nicht, wie krieg ich denn jetzt hier mal den ganzen Blech weg? Und dann als dritte Frage, ach, guck mal an, das könnte ja auch noch billiger sein, sondern die fragen als erstes, wie kriegt das billiger? Oder wie kriegt das ökonomisch günstiger? Das ist so zu sagen, offensichtlich in den Köpfen das primäre Ziel.
Hab ich jetzt aber ehrlich gesagt nicht gesagt.
Ne, ne, aber du hast halt...
Er hat nur gesagt, der Unterton war ja so, das ist ja immer noch teuer. Ich hab nur gesagt, das mag für manches noch zu teuer sein, aber es ist schon so in einem Level, wo es für Gelegenheitsnutzer von Autos, die sonst irgendwie, die schon immer mal wieder einen Bedarf haben, so über den Monat verteilt, vier-, fünfmal auch berechtigte und wichtige Bedarfe, das ist dann am Ende mindestens genauso günstig, wenn nicht sogar günstiger ist, an der Stelle auf Carsharing zu setzen.
Ja, es ist ja nicht so, dass ich das nicht machen würde. Also ich hab ja neulich so ein i3 mal ausgeliehen und der fährt sich ja schon richtig geil. Ja, aber der stand leider nicht vor der Tür, aber ist egal. Also ich hab den halt ausgeliehen, der hatte 50 Prozent, da bin ich eine halbe Stunde damit gefahren, dann war er halt auch 25, der war irgendwie, und vor allen Dingen, der Kofferraum ist ja so unglaublich klein, der ist ungefähr so groß wie bei einem Smart, der Kofferraum.
Ja gut, es ist auch ein kleines Auto, was auf Viersitzer gemacht ist. Also es ist jetzt kein Transportwagen.
Egal, also...
Also so ein Personentransporter.
Viel stärker hab ich eigentlich den Typen von Daimler getrollt, indem ich ihm irgendwie relativ klar dargelegt hab, warum ich nicht glaube, dass Mercedes in der Lage ist, in nächster Zeit Elektroautos in Stückzahlen zu bauen. Oder bauen zu können. Und da ist er dann so halb in die Decke gegangen. Naja, das Ding war, er hatte gesagt, der hat sich so komisch ausgedrückt, er meinte, sie bei Daimler würden daran glauben, dass das mit den Elektroautos kommen würde, wie bei der Ketchupflasche. Also man hält die über seine Pommes und schüttelt die über den Pommes, die Ketchupflasche, und haut da hinten drauf. Man weiß nicht, wann der Ketchup kommt, aber wenn er kommt, dann kommt sehr viel.
Hätte ich ihm erstmal entgegenget, dass man bei vielen Ketchupflaschen einfach mal drücken kann.
Wir wollen nicht an dem Vergleich mehkeln.
Naja, das ist gar kein schlechter Vergleich. Man hätte ja die Ketchupflasche auch schon vorher auf den Kopf stellen können, wenn man da frühzeitig ein bisschen gerechnet hätte, wenn man da mal Bedarf hat.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine Analogie, wo er einem jede Menge Brücken baut, die ihn zu trollen.
Damit kriegen wir auch Tomate wunderbar ins Gespräch.
Und dann meinte er, und weil dem so sei, wollten die kein Werk hinbauen nur für Elektroautos, was erst nicht ausgelastet genug ist und dann irgendwann zu sehr. Sondern er war der Meinung, sie wollen das Konzept fahren, dass sie auf einer Fertigungsstraße sowohl Elektro als auch Verbrenner bauen können.
Das geht doch alles schief.
Genau so hab ich dir nämlich auch argumentiert. Da meinte ich, wie man sich denn das vorzustellen hätte, ob das jetzt dann eine echte Elektroplattform wäre, wie der i3 oder Nissan Leaf oder Chevy Bolt oder wie auch immer. Oder ob sie dann nur eine Benzinerkarosse mit Batterien vollräumen.
Genau daran denken die durch den Autobau.
Und dann hab ich noch gesagt, die Verlorenen von Volkswagen, die machten das ja mit dem E-Golf so. Und dann war schon so leichtes Lachen im Publikum. Und naja, dann musste er sich rechtfertigen. Und wurde dann so, ah nein, das hätte er nicht gesagt.
Die kommen nie wieder auf den Publikum.
Natürlich bauen sie eine eigene Plattform. Nur, dass die dann die gleichen Aufhängungen an der Produktionsstraße hätten. Und dann könnten sie ganz schnell umdrehen. Ich hab nicht nochmal nachgetreten, aber ich gebe dir recht.
Das wird ein Desaster. Aber gut, ich erwarte nichts anderes als Desaster. Von daher ist alles in Ordnung.
Man könnte ja eine andere Peinlichkeit der deutschen Automobilindustrie da auch im Hof beobachten. Da hat er die Post ihren...
Wie hieß das?
Ah, das ist das Elektro-Auto.
Was ich vorhin auch auf der Straße vor meiner Nase hatte. Ich finde das aber gar nicht so peinlich. Nein, das Auto ist überhaupt nicht peinlich. Es ist peinlich, dass die Post das selber bauen muss. Und Volkswagen...
Okay, jetzt bin ich bei dir.
Aber guck mal, die Post hat ja noch mal Volkswagen gekauft. Also gefühlt Jahrtausende. Und dann haben sie jetzt ein E-Auto und dann haben die mit einem E-Golf an. Und wenn ich da poste, dann würde ich auch sagen, ich wollte ein E-Auto und nicht sowas.
Ja, vor allem die wollten halt irgendwie ein Gerät, was auf ihre Bedürfnisse zugeschnitten ist. Und ich finde an diesem Postauto kann man wunderbar ablesen, was so eine, nicht die einzige, aber eine ganz wichtige Dynamik ist in dieser ganzen Elektromobilitätsgeschichte, die derzeit komplett übersehen wird. Oder zumindest nicht ausreichend diskutiert wird. Es ist jetzt denkbar, anders formuliert, Elektroantrieb macht Autos so viel weniger komplex als bisher, dass jetzt sogar Unternehmen und in Zukunft auch andere Organisationen, ein bisschen zu Privatpersonen irgendwann mal, darüber nachdenken könnten, welche Art von Gefährt eigentlich genau auf den Bedarf zugeschnitten ist. Dass nicht dieser Bedarf immer nur über den Massenmarkt definiert wird, sondern dass du jetzt kleine Produktionen machen kannst, ganz dediziert. Du baust jetzt eigentlich deine Kiste zusammen, machst da vier Räder ran, haust deinen Elektromotor rein, nimmst ja irgendwie eine Software runter, gib ihm.
Auf soweit ist Deutschland nicht eingestellt.
Das Dumme ist ja, dass du ein bisschen eine Zulassung kriegst. Zum Kraftfahrtbundesamt.
Ja gut, aber das haben sie ja offensichtlich geschafft.
Ja, aber als Post kannst du sie auch leisten, das zu machen.
Dann baust du auch mehr als eins davon.
Das ist halt im Verbrennungsmotorbereich nicht vorstellbar gewesen in demselben Magen. Es gibt Ausnahmen, hier dieses englische Taxi, was irgendwie seit Ewigkeiten ja auch...
Bauen sie jetzt auch ein Elektro?
Bauen sie jetzt auch ein Elektro, aber das ist auch, sagen wir mal, eines der wenigen Gefährte, was schon immer für so einen spezifischen Bereich explizit gebaut wurde, oder diese UPS-Wagen usw. Also klar, es gibt auch da ein Large Scale, wo das schon der Fall war. Aber ich glaube, keiner hat bei der Post irgendwie gesagt, wir müssen jetzt unbedingt in den Elektromobilitätsmarkt einsteigen.
Die wollten einfach nur ihre Scheiß...
Und dann sind die dahingegangen und gesagt, ihr seid doch die Lösungsanbieter für Mobilität. Und Volkswagen so, ne, sind wir nicht.
Wir haben auch Mitverbrennung halt.
Ja, wir verkaufen irgendwie schlechte Luft.
Schlechte Luft in Tüten. Nicht bloß das, weil es eben auch sehr wegen der Komplexität sehr eingeschränkte Modellvarianten gibt. Das stimmigt ja vollkommen zu. Das ist durchaus vorstellbar. Das sieht man ja auch schon. Gibt ja jetzt Creti und Pleti in Kalifornien, fängt jetzt an, Autos zu bauen. Gibt ja da nicht bloß Tesla, sondern gibt ja jetzt auch, wie hieß denn die anderen, die sind da, gibt es auch so ein alter Elektrotechniker, den sie da... Weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber es gibt alles mögliche. Lauter so Minibuden, so 200, 300 Leute, fangen jetzt an, plötzlich eh Autos zu bauen, weil du halt eben kaufst einen Motor hier, kaufst eine Batterie da und dann...
Ja, und als wir letztes Mal hier drüber gesprochen haben, meinte ich ja noch, hier diese alten Gocomobile und so weiter von 50er Jahren, wäre noch eigentlich mal wunderbar, stellt sich raus, wenn man jetzt mal durch unsere Kommentare durchgrast, ohne Ende gibt es genau das, also so wie diese Messerschmitt-Kapsel und all diese kleinen Fahrzeuge, die...
Alle auf Batterie umgebaut?
Alle einfach auf Elektro umgebaut. Ob die dann jetzt erfolgreich sind, weiß ich nicht. Aber die Kreativität bricht sich Bahn und es ist halt durchaus vorstellbar, dass wir, wo wir heute es gewohnt sind, dass es eigentlich nur so zehn Anbieter gibt, die in drei Konzernen gehören, dass wir in 10, 20 Jahren eine ganz andere Versorgungsstruktur in der Industrie haben werden.
Ja, und in 30 wieder nur so und so viele.
Das kann sein.
Es gibt in England eine Bude, die bauen Elektroquats. Auch sehr schön.
England, EU-Ausland.
Wenn man sowas mag.
Diese Bruttinger-Penet, gibt's die als Aufzeichnung?
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen als Aufzeichnung, aber ich glaube, die haben noch nicht alles rausgehauen.
Doch, jetzt schon.
Nee, es ist noch nicht alle hochgeladen. Es ist auch nicht von allen Bühnen aufgezeichnet. Aber die Media-Convention ist aufgezeichnet.
Also, er sagte, hinter den Kulissen.
Mir wurde das so mitgeteilt. Genauso von der Veranstaltungsorganisation.
Keine Ahnung, was die dir erzählen. Ich weiß, dass alles aufgezeichnet wurde. Ich kenn sogar den Marsden, den Admin von dem Pfeilsaft. Wollten wir sagen.
Du kennst den auch.
Also von daher, was davon jetzt, wie, wo, wann veröffentlicht wird. Aber eigentlich haben sie alles schon rausgehauen. Die haben ja nach Schichten eingelegt. Und der Trafik zeigt auch anders, der endlich ist hochgeladen von den Kollegen.
Also, die sind Daimler-Typen, der ist schmerzhaft. Also da bin ich halt mit Erwartung. Nein, nein, das war in einem extra Panel. Also der saß mit Don Dahlmann auf der Bühne in zwei gemütlichen Sesseln. Und diese Bullshit-Dichte, die war so dermaßen hoch. Der Typ, der konnte gar nicht mehr richtig Deutsch sprechen. Der hatte so dieses Schwäbisch-Dinglisch drauf. Das war, also...
Du willst mir sagen, die haben von dem Sponsor auch gleich einen ins Panel gesetzt.
Die Sponsoren kaufen sich da ja E-Panel ein und Vorträge. Deswegen hängt die Programmzeit teilweise.
Ja, und sie haben ihre Case-Strategie vorgestellt. Ja, C steht für Kommunikation, E für Elektro, A ich glaub für Autonom und S weiß ich nicht mehr. Smart glaub ich.
Smart muss überall mit rein.
Ja, also Smart muss sein. Vielleicht nochmal ein anderer Aspekt von der Republika? Clemens. Du hast ja schon fast anklinken lassen.
Er kennt den Admin. Ihr kennt den auch. Es gibt da einen Fallzauber, der da so rumsteht, wo die ganzen Videos drauf sind.
Ich meine, du hast er sicherlich wieder mit dem Netz gemischt.
Hast du da IPv4 gesperrt?
Nee, aber ich hab wieder alles auf eine IPv4-Adresse genattet. Alle 11.000 Typen, die da rum.
Auf 65.000 Ports.
Nein, das ist eine common misconception. Es ist so geil, jeder den ich frage, den ich da sage, wie, 65.000 Ports, das passt doch gar nicht. Es sind nicht 65.000 Ports. Viel, viel mehr. Weil für ein Flow sind fünf Dinge, die da drin sind. Das ist einmal das Protokoll, TCP oder UDP, Source Port, Source Address, Destination Port, Destination Address.
Also 5 mal 65.000.
Für jedes Ziel im Internet, jedes Ziel, was es im Internet gibt, und jeden Port dort, den es im Internet gibt, hab ich auf meiner Seite 65.000 Ports. Das reicht dann ja wohl schon. Außer, wenn jetzt Facebook zum Beispiel nur noch eine Adresse verwenden würde, und alle gleichzeitig auf Facebook rumklicken, dann wird's ein bisschen eng. Aber ja, ja...
Dann hättest du immer noch 65.000 mindestens.
Dann hätt ich 65.000 immer noch. Ja, ich wollte das eigentlich nicht machen, aber... Mit dem Internet oder dem Job? Nee, die ganze Geschichte. Aber derjenige, dem ich das überhelfen wollte, letztes Jahr, der ist ausgeschieden aus dem Game. Und jetzt haben sie... Ja, denn jetzt... Ja, dann hatten sie irgendwie Käden und dann hab ich gesagt, ne, das wird das eh scheiße meited. Kein Scheiß, das war eine der Begründungen. Aber ja, wir haben ein bisschen... Bedingen wir ja mindestens aus, dass wir ein bisschen mal was basteln. Also jetzt einfach nur irgendwie ein Netzwerk zu bauen, wo V4 Blad drauf ist, wo die Hipster dann auf Facebook klicken können. Ist mir dann irgendwie auch zu lame. Am WLAN hab ich jedenfalls dieses Jahr nicht besonders viel gemacht. Wir hatten aber noch jemand anderes dabei, der unbedingt mal die Halle 7 machen wollte, also die Stage 1, die große Bühne. Weil das ist ja sozusagen auch schon mal so ein bisschen... Naja, das muss man mal hinkriegen, einfach mal da so ein paar tausend Leute da zu bespaßen. Und dieserjenige hat sich da sehr, sehr reingehangen und hat also exklusiv die WLAN-Geschichte für die Stage 1 gemacht. Und da gibt's noch diese lustige Story dazu, das war irgendwie echt nett. Wir saßen dann so im Nock und er brabbelte dann am letzten Nachmittag so vor sich hin, meinte dann so, naja, sieht ja alles ganz gut aus. Aber wäre eigentlich mal ganz cool, wenn da mal jemand Speedtests machen würde. Und wir sagten, okay, Challenge accepted, bin halt rüber zu Johnny Häusler, hab gesagt, hallo, du machst ja hier so das Endgame, sozusagen die Endveranstaltung. Wenn du da Bock drauf hast, fragt dann mal die Leute, ob sie nicht mal Lust haben, mal Speedtests zu machen. Alle gleichzeitig. Haben die denn auch gemacht? Interessanterweise auch die Typen im FOH, also in der Videotechnik und an der Tontechnik, mit ihren Laptops, die allerdings per Kabel angebunden waren. Ja, so haben wir es dann doch geschafft, die 2G, die wir da hatten, aufs Gelände vollzukriegen. Mit dem WLAN alleine wär's nicht gereicht, weil das geht einfach da nicht so durch die Infrastruktur durch, aber auf der Station. Aber nachdem die Jungs in der Bühne dann auch noch drauf geklickt haben und dann einer aus einem Laptop alleine 600 Megabit erzeugt hat, dann haben wir das doch geschafft, das vollzumachen. Aber es ging. Und das Netz hat es überlebt und seitdem grinst dieser Kollege, der das mit dem WLAN gemacht hat. Seitdem. Der grinst den ganzen Tag.
Aber den auch kennen.
Ich glaube nicht. Philipp Sünderhoff heißt er.
Ging es jetzt nur darum, den Uplink irgendwie dicht zu machen?
Nein, einfach mal gucken, was passiert, wenn du jetzt mal da so ein Netz hinbaust, unter dem jetzt mal, keine Ahnung, gefühlt 2000 Geräte sitzt, weiß nicht, wieviel den Veranstaltungen da sind. Da war ja jeder Platz besetzt und rechts und links quiltet noch raus. Und weiß auch nicht, wie viele Leute da mitgespielt haben. Da müsste man jetzt wirklich mal die einzelnen Detailstatistiken daraus werten. Aber jeder sollte mal sein Handy zupfen, der da irgendwie Speedtest drauf hat oder uns eine Seite aufrufen oder wie auch immer. Und das haben die Leute dann auch gemacht. Und die Idee war zu sehen, ob das A überhaupt geht und B, ob dann nicht einfach glühende Access Points von der Decke fallen oder sowas. Ist aber beides nicht der Fall gewesen. Also es hat funktioniert und Access Points sind doch hängen geblieben. Das machst du nicht im ICE. Da brauchst du auch nicht mal einen ganzen ICE für. Da brauchst du einfach nur eine Sitzreihe im ICE.
Also ich kenn viele Veranstaltungen, wo...
Die sind auch nicht dafür gemacht. Muss man ganz ehrlich sagen. Die sind nicht dafür... Niemand baut so eine Messerhalle so, dass sie mit der generischen Bestückung, die da an der Hallendecke hängt, dummerweise übrigens auch, aber die da an der Hallendecke hängt, dass du solche Spielchen machen kannst. Es gibt nur ein paar Spezialveranstaltungen, wo die Leute auch Spaß haben, ihr Netz so zu bauen, dass es geht, also Kongress, wie jetzt mal in der Halle 7. Oder wenn zum Beispiel CISCO Live, CISCO hat ja auch so ihre Hausmesse, die sie so veranstalten an mehreren Orten auf der Welt. Im Februar waren die in Berlin wieder mal, wie jedes Jahr. Und die machen halt einfach Material-Schlagweise Können. Die bringen dann halt einfach mal 1500 APs oder so was mit, die sie da wie im 8-Meter-Abstand auf den Flur stellen. Und zwar nicht von der Decke hängen, sondern so an Ständern auf dem Flur stellen.
So auf Kopfhöhe.
Nee, das macht halt einfach Sinn. Du willst bei einer Großveranstaltung keine APs an der Decke haben. Aber wer so was baut, der will natürlich auch mal sehen, ob das geht. Aber jetzt eine generische Messerhalle in Hanover ist natürlich nicht dafür gebaut, dass alle Typen, die da gerade drin sind, gleichzeitig auf Speedtest klicken. Aber so was war da... Ich hatte sozusagen als mein Projekt eher mal ein bisschen Festnetz, weil ich hab ja immer so ein bisschen Sorgen, wie jedes Jahr mit diesen, ich nenne sie immer Aussteller. Das sind zwar offiziell Partner, nennen sie die denn da, oder Platin-Partner, Medienpartner, und dann gibt's Partner, bis der Arzt kommt. Aber für mich sind das im Prinzip alles Aussteller. Und da muss ich echt sagen, da tun sich Abgründe auf. Deswegen habe ich dieses Jahr den Leuten Zwangsrota verpasst. Also ich hab mal ein bisschen Telekom gespielt, also nicht deutsche Telekom, sondern so ISP Telekom. So Telekom, wie so ein, hab ich gesagt, ihr kriegt auf jeden Fall am Ende von eurem Kabel kriegt ihr einen Router von uns. Ob ihr da noch eine Fritzbox hintersteckt oder fünf, ist mir ja egal. Aber ihr kriegt auf jeden Fall erstmal ein Kästchen von uns. Und diese Entscheidung war echt Gold wert. Warum? Na von der Logistik her, weil wir haben das Problem, wir mussten mit weniger Zeit auskommen. Die Station hatte sich überlegt, das wäre eine glorreiche Idee, wenn sie bis sozusagen kurz vor der Angst, 3 Tage oder 2,5 Tage davor die Station selber nutzen. Das ist ja ihr gutes Recht. Aber sie haben dann so Sachen gemacht, wie wir drehen jetzt hier ein Image-Video mit Drohnen. Und da darf natürlich kein Kabel von der Decke hängen. Das heißt, wir konnten jetzt auch nicht vorher aufbauen, wie den Jahren vorher, schon mal Kabel hängen, so die man dann so aufgewickelt an der Decke hängen oder so. Sondern das musste dann halt eben alles in einer Nachtschicht passieren. Und dann muss man das natürlich auch noch irgendwie getestet kriegen. Und üblicherweise ist das so, dass wenn du jetzt nur Kabel von der Decke schmeißt, irgendwas ist immer kaputt. Da fährt einer über das Kabel oder der Typ, der das Kabel oben reingesteckt hat, morgens um drei, der hat natürlich in die falsche Buchse gesteckt oder wie auch immer. Also es ist immer ein bisschen hakelig. Und wenn du das so hast, wenn du also wenig Zeit hast zwischen, wer hängt das Kabel und der Aussteller kommt morgen, und der Aussteller kommt nicht alleine, sondern die kommen alle morgen. Und jeder kommt an und sagt, ich will jetzt mein Internet haben. Und du hast halt wenig Leute auch, du hast jetzt nicht für jeden Aussteller einen Typen, den du daneben stellen kannst, sagen, hier, mach das mal klar. Dann gibt es immer so Reibereien, das hatten wir in den letzten Jahren auch schon. Und dieses Jahr war das halt extrem vom Timing her. Und deswegen habe ich gesagt, wir machen folgendes, wir machen halt diese so Mini-Zwangsrouter, die hängen wir auf jeden Fall ans Ende von dem Kabel. Damit können wir das ganze Zeug testen, bevor die Aussteller kommen. Weil wir wissen ja, ob unsere Router da sind, die schicken Reports nach Hause, ob ihnen der Link gefällt, man kann auf die Error-Counter gucken und Zeugs sagen. Ich kann jetzt garantieren, dass das Netz und auch das richtige Netz auf dem Stand angekommen ist.
Das heißt, du hast quasi den Aussteller schon mal vorsimuliert?
Ja, oder den wichtigsten Teil, also bis wirklich vor dem Aussteller gerät, auf dessen Stand.
Es gibt da sozusagen ein Device, das gehört dann zu seinem Netz, das ist schon operabel und da hast du auch noch administrativen Zugriff drauf.
Genau. Und das ist genau das, was die anderen Telcos ja im öffentlichen Netz auch machen, nur dass die halt eben nicht alle ihre Kunden gleichzeitig aufschlagen, sondern nacheinander, aber sie haben trotzdem ein Gerät bei dem Kunden zuhause, wo sie mit mehr oder weniger Access sind. Nur bei mir sind das kleine Router, da ist ein Linux drauf, sind diese kleinen Ubiquiti Edge Router RX, 38 Euro pro Stück. Da kann man sich drauf einloggen und da kann man dann mal so einen Breierschark machen. Das heißt also diese üblichen Spackenasen, die dann da kommen, wie auch dieses Jahr, die sich da draufstecken und dann natürlich erstmal bei der Veranstaltungsleitung anrufen, weil ihr Internet geht ja nicht. Da musstest du früher mal hintraben und sagen gucken, hast du das richtige Kabel und so und jetzt? Schön gemütlich im Nock gesessen, ein Breierschark aufgemacht auf dem Port, wo der Kunde da drauf ist und sagen, tja alter, wenn du mal DRCP anmachst und nicht deine statischen scheiß IPv4-Adressen aus deinem Büro mitbringst, dann geht das auch. Kaum macht man es richtig geht das auch schon. Und das konnte ich halt schön aus dem Sessel machen, meine Kollegen auch. Da musst du gar nicht hingehen. Und weil wir auch sicher waren, dass das nette Netz am richtigen Stand ist, konnten wir halt eben alles vorher verifizieren, bevor die da einschlugen. Und von daher kann man unter diesem Aspekt schon verstehen, dass so Telcos das auch gerne machen, dass sie halt gerne was haben wollen, wo sie sagen können, wir haben nicht nur die Leitung gemessen, was ja auch bloß so ein Blaschbruch ist, sondern wir wissen, dass da IP bei dir zu Hause ankommt.
Welches Gerät war das nochmal, was du eingesetzt hast?
Die gibt es doch noch mal in Outdoor-Varianten, wir haben auch noch zwei Outdoor-Varianten außen hingehängt für irgendwelche Übertragungswagen von irgendwelchen Sendeanstalten. Was übrigens auch sehr lustig war, da war einer da von denen, da war einer da von denen, die da so Audio machen, für irgendwie öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk, Deutschlandradio oder sowas. Und dem haben wir dann auch das Kabel da gegeben und der meinte, was kann ich denn hier so machen?
Ich dachte, das ist halt ein Internet.
Ja, kann ich denn hier auch, ja, also wir bräuchten so ein Megabit oder so für seinen Audio-Quatsch. Also eigentlich braucht er nur ein paar hundert Kilobits, so zwei, dreihundert Kilobits. Nee, ich hab gesagt, so einzelne Megabit haben wir hier nicht. Wir haben 2017, du hast hier 75. Muss ich vielleicht dazu erklären, wir haben natürlich mehr als 75 dort, aber 75 ist sozusagen meine Sicherung. Ich hab auf jeden dieser Dinger eine Bandbreitenbegrenzung für 75 Megabit reingemacht, allerdings symmetrisch. Nur für den Fall, dass sich jemand mal ein Laptop mitbringt, wo ein Trojaner oder ein Virus drauf ist, der zu viel Spaß haben will mit einem Gigabit. Also ich gebe euch mal 75, wenn er mehr braucht, dann sagt er Bescheid. Hat keiner gebraucht, aber egal. Und dann war dieser Typ, der meinte, ah ja, guck mal. Dann kann ich auch mal das probieren. Ich sag, ja, mach mal, dreh mal hoch. Dann hat er hochgedreht, keine Ahnung, ein halber Megabit. Dann hatte ich gesagt, oh, das geht ja alles toll. Jetzt, ähm, ich will jetzt auch mal probieren, was so passiert, wenn ich ganz unten scrolle. Er hat, weißt du, so ein Hardware-Codec, so ein 19 Zoll Ding, wo er halt seine Audiozeug da reinstopft, vorne so ein kleines Display dran und ein paar Tasten. Ähm, und da ist es uns ähnlich wie Studiolink, benutzen die SIP auch. Offensichtlich, äh, ich glaube, der MDR oder so, betreibt so ein SIP-Server für die ARD. Ja, und dann rufen die sich da gegenseitig drüber an und fahren halt so verschiedene Codex. Und dann hat er mal nach ganz unten gescrollt mit dem Ding, hat sich im Funkhaus irgendwo eine Schleife schalten lassen, dass er also das hört wieder, was er zurückkriegt, sozusagen, was er selber sendet. Und dann hat er drunter gefahren und hat doch geschafft, ein Audio-Stream mit 2,3 Megabit zu erzeugen. Keine Ahnung, wo das herzog.
Ich hab mir auch nicht klar, welches Endcoding da ist, aber wahrscheinlich ist es mehr als ein Kanal, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, aber...
Ich hab schon mal drüber gesprochen.
192 Kilohertz abgetastet.
Ich hab so die Vermutung, dass es da nur ein Feld gibt für die Bitrate und das auch noch Video abdeckt. Und dass man das dann einfach auswählen kann und keine Ahnung.
Jedenfalls, er war total begeistert. Er spielte dann darum und sendete sich immer selber durch die Schleife im Funkhaus ein Programm dazu. Ja, aber das fand ich dann schon interessant. Also wirklich deren Erwartungshaltung. Die erwarten halt, wenn sie irgendwohin gehen, dass sie komplett grottiges Internet haben und betteln dann so nach ihrem halben Megabit. Das fand ich dann auch ein bisschen traurig. Ja, andere Leute natürlich auch. Auch ein anderes Medien-Ding, darf ich jetzt mal nicht nennen, weil das ist peinlich für die. Die haben dann gleich so ein ganzes Sendebüro da irgendwie aufgebaut und natürlich wieder oben eingekippt über die Veranstaltungsleitung. Ihr Internet geht nicht! Dann kommst du da rein in den Raum, gehst da, ich hab geguckt, erstmal ist alles schick, aber kein Verkehr drauf und so, auf meinem Zwangsrouter, dann geh ich mal da so rein in den Raum, springt mich erstmal so ein Anzugträger an und sagt ah ja, hier Internet, wir haben dir 10 Megabit bestellt! Und ich so, ja, aber liefer nicht 10 Megabit. Ja, aber wir haben hier 10 Megabit bestellt! Ja, ich liefer hier 75. Und wenn da euer Gerät da reinsteckt, dann habt ihr auch was davon. Keine Ahnung, was die für ein Internet oder sonst was hat. Habt ihr nämlich geredet, habt ihr gesagt, hier einer von seinen Technikputzen, der soll mal doch mal bitte von seinem Windows-PC mal die IP-Adresse davor lesen, die er da drin hat. Und da fingen die dann an so mit 192, 180.
Nee, das ist nicht meine.
Ich hab gesagt, guck mal, da ist dieses kleine schwarze Kästchen da oben, wenn ihr euch da reinschreibt, dann sozusagen Kabel genommen mit diesem PC von dem Vogel, der da direkt abgerupft von seiner Infrastruktur, keine Ahnung. Da kommt irgendein Hausinterner IT-Vogel, der verdrahtet das alles und dann geht der wieder weg. Und dann ist das alles chick. Oder eben auch nicht. Aus deren Haus. Und dann hab ich, wie gesagt, einfach mal ein Kabel genommen und diesen PC direkt auf meinen Zwangsrouter gestellt. Ich hab gesagt, machst mal Speedtest net. Dann hat er 2x75 vorgelesen. Hab ich gesagt, ich wünsche Ihnen einen schönen Tag. Und dann haben die ihr ganze Zeugs auseinandergerufen. Weil keine Ahnung, was der Typ da zusammensteckt hatte. Ob der noch irgendwo einen UMTS-Router drin hatte oder ein ESDN-Anschluss oder sonst was. Doch, die denn ja. Also das heißt, entschuldigt. Ich hab auch drumme gebeten, aber das war gar nicht nötig, weil haben sie es sowieso gemacht. Weil ich hab gesagt, pass mal auf, wenn ihr das immer bei der Veranstaltungsleitung einkippt, dann dürft ihr auch da hinterher anrufen und sagen, dass das euer Problem war. Weil ich will hinterher nicht hören, dass mein Netz scheiße war. Man hat ja schon noch so ein bisschen so einen Anspruch da. Und das machen die aber auch. Also das war dann auch okay. Was es leider gibt als Trend ist, wenn wir mal so bei Trends sind, abgesehen von den offiziellen Trends, da rannte ja jeder mit einer VR-Brille rum. Das war jetzt so der absolute.
Das wollte ich auch noch sagen. Also das Symbolfoto war die Maus von der Sendung mit der Maus, mit dieser Pseudo-VR-Brille. Und was ich eigentlich so richtig schön fand dabei, die hat die Brille nicht vor den Augen gehabt, sondern auf der Stirn. Und das fasst die ganze Veranstaltung zusammen. Es musste eine Brille sein, aber da die Dinger nicht benutzbar sind, trägt man sie dann nur so als modisches Asyl. So wie so eine Sonnenbrille in den Haaren, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich erinnere mich an den, wann war denn das? Das war doch gefühlt noch... Wann war denn diese erste VR-Datenbrillen? Johnny Mnemonic Anfang der 90er? Das muss sowieso um die Wende gewesen sein. Und ich hab so total den Flashback von dieser Zeit. Also es wird genau derselbe Quatsch geredet.
Alle haben wieder Brille auf, alle sind wieder im Cyberspace.
Warst du denn in der Kinky VR-Ecke?
Na ja, Cyberporn.
Da gibt es nämlich auch noch eine nette Story zu.
Na ja, das war eine Naughty VR-Ecke.
Du hast nichts verpasst.
Du hast überhaupt nichts verpasst.
Die war auf derselben Etage eingeplant wie Microsoft. Woraufhin?
Diese Angst vor Schmutz. Ja, für sie Schmutz, das hatte ich bei AOL früher auch immer, aber alles sehr lustig.
Ja, nee, das war eher peinlich, dieses...
Also ja, da gibt es... Was mich jetzt mal so ein bisschen... langsam ein bisschen ärgert, ist diese Geschichte, dass... Das ist ja nur diese Hipster-Veranstaltung, das zentrale Meeting, von was sich so Social-Media-Leuten schimpft. Kann man ja so sagen. Es ärgert mich jetzt langsam wirklich sehr. Das sind Leute, die jeden Tag damit ihr Geld verdienen. Ob nur viel oder wenig, sei mal dahingestellt. Aber sie verdienen damit ihr Geld. Das Internet ist ihr scheiß Arbeitswerkzeug. Und es geht mir total auf die Ketten, dass diese Leute einen Router nicht von einem Access Point, einen LAN nicht von einem WLAN unterscheiden können, die immer noch nicht den WLAN-Kabelwitz kennen oder verstehen, warum das ein Witz ist. Und es geht mir total auf die Ketten. Die nutzen das da den ganzen Tag und haben keinerlei Ahnung, ob davon wie das funktioniert. Und ganz ehrlich, ich verlange von niemandem, dass ein Packet Capture im Heckstamp verstehen soll oder so. Aber dass es grundsätzlich Abhängigkeiten gibt, dass man Kabel reinstecken muss, wenn man sie benutzen will. Oder diese absoluten Basics. Oder zum Beispiel wurde ich mehrfach angemauzt von einer Social-Media-Frau, einer zugehemmenden Person. Sehr netten, aber trotzdem so ein bisschen. Ja, weil ihr Internetanschluss, der sei so unglaublich langsam, ob ich da nicht was machen könnte. Und bin ich da hingegangen, bin ich gesagt, ja, es ist sehr langsam. Mach doch mal, ruft doch mal Tagesschau auf. Mach doch mal Spohn auf. Okay, geh mal auf speedtest.net. Pssst, 75 Megabit. Ja, aber sie kann denn damit nicht arbeiten. Ich sag, könnte das sein, dass das dein Server ist? Könnte das sein, dass dein Content-Management-System von deinem eigenen Server vielleicht nicht aus dem Kniff kommt oder so? Ja, aber ich muss doch arbeiten. Guckt mich denn so an, so. Ich sag, ne, aber ich kann doch deinen Server nicht reparieren. Der steht irgendwo im Wald, wird von irgendeinem Vogel administriert oder sonst was. Geh mir doch nicht auf die Ketten, dass das Netz langsam ist.
Oder halt nicht administriert, weil er langsam ist gerade.
Wie auch immer, ja. Nochmal, das ist alles lieb und hübsch und toll. Aber trotzdem, ich geh mir total auf den Sender. Weil das sind Leute, die den ganzen Tag damit arbeiten. Die könnten doch mal ein Minimum von dem verstehen, was sie dort tun. Und das wird immer schlimmer. Das wird von Mal zu Mal immer schlimmer. Auch sowieso, dass jeder Trop, ja, der Router da hinten. Nein, das ist ein Access Point. Ja, oder so, weißt du, so ein...
Das ist halt leider für viele mit deines synonymen Routern ein Access Point. Das ist so...
Ah, hat die Industrie verbrochen. Trotzdem, das sind Leute, die damit ihr Geld verdienen.
Nee, die verdienen ihr Geld damit, bunte Webseiten zu bauen. Nicht mit der Technik dahinter.
Ja, aber das sollten sie tun. Jeder Handwerker, der wie ein Handwerk betreibt, sollte wissen, wo beim Hammer vorne ist. Sollte. Sollte. Das ist mein Anspruch daran. Der war ausgebildet. Dass das auch bei Handwerkern mit Unterschrift geht, aber das fällt mir jetzt zunehmend mehr auf, weil vielleicht mehr Leute sind, oder weil die Technik immer komplizierter wird, oder wie auch immer. Aber das finde ich schon sehr irritierend. Insgesamt. Ja, aber es war irgendwie, da sonst die Veranstaltung easy peasy war, war ich dann auch immer cool, hab dann ein bisschen eher die Augen hoch gedreht, hab so einen Knock erzählt, wenn mir so was untergekommen ist, und dann haben uns alle drüber gefreut, aber es ist natürlich trotzdem auch irgendwie ein bisschen so, hm, äh? So, aber das war jedenfalls eine schicke Sache. Und von daher hat es auch Spaß gemacht, hat ein nettes Team. Wir hatten einen Kollegen vom CCC noch mit dabei, nämlich den Arl, der, äh, wie wohl auch in Berlin weilte, oder meinte, er hätte da mal Lust darauf. Und, äh, das war auch sehr nett, die Kooperation. Und, äh, ja, dann wie gesagt den Kollegen Sünderhoff, der mit seiner kleinen Firma hat dann da diese WLAN aufgebaut, da in der Halle 7. Ähm, und das war auch sehr nett. Also von daher war das entspannt. Und mit diesen Zwangsroutern waren wir sozusagen so 12 bis 24 Stunden vor den Ausstellern fertig und konnten uns da auch zurücklehnen. Das heißt, wir hatten nicht so dieses AAAAAAAA wie es die letzten Jahre immer war. Von daher war es eigentlich recht angenehm. Also ich kann da jetzt nichts meckern.
Warte noch mal kurz, du hast gesagt, diese kleinen Edge-Router-X-Krisse für 38 Euro.
Ja, aber ich hab davon 80 gekauft. Aber der ist auch sonst nicht wesentlich teurer. Den gibt es noch mal als kleinen Bruder. Das ist der kleinste, der X. Dann gibt es noch mal den X-SFP. Der hat noch einen zusätzlichen Port, nämlich so einen SFP-Slot, wo man so ein SFP-Modul reinschieben kann, dass du also auch Glasfaserverbindungen damit machen kannst und so. Oder noch einen sechsten Kupferport zum Beispiel damit auch bauen kannst. Und der dann auch PoE auf allen Ports macht, der kostet dann mal 15 Euro mehr oder so. Aber das ist eine nette Plattform. Die hat leider wenig Flash und wenig RAM. Das heißt also jetzt großartig Dinger danach installieren, wie ich es auf den großen Edge-Routern mache, also da ganze Routing-Engine austauschen, also habe ich jetzt noch nicht gemacht auf den Clemens. Aber dafür haben sie vier CPUs, die haben zwei CPUs mit Dual, blablabla, also insgesamt so vier, wie sagt man, Threads oder so was kannst du fahren. Ist also auch gerade für Leute, die mal schnell eben ein bisschen Krypto machen wollen, die also mal IPsec mit Hardware-Beschleunigung oder OpenVPN oder so was machen wollen, ist das ganz nette Teil. Und 5Gbps? Nicht für so viele Dinge wie die großen Dinger. Also er macht zum Beispiel, er macht V4, macht V4 Hardware. Nee, das sind alle keine Armen. Das sind MIPS. MIPS-Cores. Nee, das sind spezielle Dinger, die haben halt ein MIPS-Core drin für das eigentliche Zeug und dann haben sie noch so zusätzliche Hardware drin, je nachdem, was für ein Modell ist. Ubiquiti fährt da zwei Modell rein. Das ist eine MIPS Little Engine und die anderen sind Big Engine. Das ist aber MIPS 64-Plattform. Und wie gesagt, mit vier Cores kann der durchaus mal ein bisschen Krypto machen. Und der hat, also wenn du so obskure, ich sag jetzt mal obskure Krypto, ein bisschen wie OpenVPN, was ja im User-Mode läuft. Aber wenn du so kernel-Krypto-Ipsic oder sowas machst, hat der nochmal richtig Hardware-Beschleunigung dafür drin. Und das ist für den Preis eigentlich ganz sexy. So fünf Ports, die kann man auch wahlweise als Switch oder als Router-Ports betreiben, kannst du auch sozusagen das Ding einfach nur als fünf-Port-Switch benutzen, als intelligenten Switch und dafür ist das auch ganz gut. Das, wie bei all diesen Ubiquiti-Routern, ist ein Linux, ein DBN-Variante darunter.
Wollen wir mal zu einer anderen Veranstaltung kommen?
Es gibt noch andere.
Ja, wird es geben.
UIConf war jetzt gewesen, aber ist vielleicht auch nicht so spannend.
Google IO läuft gerade jetzt.
Ist das so? Ja gut, aber da wissen wir ja nicht viel drüber. Aber es wird wahrscheinlich wieder irgendeine Android-Version vorgestellt werden, die in fünf Jahren auf allen Geräten läuft.
Und auf drei Viertel nicht ausgeliefert wird.
Ich hab die immer frisch auf meinem Nexus. Das haben wir ja extra in Google vorne gekauft. Weil ich da keinen Bock hatte auf diese Nummer.
Das ist halt trotzdem nur 0,1 Prozent des Gesamtmarktes.
I don't care, funktioniert gut.
Ja, ich weiß, das ist eine Perspektive. Ich sag nur, ich wollte nicht auf die Google IO hinaus. Ich wollte nur mal kurz ankündigen, was wahrscheinlich sowieso ich schon wieder... Was noch Leipzig geht, mit dem Kongress, dem 34C3, wird also weitergezählt werden. Ja, ich weiß nicht, gibt's da Anmerkungen oder irgendwelche Gedanken?
Ja, Leipzig ist eine schöne Stadt. Fahr ich immer wieder gerne hin. Ja, also im Winter ist es ein bisschen kalt.
Wirklich? Das ist ja aber jetzt doof.
Messe ist in Ordnung.
Nachts ist kälter als draußen.
Ja, vor allem im Winter halt. Vor allem im Winter. Ja, nee, ansonsten Leipzig ist super. Also ist von irgendwie jetzt zumindest Berlin aus gut zu erreichen. Ob jetzt nach Hamburg oder Leipzig fahren muss, ist völlig egal. Find ich der Meinung. Ich glaube, die Messehallen, also die Location, die jetzt da, wo ja Teil Messehalle ist, und Teil irgendwie Kongressgedöns, also das Kongresszentrumsgedöns, das kann echt schön werden. Da kann man echt was machen. Da gibt's so viel Glas, das man bespielt, also viel Glasgedöns.
Ich glaub, man braucht ein Fahrrad.
Zum Beispiel, das könnte helfen.
Ich war in der Nacht, bevor die offizielle Ankündigung kam, man hat ja so seine Kanäle, ich glaub, das ist jetzt mal so ganz frech, war ich ja hier bei Booking Tralala Kong, standen da acht Leute, sind da auch gerade, es war ein Uhr nachts. Also, das waren schon Leute fleißig, haben ja im Hotel klickt.
Das heißt, ihr habt Insider-Trading gemacht? Insider-Booking?
Die Location musste ja auch irgendwie ausgewählt werden, natürlich wussten da schon Leute, wo da was angeguckt wurde.
Ja, wir haben Insider-Booking gemacht.
Das kann man so sagen, es gibt ja auch schon ganze Leute, die haben in Dortmund schon irgendwie sich Hotels geklickt, wo das jetzt aber nicht, aber die konnten nämlich mal alle vor Freak-Handeln.
Ich kenne sogar Leute, die haben sich ein Hotel in jeder größeren Stadt Deutschlands geklickt.
Wo ein Kongresszentrum ist, habe ich auch mit jemandem gesprochen.
I don't want to brag, aber ich gehöre ja nicht zum inneren Circle dieser CCC-Geschichten.
Du kennst den Admin.
Nachdem sich die ganzen Admins neulich mal irgendwie alle zusammen, also viele davon folge ich halt auf Twitter oder so, nachdem die sich alle irgendwie in Leipzig zusammen rotteten neulich mal, für wie ein paar Tage, dachte ich so, nachtig, egal, da höre ich doch was Trapsen.
Na gut, die haben sich den einen Tag danach auch alle in Berlin wieder zusammen rottet. So ist es ja auch nicht.
Ja, aber Berlin würde es nicht werden. Das war ja auch klar, irgendwie auch. Wo denn?
Ne, war nicht so klar.
ICC spielen?
ICC gibt es nicht mehr.
Noch nach Dortmund wäre es nicht richtig.
Na ja, es gibt da in der Messe Berlin, also es gab auch Dinge, die dafür sprachen. Also das ist jetzt nicht...
Die Battlestar Galaktica Halle, war das da ja?
Das ist jetzt nicht so eine 99 zu 1-Einsentscheidung gewesen, aber Berlin war schon noch mit im Rennen.
War das diese Battlestar Galaktica Halle?
Ich weiß nicht genau, was das sein soll.
Na, mir wurde so ein Foto gezeigt von so einer Halle, die so angeschrägte Ecken hat oben. Ne ne, das war nicht das ICC.
Doch, die hat da angeschrägte Ecken oben.
Ja, aber das war nicht das ICC, das waren die Messerhallen. Das waren nur Bilder von der Messerhalle.
Das ICC ist seit sieben Jahren dicht.
Und es bleibt dicht.
Jedenfalls sah das aus wie bei Battlestar Galaktica, wenn sie diese Fliege immer so, dieses so rauskatapultieren, so sah das aus.
Wir reden vom Messegelände Berlin. Ja, das sind die Hallen auf dem Messegelände Berlin. Das ist das, was da in Frage kam. Und es gibt da Neueres und es gibt da Älteres. Ich persönlich bin kein großer Freund der Berliner Messearchitektur. Ich find das schwierig. Nichtsdestotrotz gab's schon so Aspekte, aber es gab auch ein paar absolute... No-goes. Ja, zum Beispiel der Kongress. Der hat ja wirklich sehr umfangreiche Anforderungen. Eine Anforderung ist, dass wir einfach, weil wir so viele Gruppen und sich selbst organisierende Entitäten haben, brauchen wir natürlich auch eine entsprechende große Anzahl von kleinen mittleren Räumen, wo die halt schalten und walten können. Das war etwas, was zum Beispiel in Berlin nahezu nicht realisierbar war. Aber dazu kommt, und das finde ich eigentlich auch noch in gewisser Hinsicht viel wichtiger, dass wir da auch von Anfang an das Gefühl hatten, in Leipzig extrem willkommen zu sein. Also das war wirklich hindengreifbar, dass das ganze Team dieser Leipziger Messe so...
Da Bock drauf hat.
Die wollten das so richtig. Und waren auch extrem entgegenkommt.
Das muss ich erzählen, das wird nicht so geil.
Hatten sie alles angeguckt. Und dann ging es noch ein bisschen ums Netz. Wie ist denn das hier mit dem Netz? Kam ja Chef vom Netz. Ja, was braucht er. Aber eigentlich brauchen wir nur einen Schlüssel und müssen irgendwie überall ran. Kann man drüber reden.
Du musst aber auch passen.
Ich hab schon schon klar so, okay, hier wird richtig drüber nachgedacht.
Gelegentlich gibt es so Klein- oder an Veranstaltungszentrum. Ich bin ja auch darin involviert, so ein bisschen Zeit finden, so für ITF und guck mir daher auch mal häufiger mal so eine Dinge an. Also so Hotels oder Konferenzdinger oder so. Und bin auch gewohnt, dass die einem dann kommen mit irgendwie ein Grottenkram, irgendwie ein Cut-3-Leitung oder irgendwie nix oder gar nix oder Glasfaser mit einem Pet-Schrank mitten in der Küche überm Herd und so. Solche Dinge hab ich schon gesehen. Aber dann gelegentlich tritt man auch mal auf so ein Ding, wo sich der Inhaber dieser Location überlegt hat, ach, ich hol mir mal nen Nerd. Und dann wird er auch ordentlich gebaut. Letztes Jahr war ich mal in Kopenhagen in so einem Ding. Und der war total stolz. In jedem Raum haben wir hier n-mal Single-Mode, n-mal Multi-Mode und Cut-7 und Blah und Blob und separaten Strom und Tralala und Pipa-Poo in jedem Raum. Und Exist-Points bis der Arzt kommt, Exist-Points im Fahrstuhl und blablabla und denkst du, ah ok, da hat jemand mal Spaß gehabt und ein Budget. Also das kommt vor. Ja, da hat er einfach genug davon.
Musste er auch erstmal verkabelt kriegen.
Nö, die haben ja eh heute, in so Hotels oder Veranstaltungszentren hängen ja eh in den Fahrstühlen immer irgendwelche Displays, die irgendwas machen. Das heißt, die fahren jetzt eh mit dem Ethernet hoch und runter oder sonst immer, wenn sie die jetzt nicht mit SD-Karten bestücken oder sonst immer. Und wenn man das halt richtig baut und gleich mit einplant, dann hast du dein Ethernet im Fahrstuhl und dann kannst du auch einen Exit-Point mit dran hängen. Also sowas hab ich auch schon gesehen. Oder zum Beispiel auch in der Messe Frankfurt, die haben ja auch neue gebaut. Und da ist auch in den neuen Dingen, da ist auch wirklich Glas, bis der Arzt kommt, in jeden Raum. Da hast du alle 2, 3 Meter so eine Säule zu stehen, guckst nach, da sind dann mehrere Glasfaser-Konnektoren, Single-Mode, Multimode, all das da.
Und wenn dann eine Veranstaltung ist, wollen sie irgendwie 6 Euro die Stunde für Internet haben.
Ja, das ist ja egal. Und dann haben sie so Fascho, das, was sie selber da anbringen, klar, den IP-Layer, den kannst du in der Regel wegschmeißen. Aber wenn du erstmal eine rohe Infrastruktur hast, wir benutzen ja beim ITF-Meeting auch eigentlich nur das rohe Glas. Oder wenn da was da ist. Beziehungsweise wir verpflichten die Vertraglich, dass sie uns davon was zur Verfügung stellen. Dann machst du deinen eigenen Layer darauf, das ist gut. Aber du willst halt eben nicht durch so ein riesen Veranstaltungsgelände noch mal selber kilometerweise Glas legen. Insbesondere unter Beachtung Brandschutz und unter dieser Tür nicht durch und blau und blub und so.
Auf jeden Fall in Leipzig sieht es gut aus. Ich glaube, das wird irgendwie alles funktionieren. Da gibt es irgendwie viel Glas, da gibt es überall was.
Peterstens, wenn wir da waren, gibts ein Glas.
Nee, das waren alle sehr glücklich. Da muss viel nicht gebaut werden.
Sieht ja relativ neu aus.
Ja, das ist gerade mal 20 Jahre alt. Das ist ja quasi nichts.
Für so ein Ding ist das nichts. Aber es ist ein bisschen draußen, ne?
Es ist ein bisschen draußen. Im Leipziger Norden. Ich meine, das sind dann auch nur so zwei, drei.
Hat er mal einen Bahnhof?
Also ich meine, es sind so sieben Minuten vom Hauptbahnhof mit der S-Bahn.
Aber es hat doch einen eigenen Bahnhof, oder nicht?
Ja, aber da kannst du auch nicht pennen.
Also Hotels sind ganz schön dünn gesät in der Ecke.
Nee, aber Richtung Hauptbahnhof, also ich bin ja jedes Jahr zu Pfingsten in Leipzig, also viele Jahre zu Pfingsten da gewesen und ich hab ein Hotel gebraucht. Instadt, also Richtung Hauptbahnhof, ist voll mit Hotels. Und wenn es halt sieben Minuten mit der S-Bahn sind, dann hey.
Ja, du nimmst ja irgendwas im Zentrum, setzt dich morgens in die S-Bahn, fährst zwei, drei Haltestellen.
Ich hab schon.
Aber bis da, oder...
Aber bis man fährt die S-Bahn?
S-Bahn wird, weiß ich nicht genau, wird natürlich irgendwann nicht fahren, aber es gibt auch noch eine Straßenbahnlinie, die 16. Und...
Die fährt auch zum Hauptbahnhof, übrigens?
Die fährt zum Hauptbahnhof.
Und die fährt 247.
Das weiß ich noch nicht, aber... Ich will jetzt nichts versprechen, aber es klang so an, dass die Verkehrsbetriebe da flexibel auf Veranstaltungen reagieren können. Einerseits, und andererseits, was nicht öffentlich bedient wird, wird halt geschuttet.
Also, die leitzigen Verkehrsbetriebe kennen das mit vielen Leuten in der Stadt. Die jedes Jahr Pfingsten, Wolfgurtig treffen irgendwie 10.000 Groftis durch die Stadt und müssen irgendwie Straßenbahnen fahren.
Ja, wir machen dann 15.000 Groftis.
Buchmesse und so. Also, da bin ich mir auch relativ sicher, dass da einfach...
Aber die Buchmesse geht nicht bis nachts um drei.
Nein, das ist richtig, aber... Aber ich hab das Gefühl, das ist nur ein Gefühl, und das muss ich erst mal bestätigen, aber ich hab das Gefühl, dass Leipzig so als Stadt angemessen reagieren wird. Ob auch immer wir für den Sog da erzeugen werden. Ob das sich jetzt gleich beim ersten Event schon so niederschlägt, keine Ahnung, vielleicht, vielleicht nicht. 35C3...
Ich bin ja auch mal gespannt darauf, wie der für seine Demokratie näher bekannte Staat Sachsen darauf reagiert, dass da 15.000 Hacker, böse böse Hacker, da sich ansammeln.
Ich glaube, das ist gar nicht das Problem. Also nicht in Leipzig zumindest.
In anderen Teilen in Sachsen ist das schlimm, aber in Leipzig...
Leipzig ist zwar in Sachsen, aber es ist nicht Sachsen.
Du bist so dicht an Sachsen-Anhalt dran.
Die haben aber auch Konnewitz noch.
Nein, das ist einfach Leipzig. Ich meine, du kannst ja auch für Berlin sagen, das liegt in Brandenburg.
Übrigens gibt es ja diverse Zugverbindungen, die da relativ schnell hinfahren. Ich kenne persönlich zwei Leute. Einer, der in Leipzig wohnt, arbeitet in Berlin. Und ein, der in Berlin wohnt, in Leipzig. Weil die sich nicht kennen.
Ich meine, du bist vom Südkreuz bis in der Stunde da. Da ist dieses Nachhauseschattel. Das ist halt nur so mit Abends.
Aber gibt es das auch?
Der Flixbus hält auch an der Messe.
Der Flixbus hält direkt an der Messe, das ist richtig.
Da meint auch jemand, wenn Messe, das halten die ECEs auch an dem Messebahnhof.
Da muss man halt wahrscheinlich der Bahn rechtzeitig Bescheid sagen, was wahrscheinlich vom Club wieder verkackt.
Um das nochmal abzuschließen, was auch durchaus anklang, ist, dass man da eine Kompatibilität sieht zwischen dem Kulturraum, den der Club so ausfüllt und dem Anspruch, den die Stadt auch historisch an sich selber hat im Bezug auf friedliche Revolution etc. dass das schon ein guter Match wäre. Das klang schon oft an und das sehe ich auch nicht anders. Ich finde das auch ein gutes Statement, einfach mal zu sagen, wir gehen ins Osten. Also richtig in Osten meine ich.
Also nicht Berlin, sondern Osten.
Genau.
Soviel zum 34C3, ich glaube, sehr viel mehr kann man zur derzeit nicht sagen.
Tickets gibt es noch keine.
Genau, Tickets gibt es noch keine.
Würde es aber geben in Massen.
In Mengen heißt das.
Dieses Mal könnte es wieder reichen für alle.
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Aber das sehen wir doch dann, wenn es soweit ist für den Tickets.
Wie viel passt da rein in den Laden?
Man sollte nicht die Erwartung haben, dass jetzt das Limit der Veranstaltung auf einmal das Limit dieses Messegeländes ist. Also, sicherlich wird dieser Kongress auch nur ein bestimmtes Wachstum vertragen können. Weil du musst zusehen, dass das für das, was wir in den letzten Jahren hatten, nämlich dass es ein organisches Wachstum in beherrschbaren Größenordnungen gab. Auch wenn es schon relativ stramm war, das Programm in Hamburg, aber da hat sich auch viel angestauter Bedarf der letzten Jahre auch niedergeschlagen. Du kannst jetzt nicht jedes Jahr 3.000 weitere Teilnehmer verkraften. Weil dann bist du halt schnell in so einem Republikamoment, dass du dich umguckst und sagst...
Wie viele Leute sind auf der Republik?
Aber es ist halt nicht organisch gewachsen. Das ist wie der Kongress, der ist so nach und nach gewachsen. Die Republik ist plötzlich groß geworden, also so plopp.
Da retten auch fast nur Hipster rum, das ist echt schlimm.
So schlimm ist es jetzt auch nicht. Das ist jetzt nicht meine Veranstaltung, aber so schlimm ist es ganz ehrlich nicht.
Wie viele Leute passen nun auf die Leipziger Messe?
Buchmesser hat 170.000 Besucher.
Das ist schon ein großes Messegelände.
Aber weder belegen wir 100% der Fläche, noch wollen wir das.
Aber es passen jetzt schon 2.000-3.000 mehr rein als beim letzten Mal.
Ich sag gar nichts zu, was da mehr oder weniger ist. Am Ende ist das eine Frage, die auf vielen Erwägungen basiert. Klar ist, es muss wieder ein Wachstum geben können. Einerseits, andererseits, dieses Wachstum muss zum Kongress passen. Wir können jetzt nicht einfach nur eine Halbtrommel rühren mit, ja jetzt geil, alle Schleusentore sind offen. Sondern es wird eine Deckelung geben. Und diese Deckelung hat eine politische, eine technische, eine organisatorische Begründung. Also eine Komponente aus all dem, und ich glaube, dass es diese Zahl in dem Sinne auch noch gar nicht gibt zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Und das wird man alles abwarten müssen. Aber man hat, glaube ich, mehr, auf jeden Fall mehr Potenzial Härtefälle reinzuschleusen. Ja, zu vermeiden, sagen wir es mal so. Also man will ja niemanden ausschließen, trotzdem gibt es halt eine, muss man sagen, dass man es einfach irgendwie richtig hat.
Interessant wäre ja auch, weil es eben nicht so eine mega Großstadt wie Berlin oder Hamburg ist, wenn vielleicht doch aus diesem Grund ein paar Leute weniger kommen oder auch schon deswegen, weil es eben nicht eine große Stadt ist. Weil irgendwann gibt es ja vielleicht auch mal ein Ende von Wachstum. Also nicht alles skaliert, unendlich so weiter.
Und Leipzig-Kalde fliegen auch nicht so viele Flugzeuge an. Also vor allem die HL mit Paketen halt.
Das ist doch egal. Es ist doch vollkommen egal, wo der Kongress stattfindet. Ob der jetzt in einer Stadt stattfindet, die eine Einwohnerzahl von 1,5 Millionen hat oder nur von einer Million, ist für den Kongress vollkommen unerheblich. Der Kongress könnte auch irgendwie in Niedersachsen, in Großburg-Wedel stattfinden, wenn da die passende Location ist, und es würde trotzdem voll werden. Ja, aber ich weiß das.
Ich denke schon, dass das Publikum, was auf den Kongress geht, das ist auch harter.
Das ist denen so scheißegal.
Die fahren auch nach Brandenburg hier wie auf dem Acker.
Ja, da waren wir aber Acker fahren gewesen.
Das Camp war halt auch voll ausverkauft, bis wirklich zum letzten Bändchen, Äckchen.
Das geht eigentlich an der Front. Ich bau dir jetzt mal eine Brücke, das Thema abzubrechen. Aber sag doch mal, was geht eigentlich jetzt an der Campfront? Waren da nicht mal welche Gerüchte im Gespräch, dass man das vielleicht mal außerhalb des 4-Jahres-Tonus noch mal machen möchte?
Ja, das ist immer in der ersten Woche nach dem Camp, wenn alle so vollkommen durchstrahlt sind. Und irgendwie so die Wimben.
Das ist halt jede Woche! Ich kann mir den nächsten Monat gar nicht vorstellen, nicht auf dem Camp zu sein.
Dann beruhigt man sich erst mal 2-3 Monate, dann macht man erstmal wieder mal ein Kongress und ist da von einem im Arsch. Und dann denkst du auch schon wieder anders darüber nach.
Also steht jetzt nichts akut?
Nein, das ist erstens das nicht. Und zweitens, da diskutiert noch nicht mal irgendjemand.
Genau, außerdem kann man jetzt ja erstmal auf die Schale gehen, wenn man unbedingt auf Campen gehen möchte.
Oder aufs EMF Camp.
Also es gibt genug Angekundigungen.
Also man kann Campen gehen, wenn man das möchte.
Der Club wird mit Sicherheit erst wieder in zwei Jahren über ein Camp nachdenken.
Nachdenken vorher.
Nachgedacht haben. Gut, verlassen wir mal diese Veranstaltungsebene. Wir sollten über Buchhaltung reden und andere spaßige Sachen. Also ich hab ja mit Tomate hier diesen Fight gefightet. In den letzten Monaten. Ich berichtete, Freak Show berichtete.
Ich hab das auch fleißig gehört zu Hause.
Genau. Und ich muss sagen, die Reaktion auf irgendwie Buchhaltung ist geil.
Das ist ja so ein Partykiller.
Also ich hab die besten Gespräche morgens um drei in der Kneipe beim Bier über Buchhaltung.
Läuft. Also wirklich.
Du betreibst das ja auch als Sport irgendwie.
Das ist doch super. Dann können wir über die schönen Sachen reden, Tim.
Genau.
Ich will mal Eis haben.
Stimmt, wir haben ja noch Eis. Ich will auch Eis.
Ist das für alle Eis?
Na, du hast kein Eis bestellt.
Ich wusste nicht, dass man auch Eis bestellen kann.
Wir mehren sich die Beschwerden, dass unser Gast im Mikro nicht so doll rüberkommt.
Das ist nämlich nicht so wahr.
Okay, ich hab's Ihnen nur wieder gegeben.
Du bist nicht mikrogen. Wenn du Eis haben willst, kannst du meins haben.
Tim, wir haben deine Buchhaltung fertig.
Genau, das ist wirklich cool. Ich hab ja auch schon einiges darüber erzählt. Ich grübel jetzt auch gerade. Ich will mich jetzt auch gar nicht groß verhalten. Aber was ist denn dein Blick auf dieses Buchhaltungsthema? Das ist ja sozusagen...
Buchhaltung ist ja...
Deswegen meint die auch so Partyschreck. Das ist so, alle zucken innerlich zusammen.
Nein, nur die ohne Steuerberater.
Die und die, die wissen, dass sie längst ihre Einkommenssteuererklärung abgeben müssten.
Ich zucke da nämlich nicht mehr.
Du hast einen Steuerberater. Gute Wahl.
Aber was ist deine API dazu?
Telefon und Mail.
Und ab und zu Hausbesuche. Ich hab meinen auch längst dazu interessiert, dass er nicht mehr sagt, schicken sie mir Lala, bringen sie mir mit, sondern er kriegt von mir meine Scans, die ich mit diesem Scanner dort mache, von all möglichen Belegen. Und wenn er wirklich meint, dass er die als Papier braucht, druckt er sich die selber aus. Hat ein paar Jahre gedauert, aber macht er.
Wenn man ihnen gleich 10 Euro mehr zahlt, dann sollte man einfach anbringen.
Nee, das ist halt so ein gutes Gewerbe gewesen. Das ist jetzt nicht so ein Hipsa-Buchhalter, sondern eher so...
Aber es geht seit Jahren jetzt. Was in meiner Erfahrung mit Nerds und Steuererklärungen ist ja irgendwie die Verpeilens. Und wenn sie dann irgendwie so kurz vor Ende Mai kommen sie alle an und fragen, ob jemanden kennt, die die Steuererklärung machen könnte. Dann lacht man so, ja klar, ich kann dir das gerne mal aufschreiben, was du dafür brauchst. Dann schreibe ich ihnen das auf, was sie alles beibringen müssen. Dann höre ich nie wieder was von denen. Weil sie es verpeilt haben. Oder weil sie Angst davor haben, Belege zu suchen, weil sie nicht feststellen, wie viel Geld sie eigentlich ausgehend das Jahr über oder nicht eingenommen haben. Oder was auch immer. Und ja, das ist irgendwie... Und dann gibt es halt... Die meisten sind ja irgendwie Freiburger mit zehn Rechnungen im Jahr, weil sie lange Projekte machen. Das ist ja alles Pille-Palle. Spannend ist es halt bei Leuten wie dir. Die halt eine richtig große Einnahme-Überschuss-Rechnung machen müssen. Das ist halt Arbeit. Das haben ja die meisten da draußen gar nicht so. In dem Rahmen. Wie du. Das muss man auch mal ganz klar sagen.
Ja, eigentlich könnte es ganz einfach sein.
Es ist auch total einfach, wenn man es halt konsequent macht.
Genau, dazu muss man es ja auch konsequent kennen. Und irgendwie, und deswegen, darum wollte ich jetzt gerade hinaus. So Buchhaltung, Nerds.
Nerds?
Kannst du immer kommen mit, oh, guck mal hier, ich hab hier ein total kompliziertes Thema. Und was sagt der Nerd? Oh geil, wo ist denn das Handbuch? Irgendwie, ich pflüge mir das jetzt mal hier über Nacht rein. Ich hab mir da mal was im Internet runtergeladen. Und zwei Wochen später...
Und ballern mich durch die Tutorials durch.
Genau, wird die Branche gewechselt. Und irgendwie scheint das so bei diesem Steuerding nur begrenzt.
Ich glaube, das liegt in der DNA dieser Bevölkerung auch einfach. Angst vor Steuererklärung zu haben. Das ist ja so ein Volksschritt, die Steuererklärung. Weil man liest immer, wie kompliziert alles angeblich sei. Das sind die Spezialfälle. Das hat fast niemand. Jetzt aus unseren Kreisen. Diese Spezialfälle hat fast niemand. Und irgendwie sollen alle nicht so tun, ob es jetzt irgendwie großes Drama wäre. Und irgendwie, ich sag, du musst halt aufschreiben, was du von der Krankenkasse bezahlt hast. Dann stehen die da und gucken, wie Oxfam gesagt hat, du hast ein Zettel bekommen, da steht es drauf. Die lesen halt auch ihre Post nicht durch, die sie bekommen. So von der Krankenkasse. Oder vom Finanzamt. Und dann kriegen sie Briefe vom Finanzamt. Dann sag ich immer, ja ruf halt an und sag Bescheid, dass es länger dauert. Die tun hier nichts am Telefon. Ja, ich telefoniere nicht gerne. Ja, dann schreib halt eine verdammte E-Mail hin, wie das geht.
Die sind ganz cool im Finanzamt.
Ja, also wenn man mit denen spricht, die mögen das. Oder wie ist das, sag ich halt, schreib denen halt eine E-Mail. Und dann kommt die Frau vom Nerd, wie man kann den E-Mails schreiben.
Das hatte ich heute auch, ja.
Ja, aber das wissen die manchmal übrigens selber nicht. Man kann durchaus mal so Sachbearbeitung. Das ist mein Klassiker, den ich immer wieder höre. Also zwei, drei Mal im Jahr, wo ich mit Behörden oder so zu tun habe. Wo sie mir dann sagen, ja, dann füllen sie mir das aus und dann faxen sie mir das zurück. Ich so, was soll ich damit machen? Und dann immer so hin und her. Und ich sag, fax, das hab ich seit 20 Jahren nicht mehr. Haben sie denn keine E-Mail? Ja, sowas haben wir hier, aber ich weiß nicht, wie das geht.
Dann schickst du es einfach an die Poststellenadresse und die verkeilen es intern weiter.
Geht ja auch immer.
Ich hab aber zu eigenem gedacht, ich bin aus der Zukunft, ich hab kein Fax mehr. So.
Um jetzt auch mal zu meinem eigentlichen Punkt zu kommen. Ähm, ich finde, warum funktioniert das noch nicht? Oder vielleicht bestehen wir hier vor einem neuen Trend. Weil ich hab das ja im Prinzip selber auch gerade mal so durchgespielt. Und stelle fest, eigentlich alles, also, ist jetzt nicht ohne Komplexität, das will ich jetzt gar nicht sagen, aber es ist nicht unbeherrschbar. Weil es im Prinzip so ein bisschen wie Jura auch eigentlich so ein programmierähnliches Environment ist.
Es gibt halt Regeln, die du einhalten musst.
Genau, es gibt Regeln, es gibt Ausnahmen von den Regeln und so weiter, wie jede schlechtere Programmiersprache, die irgendwie 20 Jahre lang vor sich hingepatcht wurde.
Und den Rest diskutierst du mit dem Finanzamt?
Ja, genau.
Das geht auch?
Wie im Compiler auch.
Im Prinzip kann man auch, sagen wir mal, allein für die eigene Existenz bereits schon mit einem sehr überschaubaren Aufwand eigentlich schon sehr gut hinkommen. Aber allein so dieses grundlegende Verständnis eines T-Kontos zum Beispiel.
Das brauchen die meisten ja überhaupt nicht. Für ihre Steuererklärung, ihre Buchhaltung.
Darum geht es mir jetzt nicht. Also dieses, brauche ich nicht für... das kann nicht die Erklärung für einen wahren Nerd sein. So geht man ja auch an die anderen Themen nicht ran. Das ist richtig. Eigentlich müsste sich auch hier so ein A, da versucht eine Blackbox, sich vor mir zu verstecken. Die mir dann auch noch finanziell schaden kann.
Auch Strafrecht?
Auch Strafrecht, also auf vielen Ebenen. Unter anderem halt Geld, Zeit, Aufwand, Nerv, Stress, Schweiß, Freiheit.
Also höhles, Freiheit.
Das ist ja Investment-Banking.
Das war aber auch die Steuererklärung das Problem.
Du weißt warum sie Al Capone irgendwie in den Knast gesteckt haben?
Steuerinterziehung. Also nicht mal wegen seinem Schmuggel, sondern wegen Steuererklärung. Damit haben sie halt gekriegt.
Ja, sag genau, das ist immer mein Argument.
Damit haben sie gekriegt, mit der Steuer.
Genau. Und wenn ihr schlimmer geglaubt habt, man könnte euch nichts nachweisen, die kriegen euch mit der Steuererklärung.
So siehts aus. Nee, es ist auch so, jeder mit Nördsel sagt so, mach doch eure Reisekosten abbrechen, da gibt es irgendwie Tagespauschalen. Da musst du nicht Steuern drauf zahlen. Ja, hier, guck mal, so ein Excel-Datei füllst du für jede Reise aus, steht unten ein Betrag, den ich bezahlen muss. Ist mir zu viel Aufwand. Also O-Ton von vielen Nörds, das ist mir zu viel Aufwand. Gut, dann kann ich auch nur sagen, dann tut es mir halt leid, aber dein Aufwand, den du irgendwie in eine obscure Programmiersprache steckst, den du nie wieder benutzen wirst, einfach nur weil es dich interessiert, der ist viel, viel höher gewesen, und dein Outcome davon war gleich null gewesen, aber hey, be my guest.
Genau, und ich finde, man müsste mal, also, so rum, es gibt genug Anlass, auch mal die Energie in diesen Research zu stecken, um das System zu verstehen. Und da gibt es halt so verschiedene Ebenen, es gibt so dieses Steuerrealität, erst mal abstrakt so, verstehen, was eigentlich von mir erwartet wird. Also ich hab ganz ehrlich nicht wirklich durchblickt, wie so die Interrelationships sind von diesen einzelnen Steuerbereichen, was das eigentlich genau betrifft, was man eigentlich wann, wie, warum, unter welchen Bedingungen erklären und anmelden und abschließen und abschreiben muss und so. Also allein die Terminologie ist sozusagen schon nicht da. Genau, ist eine Fremdsprache oder eine Promemiersprache. In gewisser Hinsicht ist es ja auch ein Code. Also es ist ja quasi eine Abstraktion der Gesellschaft auf Basis wirtschaftlicher und privatwirtschaftlicher Aktivität. Die versucht dich halt irgendwie von außen anhand von ein paar Rahmendaten abzutasten, um dann sozusagen eine Forderung zu erstellen, was du dieser Gesellschaft schuldest.
Oder von ihr zurückkriegst.
Genau.
Oder in eine andere Richtung. Und das Ding ist, man hat ja eigentlich keinen Opt-out. Also...
Ja doch, wenn du nicht selbstständig bist und noch nie ein Steuererklärung abgegeben hast, dann musst du auch nicht.
Wenn du noch nie einer abgegeben hast?
Und nicht selbstständig bist.
Ja.
Also nur abhängig beschäftigt der bist, du hast noch nie einen abgegeben, musst du keine abgeben.
Was ist denn, wenn du selbstständig bist und dann bist du nicht mehr selbstständig, dann fängst du wieder den normalen Job an?
Das ist egal, du hast angefangen mit Steuererklärung und musst abgeben. Wirklich?
Du kommst dann nie wieder raus?
Nö.
Bis an deinem Lebensende.
Aber soweit ich weiß, bis an deinem Lebensende.
Man kann nicht mit denen diskutieren.
Dann kannst du mit denen diskutieren irgendwann.
Du kannst ohnehin eine Menge mit denen diskutieren.
Die sind auch sehr empfindlich für Diskussionen. Und mal ganz ehrlich, die meisten Angestellten, wenn die eine Steuererklärung machen, kriegen sie was wieder.
Ja, also es lohnt sich sowieso immer, sie weiterhin zu machen.
Ich hab sogar als Studi Steuererklärung gemacht, da habt ihr dann irgendwie Geld wiederbekommen. In größeren Mengen.
Ja, ich kenn das auch.
Und es war kein anderes. Auf diesen Bögen steht drauf, was der Bogen sagt, was er von mir will. So, trage hier die Daten deines Lohnsteuernachweises ein. Trage, fällt 22B des Nachweises, da kriegt man drauf A, 22B, und schreibt die Zahl da rein. Es ist total einfach, es ist wirklich nur Copy-Pasten eigentlich.
Wo wir gerade mal sind, darf mich mal darüber beschweren, dass wir auch heute in 2017 immer noch die Situation haben, dass du da Sachen eintragen musst, die der Staat längst weiß. Geht mir total auf den Sack. Und sie begründen es dann immer, finde ich es total geil, sie begründen es immer mit Datenschutz. Das heißt, sie beschützen meine Daten vor mir oder vor sich selber. Die Daten, die sie eh schon haben.
Vor zentraler Speicherung.
Also ich finde es halt einfach absurd. Diese ganzen Krankenkassennummern und so weiter und fort, das ist eh alle Zentrale irgendwo hier speichert. Und da können sie, sie rufen immer dann den Datenschutz auf, wenn es darum geht, mich als Bürger zu ärgern.
Ja, das wird jetzt aber einfacher. Ab diesem Jahr wurde angefangen auszurollen, dass alles, was elektronisch bemittelt worden ist, von Krankenkassen, von Arbeitgeber, etc. per P, dass du mit LZ dich einlöchst, auf den Knopf drückst, mach dir einen Vorschlag für eine Steuererklärung, du sagst Ja oder Nein und fertig. Aufgrund der elektronisch bemittelten Daten.
Immer noch meh. Die können die Sachen sich wirklich selber abholen. Ich muss nicht immer Träger sein, egal ob per Copy und Paste oder sonst und was zwischen einzelnen staatlichen Demistatlichen Initiationen. Ja, aber trotzdem. Ich find's halt sehr lästig. Ich möchte jetzt nicht das schwedische System propagieren für uns, weil da sind wir einfach als Land mit einer Stasi und mit einer Gestapo in unserem historischen Bäcker. Ganz schwierig. Aber in Schweden hast du deine Steuernummer und jede Firma, die irgendwas mit dir macht oder jede Krankenhasse bucht alles auf diese Nummer. Die haben einfach einen großen Daten-Eimer. Wenn denen übrigens mal einer aufmacht, wird es auch lustig.
Und die öffentliche Steuererklärung.
Ja klar. Ich hatte das schon mal mitgebracht. Es gibt ja so regelmäßig ein, zwei Mal im Monat diese Zeitungsseiten, wo dann die Bachelor der jeweiligen Region aufgelistet werden und zwar nach Einkommen sortiert. Aber egal. Diese Verhältnisse, wie gesagt, da sind wir als Volk nicht geeignet für. Aufgrund unserer Vergangenheit. Aber trotzdem, ich finde schon, dass diese T-Notärten hast du auch bei allen möglichen anderen staatlichen Sachen. Wenn es nur um welche Grundstückssachen geht oder dass die nicht mit sich selber reden und dass du dann gezwungen bist als Bürger Daten von A nach B zu tragen. Was ich echt lästig finde. Sorry, ich wollte nur mal einfügen, dass mich das ärgert.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich finde es lohnt sich in den meisten Fällen. Weil dann auch noch so etwas wie Wegepauschalen und der ganze Kran dazukommt. Also wenn man irgendwie einen Weg zur Arbeit hat.
Das lohnt sich alles. Genau, aber ich finde ja, es lohnt sich ja noch was anderes. Wenn man jetzt einfach mal so rein aus dieser ich versuche das zu verstehen und also das ist ja, man rüstet sich ja geradezu auf. Ich meine gerade so der Hacker-Approach mit das System und die Gesellschaft verstehen und dann irgendwie sozusagen seine Inner Workings entdecken und dann irgendwie so dann vielleicht auch die möglichen Exploits daraus zu gewinnen. Gut, das besteuert dann immer so ein Ding.
Ach, da könnt ich Geschichten erzählen.
Ja, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Darauf wollte ich aber jetzt nicht unbedingt hinaus. Also einfach nur jetzt mal so auch als Motivation. So, dass man das sozusagen einfach mal so weit angeht, dass man denkt, okay. Das ist natürlich die Frage, wie lernt man das am besten? Weil so Mannensteuererklärung gibt es halt einerseits in Massen. Also das Netz ist voll mit Steuertipps und hier, und Rechnungswesen, Erklärungsblah, voll mit Werbung. Gibt es denn ein Standardwerk?
Es gibt ein Standardwerk, dessen Name ich gerade nicht weiß. Das hab ich damals in der Bankausbildung gehabt, wo wir dann auch T-Konten gemalt haben, also so richtig auf dem Papier angefangen mit der Handschreiben. So, und dann kriegt man langsam ein Gefühl für soll und haben und für eine Bilanz und aktiv für eine passive Seite und den ganzen Kram. Lenden wie eine Ehe, also Einnahmenüberschussrechnung aufgebaut, das sind jetzt zwei verschiedene Dinge auch. Und dann, ja, lenkt man sich halt von der Pike auf. Man wird erstmal richtig Konten bewuchen. Und dann geht es weiter so, was für Konten gibt es eigentlich, was ist ein Standard-Konten-Rahmen, brauche ich den überhaupt? Es gibt nicht viele Leute, die brauchen sowas überhaupt nicht. All diese Dinge. Und da gibt es ein Buch, das kann ich nachher noch raussuchen, und dann können wir noch nicht schon was reinschmeißen, weil ich gerade den Namen vergessen habe.
Von dem Herrn zum Thema Buchführung oder was?
Ja, da gibt es Standard-Werke, die man da benutzen kann. Ihr müsst ihn noch mal raussuchen, ich hab's gerade vergessen, wie es heißt. Aber ich hatte da so ein paar schöne in der Bank.
Das ist aber ein Standardwerk, da kommt so einiges hoch.
Ja, und dann, das ist, wie soll ich sagen?
Also Standardwerk zum Thema Buchhaltung oder?
Ja, was Buchführung betrifft eigentlich.
Buchführung.
Ja, und Buchführung ist ja quasi auch Buchhaltung. Genau, und da gibt es für Balanciere ein anderes Standardwerk als für Einnahme- und Überschussrechnung, aber ja, da gibt es verschiedene Bücher zu, die man dann lesen kann. Nein, es gibt keine Online-Kurse. Und also ansonsten, es gibt so, wenn man einfach nur mal versteht, wie die Steuererklärung funktioniert, es gibt von der akademischen Steuergemeinschaft gibt es PDFs, wo genau der Workflow, also der Algorithmus draufsteht, wie sich was berechnet für die Steuererklärung. Da kann man Zahlen reinschreiben, da steht, was man plus und minus rechnen muss, wo man es nachher in die Steuererklärung eintragen müsste. Da steht nachher da, welcher Betrag versteuert werden muss, wirklich. Akademische? Ja, hau mal auch in die Show notes nachher rein, ich suche das noch mal raus. Und das ist schon ziemlich nice, weil dann hat man auch ein Gefühl dafür, wie diese Felder entstehen und wie die Berechnung entsteht.
Ja gut, aber das Problem mit dieser Berechnung ist, dass man überhaupt erst mal wissen muss, was man in diese Felder irgendwie einträgt.
Ja, das steht da ja drauf, auf diesem PDF, das man da ausdrucken kann. Da steht es ja ordentlich drauf, da steht wirklich ganz detailliert drauf, was man da eintragen kann. Mit Erklärung nachher hast du dann deine Zahlen für die Steuererklärung, in welches Feld es jeweils rein muss. Das geht schon klar. Das kann man schon mal machen. Das ist kein großes Drama. Dann kriegt man langsam so ein Gefühl dafür auch, wie man halt auch für andere Dinge, wenn man am Rechner arbeitet, ein Gefühl bekommt, wie das so funktionieren muss, sein sollte. Und dann wird man auch immer besser.
Ich hab ja hier in den letzten Sendungen schon mal ein bisschen in dem Bereich erzählt. Wenn man jetzt, ich wollte nochmal so ein anderes Tool nochmal ansprechen. Und wir sollten vielleicht nochmal kurz auch zu diesen Spendenplattformen dann auch nochmal kurz kommen oder vielleicht fangen wir damit mal an. Ich weiß gar nicht so genau.
Wir könnten erst auf Spendenplattformen abfrühstücken und dann zu dem Tool kommen. Dann ist das Finanzthema wieder erledigt, weißt du?
Ja, das stimmt.
Dann wär's halt durch.
Schade, eingeschlafen.
Die werden auch wieder wach irgendwann.
Hast du keine Reuspertaste?
Lord Vader.
Wenn man einschläft, dann vergisst man ja, die zu drücken, weißt du?
Ja, das ist richtig.
Ich hatte gestern, vorgestern, hab ich irgendwie mal so einen Tweet abgesetzt, mal ein paar Grafiken veröffentlicht, die ich selber gemalt hatte. Mit einem Pinsel, genau. War ein sehr ungewöhnlicher Tweet. Ich glaub, das hab ich in all meiner ganzen Twitter-Zeit noch nie getan, so etwas. So, dass ich irgendwie so Zahlen irgendwo eingetragen habe, Kurven generiert habe und dann so diese Grafiken gepostet hab. Ist ja eigentlich immer so.
Ich hab das doch mal mit der Bahnencard gemacht, ab an, die sich lohnt und so.
Ja, genau.
Aber hey, du hast Numbers mal wieder benutzt.
Ich benutze auf einem Meter Numbers.
Das heißt, du hast das doch gar nicht selber gemalt. Du hast Numbers malen lassen.
Naja, das ist ja das, was ich heute mit malen. Oder? Malst du anders? Genau, was hab ich gemacht?
Ich mal mit Grafana.
Ich hab mal... Also mich hat dieses... Ich hab letztes Mal ja auch schon ansatzweise darüber berichtet. Knüpft jetzt im Prinzip daran an. Ich guck mir halt gerade an, was eigentlich so diese Finanzrealität ist bei diesen ganzen Finanzverteilungsplattformen. Und Flatter kenn ich ja nun schon von Anfang an. Seit 2010, gibt's ja jetzt irgendwie fast 7 Jahre. Wir sind alt. Und...
Gibt's das denn noch? Weil Flatter wird ja da und da immer tot gesagt. Aber die leben ja dann gelegentlich länger. Aber ist das... Holgi hat jetzt irgendwas geschrieben, dass wir in den ganzen Flatter-Zahlen alle auf Null gegangen sind in diesen komischen Kästchen auf seiner Webseite. Oder irgendwas, schrieb er da einen Tweet? Aber die gibt's noch.
Flatter gibt's noch. Flatter hat teils ohne in den letzten zwei Jahren schlecht performt, was so ihre ganze Öffentlichkeitsarbeit und so weiter betrifft. Die Webseite, außer einem einzigen Relaunch und der Umstellung des Zahlungssystems, hat relativ wenig Liebe erfahren. Und das ist, sagen wir mal, etwas, was nicht unbedingt guttut, honoriert wird. Man will eigentlich, dass so eine Plattform irgendwie auch immer irgendwas, sich irgendwie anpasst und irgendwie mitmorpht und auch Antworten findet auf neue Herausforderungen. Das hat definitiv dem Laden gefehlt. Der Grund war schlicht, die haben halt einfach bis dahin mit ihrem Modell nicht genug Geld verdient, um sich irgendwie weiter ihr 15 Mann Start-up-Team zu finanzieren. Und das ist dann halt irgendwie auf zwei Leute runtergebrochen, die dann auch noch so ein privates Leben hatten und vielleicht im Prinzip jahrelang seit, sozusagen nebenbei fortgeführt haben.
Was ist jetzt in demselben Status wie diese Twitter-Alternative, die wir da mal hatten? Ich weiß, aber die haben ja auch dennoch, naja wir hören jetzt mal oft damit, ich weiß, ich hab auch so einen Account da gehabt. Aber die haben ja auch gesagt, dann lassen wir jetzt noch nebenher laufen und dann haben sie auch irgendwann den Hahn abgedreht. Siehst du das jetzt für Flatter auch?
Flatter ist ja jetzt gerade gekauft worden von EO. Ja, von EO, von dieser AdBlock Plus Spule hier aus Berlin. Offiziell aus Köln, aber die haben halt hier ihr Büro, glaube ich, im Wesentlichen schon noch hier. Weiß nicht so genau, auf jeden Fall weiß auch nicht, wie lange dieses Investment jetzt trägt. Aber es gibt jetzt sozusagen Geld für Development auf einmal wieder, merkt man auch. Es gibt jetzt neue Dinge bei Flatter. Das ist jetzt alles noch Trippelschritte, aber nachdem wir so lange nichts mehr gesehen haben, ist da was zu tun. Ich habe ja anders darüber nachgedacht, weil viele machen jetzt auch die Patreon, jetzt gibt es auch noch Steady und sicherlich gibt es demnächst noch ein paar andere Ideen, weil im Prinzip hat ja diese Idee, dass Regular Crowd Supported Funding hat sich ja gezeigt, dass das eine extrem sinnvolle Sache ist, dass es auch im Falle von Patreon auch ziemlich erfolgreich ist. Die setzen da, weiß ich nicht, wie viel Geld um, aber durch diesen ganzen YouTube-Sock hat das einfach eine Menge Aufmerksamkeit.
Sind dann auch endlich mal die Amis aufgesprungen, die ja vorher immer so, hey, Flatter.
Ja genau. Und mich hat, so und da ich halt auch immer so gefragt wurde, naja, warum benutzt du das nicht, so wurde doch bei Flatter irgendwie von Anfang an so dabei war, warum Milliarden gemacht, warum machst du denn jetzt genau einen Milliarden verdient habe, warum, warum ich denn diese anderen Plattformen nicht mache, naja, das war halt bei mir eine Mischung aus mehreren Dingen. Also erstens hat mich das schon mal gestört, dass diese Plattformen so unglaublich viel von einem verlangt haben, dass man nämlich einerseits, du musst dann irgendwie deinen ganzen Content irgendwie veröffentlichen, regelmäßig posten, du musst sozusagen deren Webseite als Outlet benutzen, um darauf hinzuweisen und wirst halt dazu auch gezwungen. Sowas mag ich immer schon mal generell nicht. Da können Leute natürlich sagen, ja ach so, egal, dann postest du das dann. Ich meine, klar, hätte ich da irgendwo mein RSS-Feed reinhängen können, so, fertig aus, dann wäre das vielleicht noch gegangen, aber es war halt dann wieder Extra Manual Work. Dann bin ich auch kein Freund von diesen ganzen Perks-Geschichten, zumal das auch finanztechnisch schnell in die Bredouille bringen kann, wenn du auf einmal anfängst, irgendwelche Kaffeetassen zu verteilen, weißt du, so als Spenden-Dings, dann bist du halt auf einmal Warenhändler und Pipapo, da kommst du dann so als gegenüber dem Finanzamt halt mal ganz schnell in neue Probleme.
Nicht gegenüber denen, da kommen auch diverse andere Vögel denn auf dich zu, in Deutschland. Wenn du plötzlich anfängst, Waren zu verticken, dann kommen irgendwelche Gewerbe-Dinger dafür, dann wirst du von irgendeiner Industrie- und Handelskammer zwangsvereinnahmt. Der ganze Zoo, der da dran hängt.
Macht ja alles auch keinen Spaß.
Die ganzen Speck-Marken.
Aber meine Kernkritik war und ist eigentlich auch immer noch immer so diese Frage, was ist denn eigentlich eure Dienstleistung überhaupt? Geld verteilen. Was tut ihr für mich, was ich nicht für mich selbst auch tun kann, mit weniger Arbeit?
Sie sammeln Geld ein und geben dir das dann?
Ja, das kann ich auch.
Ein Teil davon. Aber selbst machen, da kriegen sie halt keins ab. Das ist gemein von dir.
Es gibt ja noch andere Aspekte. Bei deinen Tweets hast du zum Beispiel auch PayPal mit drauf gehabt. Und das erste, was mir einfiel, dass ich dir zum Beispiel ein für alle Mal deinen PayPal-Kanal dicht mache, indem ich solche Dinge sage wie Kuba ist geil. So, jetzt ist das Ding für dich abgefahren. Dann hört jetzt jemand von PayPal und deswegen bist du jetzt auf der Sperrliste.
Kuba geht es jetzt gerade richtig ab mit den USA und so.
Der große Führer. Nee, aber ernsthaft, gerade Kuba gab ja so diverse Läden, die denen PayPal-Konten gesperrt wurden, wie jemanden kannte, der kubanische Zigarren verkauft hat.
Nein, die haben ein Bargo gebrochen gehabt. Das war das Problem.
Ist egal. PayPal sperrt gerne Konten, wie sie gerade lustig sind. Irgendwelche Gründe fallen denen immer mit ein. Das ist auch ein Faktor, den man mit dazu nehmen muss, nicht nur wie viel bleibt von der Kohle übrig und wie gut funktionieren die, sondern auch wie zuverlässig geben die mir auch mal eine Patte. Und da ist halt PayPal relativ weit unten. Richtig.
Das ist jetzt nochmal eine politische oder Zuverlässigkeitsbewertung, die kann man jetzt auch noch mit reinmachen, aber ich wollte jetzt einfach mal nur von der eigentlichen Dienstleistung dieser Anbieter her, weil wenn ein Patreon sagt, ich tu dir Gutes, dann ist halt meine Frage ja, was denn eigentlich? Und dann so, naja, wir leiten dir ja die Spenden zu. Von wem? Das ist jetzt mein innerer Dialog mit Patreon. Patreon sitzt im Raum.
Von den Leuten.
Ja, genau, das Geld kommt von den Leuten. Wie kommen die Leute zu dir? Na ja, du sagst denen, dass sie über uns Geld geben. Ja, aber dann waren sie doch schon bei mir. Warum soll ich sie denn dann zu dir schicken?
Ja, weil ich dann Geld verdienen kann.
So darfst du ja nicht antworten, da hast du ja schon verloren. Ja, aber dann kommt so ein Trump-Moment.
Ja, aber dann macht Patreon das, dass du halt irgendwie eine Plattform bietest, wo du halt noch zusätzlich... Ja, dann wird von Skalierungsfaktoren gesprochen. Wo du halt Content nur für Patreon-Abonnements, also die bei Patreon über Summe X spenden, dann Content nur für die verfügbar machst zum Beispiel, die dann auf sich einloggen müssen, auf der Plattform selbst, zum Beispiel eine Podcast-Folge hören können, die halt nur Patreon-Unterstützer bekommen. Und sonst niemand. Das war schon ein Superlevel, ich glaube.
Man macht also schon wieder extra Content für Patreon. Was machen die dann eigentlich selber extra für sich?
Was hat Patreon eigentlich jemals für uns getan?
Das ist das, womit sie denken, dass sie es bewerben könnten. Wo sie sagen, wir bieten euch die Infrastruktur, wenn Leute X Euro geben, also ab einem bestimmten Summe, zum Beispiel 10 Euro, dass sie dann mehr Content von euch bekommen können, ohne dass ihr technisch bei eurem Blog oder eurem Seite irgendwas bauen müsst. Wir haben das ja für euch.
Das ist aber nicht netzneutral.
Also das ist, glaube ich, die Argumentation, wo sie glauben, dass sie diese Summe, die sie nehmen, nehmen können, dass es das halt wert sei.
Genau. Und das ist halt so eine Abwägungssache. Also ist mir dieser Netzwerkeffekt oder eine theoretische Abofunktion, die ja dann auch das Problem hat, wenn ich jetzt mal irgendein Content darauf hin, ich weiß nicht genau, welche technischen Mittel, die einem unter Umständen bereitstellen, um sowas einfach zu machen. Ja, denke ich mir auch, vor allem will ich mich dann davon abhängig machen als Kanal und alle anderen irgendwie ausschließen? Nee, will ich eigentlich auch nicht. Also gerade aus Deutschland heraus. Und davon abgesehen, ich will überhaupt keinen exklusiven Content machen.
Genau, dann ist auch Patreon nix für dich.
Naja, es gibt ja auch Leute, die keinen exklusiven Content machen, die da sind und der Meinung sind, das würde ihnen jetzt helfen.
Ja, weil die Angst haben irgendwie, glaube ich, dass sie Geld auf ihr Konto überwiesen bekommen könnten. Also es wirkt immer so auf mich aus, die Angst haben, dass sie Geld auf ihrem Konto von Leuten bekommen könnten. Direkt.
Na gut, dann kommt halt so das Argument der Einfachheit und da kann ich ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch mitgehen, weil das dann sozusagen, ja, wir rechnen alles für dich aus und am Ende kriegst du nur noch Geld und über mehr Sachen musst du irgendwie nicht nachdenken.
Wenn's doch so wäre.
Ja gut, das ist ja auch, sagen wir mal, durchaus ein Versprechen, was auch Flatter in gewisser Hinsicht mit sich gebracht hat, was ich an der Stelle ja auch, wo ich auch mitgegangen bin. Die Frage ist halt nur, wie viel Geld geht denn jetzt eigentlich wirklich flöten? Also was kostet mich denn irgendwie diese Dienstleistung tatsächlich?
Ja, ein Geld.
Und in welchem Maße ist denn das halt auch legitim? Und jetzt bin ich gerade dabei, aber ich werde das jetzt derzeit noch nicht im Detail veröffentlichen, aber nur mal so als Zwischenstand. Ich versuche gerade mal herauszufinden, wie es eigentlich genau ist. Die Antwort ist jetzt complicated. Das ist nicht alles ganz einfach zu beantworten. Aber ich denke, ich habe jetzt gerade so ein relativ gutes Gefühl dafür, wie eigentlich diese Bezahlkaskaden bei den einzelnen Dienstleistern so funktionieren. Und das Erstaunliche ist, dass einfach der Malus, den man sozusagen oft da zahlt, der ist schon echt ganz schön groß.
Ja, komm, schnell mal die Zahlen vor, Tim.
Ja, also nur so als Größenordnung. Ich erkläre auch gleich nochmal, die Frage ist, aus welcher Perspektive berichte ich das zunächst einmal. Vielleicht erstmal so...
Na ja, ich will dir Geld geben, Tim. Ich will dir 10 Euro geben.
Ja, genau. Also es geht ja jetzt nicht nur um mich, sondern sagen wir mal jemand, der jetzt irgendwie nicht umsatzsteuerpflichtig ist.
Was die meisten kleinen Creator draußen sein sollten.
Genau, oder Kleinunternehmer und so weiter. Man muss halt keine Umsatzsteuer abführen, deswegen kommt das alles irgendwie nicht mit rein. Und da hat man dann heutzutage... Dann hängt es auch so ein bisschen davon ab, was hat man selber für so ein Konto? Also wenn man jetzt hier ein normales Bankkonto hat, zahlt man da Transaktionen auf Überweisung. Das ist nämlich ganz schön teuer geworden. Ich hab ja noch so ein Konto von früher, wo ich irgendwie gar nichts bezahle. Das ist so Gnade der frühen Geburt. Ich hab da halt irgendwie so ein Konto seit Ewigkeiten. Das hat irgendwie ganz ordentliche Konditionen. Man kann sich allerdings auch so Business-Kontos irgendwie zusammen kaufen, die relativ hohe Monatsgebühren haben, wo dann irgendwie auch keine Transaktionskosten mehr sind.
Man will ja auch immer ein Konto haben, wo keine Abbuchungen darauf möglich sind und so weiter.
Das ist nochmal so ein anderes Feature, was man gerne hätte, aber you can't have it all. Das gibt es sicherlich jetzt auch, aber es ist auch nochmal so ein Aspekt. Mir geht es jetzt erstmal nur um Gebühren, unabhängig von dem sonstigen Feature Set. Aber wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen, dass die Banktransaktionskosten, die normalen SEPA-Transaktionskosten, niedrig sind, kann man einfach mal sagen, nichts schlägt SEPA-Direct-Überweisung. Also Spenden, die irgendwie hier, nochmal dazu, dass jetzt eine rein deutsche Perspektive, die ich jetzt hier in meinem Video habe, die ich jetzt hier in meinem Video habe, die ich jetzt hier in meinem Video habe, die gilt nicht global und die gilt auch nicht europaweit. Andere Länder, andere Sitten, andere Riten. Man könnte vielleicht sagen, es ist so ein bisschen so eine EU-Brille vielleicht. Es gilt im Wesentlichen für EU. Naja, also wenn man jetzt quasi so privat ist, dann kann man davon ausgehen, dass man vielleicht sowas wie 95 bis 100% von so einer Spende im Prinzip behalten kann. Was schon eine ganz ordentliche Quote ist. So, finde ich irgendwie ganz ordentlich. Dieses PayPal hat das Problem, dass es halt, aber das gilt im Prinzip bei SEPA jetzt eben teilweise auch, wenn man sich so ein Konto eingetreten hat mit hohen Transaktionsgebühren, dann verhält sich das ähnlich, dass halt kleine Spenden dann auf einmal extrem teuer werden. Also wenn man zum Beispiel, manche von euch machen das ja, ich finde das ja ganz herzlich, aber denkt mal echt drüber nach, wenn man so ein Euro mit Paypal spendet, das Thema ist, da bleibt jetzt mal, wenn keine Umsatzsteuer im Spiel ist, bleibt irgendwie 63% über. Also da wird ein Drittel einfach mal weggehauen. Das bleibt halt einfach alles nur bei Paypal für eine Transaktionsdienstleistung, die sicherlich nicht diesen Wert haben sollte. Also es kostet sie ja nicht mehr Aufwand, 10 Euro zu transportieren. Aber nur weil der Betrag klein ist, verdienen sie halt viel dran.
Sie hat die Grundtransaktionsgebühr schon neben von 30 Cent, glaube ich.
Eigentlich wäre es schlau, wenn sie es andersrum machen. Alles unter 10 Euro, ist jetzt mal egal, da wollen wir uns nicht kümmern. Aber ab über 10 Euro, da könnte man mal 30 Cent nehmen. Die fallen dann auch gar nicht mehr so auf, dann tut es nicht so weh, aber bei einem Euro ist es natürlich bescheuert.
Natürlich. Ich kann ja verstehen, dass sie so ein bisschen eine Firewall haben, damit sie nicht einfach nur noch so ein Bitch-Hubser werden.
Damit sie nicht zum Micropayment werden, weil sie alles mit protokollieren müssen, dass dann die Platte voll läuft.
Das sind ja Egeldinstituten, das sind ja eine zulassene Bank.
Ja, ich meine, wenn das irgendwie kostenlos wäre, dann würdest du das ja als Payment-Firehouse irgendwie benutzen. Und dann kann ich auch verstehen, dass das dann eben schnell überlastet ist.
Und dann jemand als VPN-Tunnel. IP over Paypal.
So, also das ist das Problem mit Paypal. Also Paypal wird erst dann so richtig interessant, so ab frühestens 15 Euro irgendwie. Da macht das irgendwie Sinn. Aber ansonsten ist einfach der Verlust extrem groß. Und jetzt in meinem Fall, wo ich halt auch noch irgendwie Umsatzsteuer anrechnen muss, wird es halt auch schnell nochmal ein bisschen krasser. Also da hast du halt dann mal schnell Verluste.
Dann kriegst du doch auch wieder die Umsatzsteuer.
Nein, nein.
Wenn du dich bemühst, richtig.
Das ist noch ein Lahn. Die sind hoffentlich noch höher als deine Ausgaben.
Also hoffentlich.
Ja, aber dann muss er zumindest nicht die komplette Umsatzsteuer wieder abgeben, sondern nur einen Teil.
Nein, er muss erst mal ab, man kann es aufrechnen. Aber abführen muss er trotzdem. Umsatzsteuer zahlen muss er halt irgendwann mal. Und das wirst du dann...
Genau. Klar, das kann man jetzt auch nicht einfach so 1 zu 1 rechnen. Das wollte ich damit sagen. Aber es geht halt davon ab. So. Bei den Plattformen spielt das auf einmal auf jeden Fall auf eine ganz andere Rolle. Jetzt hab ich mir halt mal Flatter, Steady und Patreon irgendwie genauer angeschaut. Und da ist es dann halt so, dass die eben auch einfach sehr unterschiedliche rechtliche Konstrukte haben. Also... Und das Lustige ist, dass Flatter da halt irgendwie die Einzigen sind, die das irgendwie richtig machen, hab ich so den Eindruck. Also, das sind die Einzigen, die auch wirklich als Zahlungsdienstleister registriert sind. Und deswegen nicht so merkwürdige Fuck-ups machen. Mit irgendwelchen gedachten Konstruktionen, wie das Customer-Relationship ist, weil die halt nicht wirklich Zahlungen weiterleiten. Was ja eigentlich das ist, was sie ja auf ihre Webseite schreiben. Wir leiten die Zahlungen an dich weiter. Aber tatsächlich...
Sind das zwei Verträge, die da geschlossen werden.
Genau, ist sozusagen die eigentliche Einzahlung vollkommen entkoppelt von der Auszahlung. Das ist einfach so furchtbar und transparent, was dann halt auch darin passiert. Weil einfach da eine Megakaskade von Dingen passiert. Also bei Flatter ist es halt zum Beispiel so, dass du eigentlich nur... zahlst halt irgendwie Geld rein, dann geht da dir ein Servicegebühr von ab, das sind 10%, und ab da ist das dann deine Einnahme. Wenn du halt Umsatzsteuer hast, geht die davon eben noch ab. Aber das ist sozusagen die volle Geschichte. Du hast sozusagen so einen direkten Kanal. Und das führt dann halt dazu, dass du eben bei Flatter zwar jetzt nicht unbedingt an die Summen rankommst, die du jetzt sonst hast, also bei direkter Zahlung, aber halt irgendwie so bei 90% landest. Erstmal so im Normalfall. Derzeit übrigens auch noch bei 100%, weil sie diese ganzen Fees derzeit irgendwie nicht haben. Aber das wird sich bestimmt demnächst natürlich auch wieder ändern. Wenn du dir jetzt zum Beispiel Steady und Patreon, die ein relativ vergleichbares Modell haben, anschaust, dann hast du halt quasi von den Einnahmen auch wieder diese Plattformgebühren. Aber vor allem dann eben noch mal so geht eben die Umsatzsteuer da erst mal von runter. Und das ist irgendwie ganz haarig, weil das bedeutet, dass quasi so im Regelfall, weil das hängt ja immer noch davon ab, woher kommt das Geld.
Aus welchem Land?
Genau so, also aus welchem Land. Weil dann immer so die Landesumsatzsteuer herangezogen wird. Also wenn dann jemand in Ungarn spendet, dann sind halt sozusagen schon mal 27 Prozent schon mal gone. Und zwar so richtig komplett gone. Die kriegst du halt nicht wieder. Weil die nicht korrelieren mit deiner Umsatzsteuer, die du vielleicht normalerweise zahlst, weil du ja sozusagen entkoppelt bist. Das läuft halt einfach einmal durch so eine Blackbox durch, aber bevor es bei dir rauskugelt, ist halt das einfach schon mal komplett verloren gegangen. Und das ist sozusagen auch das, was da so furchtbar intransparent ist. Ja, das ist ein echtes Problem. Also man kann da eigentlich nur mithalten mit Flatter, indem man sich halt auch mal wirklich als richtiger Zahlungsdienstleister aufstellt, aber das macht irgendwie keiner, auch Patreon irgendwie nicht.
Ja, das ist sehr ärgerlich eigentlich, weil ich hab das auch erst jetzt im Rahmen deiner Recherche mir gedacht, was die machen und das ist irgendwie völlig abstrus und absurd, weil den Aufwand, den sie jetzt treiben, den könnten sie weniger haben und dafür einen anderen Aufwand machen, der mehr Geld durchreichen könnte an die Leute, an die Creator. Und das ist halt, ja, und das ist halt irgendwie auch die Modelle, dass der Creator einen Lizenzvertrag abschließt mit Patreon beziehungsweise Steady, dass die Abos verkaufen dürfen von deinem Content. Das ist ja schon einfach so irgendwie eine Konstruktion, die ich echt mies finde, einfach, weil irgendwie Abos verkaufen, ist ja dann auch eine Pflicht irgendwann drin, also bei einem Abo steht ja irgendwie eine Lieferpflicht an Dingen, das ist so gar nicht genau rechtlich geklärt bei denen, dass du eigentlich beim Abodomor eine Lieferpflicht hast, und Abodomor ja auch heißt, es sind x Ausgaben im Jahr oder in einem Zeitraum y, was halt ein Abodomor auch ausmacht.
Wo ist denn mein Blogpost?
Ja, den ich bezahlt habe. Wo ist denn meine Datenschleid-App? Aber das kommt auch gar nicht richtig klar, also auch wenn ich auf die Steady-Seite drauf gehe, das steht nicht wirklich ersichtlich da, was sie da eigentlich tun. Neben mir Abonnements verkaufen, was irgendwie als Unterstützung für Creator verkauft wird und vom Creator irgendwie einen Lizenzvertrag schließen, dass die den Kram weiter verkaufen dürfen. Und dann fangen wir noch gar nicht damit an, dass vielleicht in meinem Blogpost irgendwelche Creative-Comments-Bilder drin sind, die ich nicht kommerziell nutzen darf. Und dann verkaufe ich ein Abo, wo ein Creative-Comments-Bild drin ist, dass das nicht kommerziell genutzt werden darf. Das sind auch gar nicht drin. Das sind auch mal Probleme, die ja auftreten, meiner Meinung nach.
Stimmt.
Also das ist alles irgendwie nicht klug, was die da machen.
Ja gut, bei Steady ist es zumindest so, dass alles im Wesentlichen auf EU-optimiert ist. Und innerhalb dieses Rahmes bleibt, am Ende auch nicht die Umsatzsteuer, die am Anfang gezogen werden muss, die ist dann halt auch dann weg. Bei Patreon wird es dann nochmal so ein bisschen wilder. Weil wenn du nämlich jetzt irgendwie aus Deutschland über Patreon etwas an Deutschland spendest, dann geht das ja, also mit Einschränkung muss ich sagen, ich hab jetzt nicht so, kenne ich alle aktuellen Trends und Entwicklungen, die sich bei Patreon unter Umständen noch entwickelt haben, aber mein letzter Stand ist, dass man am Wesentlichen eigentlich nur über PayPal reinschieben kann. Und das bedeutet, wenn ich halt jetzt sozusagen schon mal Geld per PayPal dahin zahle, verpufft schon mal Geld, verpufft schon mal so die erste Gebühr. Vor allem bei kleinen Beträgen, wie ich das gerade eben schon gesagt habe, ist das irgendwie gerade mal nicht ganz wenig. Dann kommt halt irgendwie diese Spende an. Und vor kurzem haben die dann halt umgestellt. Seit Anfang 2015 gibt es nämlich so eine neue Regelung in der EU. Dieser, wie heißt das nochmal gleich?
Moss, Mini, One Stop Solution, Shop Solution. Also das ist halt der Effekt, dass bei digitalen Gütern der Steuersatz von deinem Land, wo du sitzt, als Kunde zu bezahlen ist. Also z.B. dann halt in Österreich 20%, bei uns in Deutschland 19%, in anderen Ländern bist du, ich glaube, 27% hoch.
Also das passiert ja genauso, muss man dazu sagen.
Genau, die machen das auch.
Nichts Spezifisches, das ist halt dieses Ziehen, dieser Umsatzschwein, die geht auch schon mal irgendwie genauso wieder weg. Nur, dass du halt bei Patreon alles in US-Dollar machst. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo du dann deine Euros über einen Teil schickst, hast du dann schon mal ein schönes erste Mal Währungsverluste. Die kann ich jetzt prozentual nicht so richtig greifen. Da müsste man nochmal so ein paar Tests machen, mit bisschen Geld hin und her schicken, hab keine Ahnung, wie das da gerade ist, aber das läuft jetzt nicht zu unseren Gunsten.
Das ist auf gar keinen Fall. Das heißt, Transaktionsgebühr plus Währungsverlust plus pauschale Umsatzsteuer, die schon mal abgezogen wird.
Dann ist das Geld überhaupt erstmal bei Patreon.
In US-Dollar.
In US-Dollar, genau. Dann gehen davon die Plattformgebühren ab, sind im Endeffekt nur 5%. Wie groß diese Gebühren für Zahlungsübertragung ist, ist schwer zu urteilen. Aber dann kommt überhaupt erstmal ein einiger Nettobetrag raus. Der muss dir dann ja auch wieder zurück überwiesen werden. Von US-Dollar in Euro, Wiederwährungsverluste, 2%, die noch mal an der Stelle in der Regel abgehen, auch wenn das gedeckt ist bei 20 Dollar. Wenn du sehr viel Geld verdienst, dann macht das unter Umständen nicht mehr so viel aus. Aber 2% sind irgendwie 2%, wobei das mit der Deckelung irgendwie auch neu ist.
Das ist auch nicht richtig verstanden.
Ich hatte das ja auch eine Weile, dass ich die Flatterkohle auch nur darüber holen konnte. Und da habe ich von der Deckelung irgendwie nichts gemerkt. Das war furchtbar teuer alles. Dann landet man auch bei 70%. Das ist sozusagen die Realität. Das ist geschätzt, klar. Es ist sehr schwer, die tatsächlichen Gebühren, die da anfallen. Das hängt dann immer von den Summen ab. Und wie viele Spender von denen, die dir was spenden, spenden auch noch andere, sodass diese Zahlungsgebühren geteilt werden können. Aber ich würde mal so sagen, Pi mal Daumen, 70 Prozent, das ist irgendwie realistisch. Ja, und das ist so die Situation. Also es gibt ein unklare rechtliches Ding, was das sozusagen für einen Anbieter für eine Auswirkung hat.
Ja, also gerade wenn man halt Fremdmaterialien benutzt.
Genau, also was genau ist eigentlich die Dienstleistung, das ist natürlich bei Patreon alles noch viel unklarer definiert. Also eigentlich gar nicht.
Doch auch irgendwie verkaufen die ein Abonnement im Endeffekt.
Und vor allem halt so typisch USA-Company, du kriegst halt noch nicht mal irgendwie so eine ordentliche Abrechnung, wo einfach mal drauf steht, was eigentlich passiert ist. Sondern so, ja hallo hier ist Geld. Es gibt auch irgendwie keine klare Dokumentation, wie eigentlich diese Zahlenkette ist. Das habe ich mir jetzt irgendwie alles so zusammen recherchiert. Und das ist irgendwie alles nicht schön. So, und dann hat man halt irgendwie da diesen Aufwand und ich weiß irgendwie nicht.
Jetzt die spannende Frage. Für die 30% die dich das kostet, kannst du das selber machen?
Das mache ich alles selber seit Jahren.
Pack meine Kontonummer hin, können Sie überweisen, Jutas.
Dauerauftrag heißt das.
Nennt sich Dauerauftrag.
Super Dauerauftrag, tut alles, wenn die Leute das machen, machen die Leute das.
Also klar, man muss halt in sein Online-Banking gehen oder zur Bank laufen, je nachdem, wie paranoid die Leute sind, und das halt einmal eingeben und machen und tun. Sodass es überhaupt erst mal passiert, das ist halt der Aufwand, der initiale Aufwand dafür ist größer als für so eine... Flatterklicken oder Patreon-mordlichen Euro einzahlen lassen, weil du kannst ja bei PayPal auch abbuchen lassen von deinem Konto, also der Hintler. Das ist halt der initiale Aufwand, ist ein Ticken höher, aber der Outcome, wenn ich die Leute unterstützen möchte, ist viel viel höher, wenn ich Seeper-Überweisungen mache. Und das ist glaube ich das, wie alle zehn immer, wir wollen die Creator unterstützen und die Leute, die hier Content liefern und so, dann macht es auch bitte auch so, dass möglichst viel Kohle bei denen ankommt. Das ist halt das Wichtige dabei, weil es ja schön, wenn irgendwie ihr dann einen Euro per PayPal spendet, wenn ihr halt davon 40% verpuffen, ist das sehr, sehr schade, weil das einfach halt nicht das ist, was sie wollen. Sie wollen, dass der Euro so viel wie möglich ankommt. Und es ist halt irgendwie...
Ich hab kein Problem damit, wenn jemand einen Euro im Monat zahlen möchte. Aber es ist besser, einmal im Jahr 12 Euro zu zahlen, als 12 mal ein. Weil dann bleiben nämlich nur noch 6 Euro übrig, versus irgendwie vielleicht 10.
Also der Tim ist ja angewiesen auf Geld spenden, weil er ja auch hier das bezahlen muss, und Equipment und Zeug. Und das Eis. Und wir brauchen ja auf alle, jede Folge neue Mikrofone. Nee, stimmt nicht.
Jede Folge neues Eis.
Und bei mir fragen auch Leute, warum ich dann für PayPal jetzt irgendwie kein Adress habe. Kam mir letztens per Twitter. Ich hab auch noch frecherweise gar nicht geantwortet. Weil ehrlich gesagt, ob da per PayPal 3 Euro für mich kommen oder nicht, die 3 Euro, die die, ja die landen irgendwie virtuell über Umwege dann doch irgendwie vielleicht indirekt in meinem Portemonnaie, falls ich mal Geld habe, aber nur virtuell, dann kauf ich irgendwas, aber die Verbindung zur Spende fehlt. Das heißt, wenn mir Leute, so wie letztens, mir den Müsli Löffel von Amazon schicken, find ich's viel besser, weil ich hab die nächsten 20 Jahre, wenn ich von dem Löffel esse, dann weiß ich, das ist eine Spende. Also ich weiß, Timme braucht Geld, weil er muss ja Zeug bezahlen, wobei er sicher bestimmt auch Equipment-Sachen auf seine Amazon-Wunschliste setzen könnte. Aber man muss auch Finger mit haben.
Was ist denn der Müsli Löffel von Amazon?
Der ist von Amazon, ist der nicht, der wurde nur von denen geliefert, weil Amazon ein Wunschliste ist. Der ist von Schleichwerbung von WMF, aber ich brauchte halt einen Löffel, wir können eine andere Werbung der Firmen nennen. Aber ich brauchte einen Löffel, der nicht Suppenlöffel groß ist für das Müsli, weil das ist unangenehm zu essen, aber auch nicht Teelöffel klein, weil dann komm ich zu spät zur Arbeit, wenn ich zur Arbeit gehen würde.
Das war doch von den Sendungstitel, wenn ich zur Arbeit gehen würde.
Kehme ich zu spät. Wir haben ja schon den anderen Titel. Mit so einem kleinen Teelöffel kann man keinen Müß lernen. Da gibt es so einen Löffel dazwischen und ich hab von ganz früher noch, jetzt kommt wieder Schleichwerbung, vom Kinderverkehrsgarten, da gab es, wenn man da mitgemacht hat, so einen Löffel, so eine Kindergröße, so genau dazwischen, den hab ich jahrelang als Müßlöffel benutzt, aber ich brauchte noch so ein Ding und das sind halt Müßlöffel. Da gibt es so in Zwischengröße, das ist total praktisch.
Man merkt schon, das macht dich glücklich und das schafft Bezug.
Nee, da haben wir auch schon ganz viele andere Sachen. Und wenn ich jetzt auch gar nicht alle weiß, weil ich es auch schon vergessen hab teilweise, aber das sind jedes Mal, wenn ich Dinge zu Hause benutze, wo ich weiß, die kamen als Spende, dann freut man sich natürlich. Und dann ist so eine Spende mehr wert als die zwei Euro oder fünf, die der Löffel gekostet hat.
Also ich guck mir die gerade an.
Diese Müsli-Löffel von WMF.
Es gab auch andere Firmen, so ist es nicht.
Link, hier, Slack, Slack, Slack.
Ich hab doch keinen Slack. Ich kann doch keine Technik.
Mach doch einfach mal Müsli-Löffel WMF ein.
Das muss ja schon der richtige Müsli-Löffel sein.
Edelstahl-Rost-Frei, 16,5 Zentimeter. Läuft.
Ja, ich hab den auch verglichen mit meinem Kinderverkehrsgarten-Löffel. Die sind tatsächlich relativ gleich groß. Der eine ist etwas höher, der andere ist ein bisschen breiter, aber das ist sehr angenehm damit zu essen.
Also andere nutzen es für Kaffee oder Kakao. Ich lese gerade den Kommentaren. Der Löffel liegt gut in der Hand. Schöner wäre es für meinen Geschmack jedoch gewesen, wenn die Enden am Still stärker abgerundet wären. Dann würde er besser in der Hand liegen. Da gibt es Kritik an einem Löffel.
Ja, ich guck mir das nochmal genau an.
Sieht edel aus, glänzt schön, ist aber größer und der Stil breiter als gedacht. Das ist auf den Bildern und der Beschreibung erkennbar.
Daher nur vier Sterne.
Ich hab mir extra den im Kaufhaus angeguckt, die Müsli-Löffel-Abteilung. Und es gibt wirklich Löffel für alle möglichen Sachen. Also auch Honig-Löffel. Ich hab keine Ahnung, Kaffee-Löffel, spezielle Umrühr-Löffel. Also wirklich in allen verschiedenen Größen. Aber der Müsli-Löffel ist halt nochmal speziell. Deswegen gibt es halt auch ein Müsli-Löffel. Aber es gibt Löffel für alles Mögliche.
Löffel zum Auslöffeln. Amazon empfiehlt mir jetzt noch Suppentassen-Löffel. Also nicht Suppen-Löffel, sondern Suppentassen-Löffel. Dann noch ein Kaffee-Löffel-Set sechsteilig und ein Joghurt-Löffel-Set zweiteilig.
Genau, Joghurt-Löffel, das sind, weil die Joghurt-Behälter so riesen. Die haben längeren Stil, damit man sich nicht immer die Finger mit Joghurt falsch macht.
Ja, richtig so. WMF ist halt auch irgendwie schon ein bisschen so mein Held, was Haushaltswahn betrifft.
Ja, das ist leider richtig.
Aber ich wollte jetzt auch gar nicht euer Thema weggrätschen. Ich wollte nur sagen, dass ich halt auch Spenden in...
Tim kommt nicht hinterher mit Affiliate-Links, die er hat.
Weil auch das sind Spenden, ne?
Auch das sind Spenden, na klar.
Rufen sie jetzt die Nummer hier neben ihrer Landesflagge an.
Ne klar, der Mix macht's.
Der kann man nicht einfach nur an eine Nummer schalten, wo Leute einfach anrufen und Tim sagt irgendwas auf Band und dann haben die halt dafür bezahlt?
Wenn ihr auch denn das Müsli-Löffel haben wollt.
Drücken Sie mir eins.
Vielleicht sollte ich einmal mein Müsli-Löffel benutzen und ihn dann versteigern, so.
Mais bieten, aber ungewaschen, ne?
Geil.
Von diesem Löffel hat schon...
Das seh ich schon. Der Metaebene Fetish Shop. Müsli-Löffel, Klammern WMF, von Dennis benutzt.
Klammern ungespült.
Das ist dann wie Höschen getragen.
Also Löffel ungespült ist ja das gleiche Niveau.
Aber schrankfertig abgeleckt.
Das ist Naughty VR. Gut. Ja, damit können wir diesen Teil auch abschließen. Zu den Spendenplattformen hab ich jetzt auch in dem Sinne nichts weiter hinzuzufügen.
Auch soll das uns bedanken für die vielen Spenden?
Ja, das eh.
Aber sagen wir mal so. Mein Ziel ist das normal etwas detaillierter zu bloggen.
Ich will mal wieder bloggen.
Ich hab schon seit Jahren keinen Blogpost mehr verfasst. Also keinen substanziellen. Und ich hab vor allem früher ja auch viel zu Flatter und so weiter auch schon an sich geschrieben und hab das dann irgendwann nicht mehr fortgeführt. Und das ist jetzt so ein bisschen mein heimlicher Plan, das vielleicht mal wieder aufzugreifen. Aber ich wollte noch was anderes, was mit Geld zu tun hat, auf eine interessante Art und Weise mal darauf hinweisen, weil ich finde, das Projekt hat es einfach mal verdient. Und zwar wer schon mal auf dem Kongress war, der kennt das wahrscheinlich. Also wer auf dem letzten Kongress war, das ist wichtigstier.
Letzter Kongress.
Genau. Oder bei Logbook Netzpolitik 200 war oder danach eins dieser T-Shirts ersteigert hat oder gekauft hat viel mehr. Wird schon mal auf der Webseite pretix.eu gewesen sein. Und Pretix ist so eine Art Ticket-Sale-System, also ideal für Konferenzen, Workshops, Veranstaltungen. Also im Prinzip so wie Xing-Events oder Eventbrite.
Nur in Netta.
Gibt es noch andere Systeme, mit denen man das vergleichen kann, aber das sind die typischen Go-To-Plattformen. Die nehmen dann halt schon relativ viel Kohle. Nicht ohne Dienstleistung, ich finde grundsätzlich ist das eine der besseren Erfindungen im Internet. Du musst für eine Veranstaltung Tickets verkaufen. Das kann ganz schön anstrengend werden. Wir nehmen euch das mal ab.
Und das Geld gleich mit?
Naja, aber das ist eine solide Dienstleistung. Ich würde nicht im Traum daran denken, heute so ein Event zu machen ohne sowas. Wenn ich mir den Aufwand anschaue, den du treiben musst, denk mal, Online-Kauf, Plan, Zahlung, Rückläufer, Storno, Versand, all dieser ganze Klimp. Das nervt.
Oh mein Gott, ich hab in den 2000ern ein Konzert veranstaltet, so richtig so großes Festival mit fünf Bands und wollte dann auch Karten über damals CTS Event-Themen verkaufen, die erst mal flach 300 Euro Einrichtungsgebühren haben wollten, aber noch keine Karte verkauft gewesen. Und dann irgendwie unglaubliche Gebühren und das war alles schlimm. Und seit es solche Tools wie Clemens oder Eventbrite oder jetzt auch Pretix gibt, ist das alles so schön geworden. Und bezahlbar. Genau.
Auch bei den, wie heißen sie?
CTS Event-Themen, die sind nach wie vor nicht bezahlbar. Aber das brauchst du auch und die brauchst diese Plattform nicht mehr, weil der geht noch in einen Ticketladen und kauft eine Konzertkarte.
Stimmt.
Also wer macht denn das noch, außer Menschen ab 60 oder 70, die halt irgendwie Zahlen im Internet einfach nicht trauen?
Zu Recht. Ja, das ist noch, also ich glaub nicht nur ab 60. Also im Fußball bin ich auch mal wieder erstaunt, wie viele Leute dann so am Verkaufstag in so einem Vereinshaus stehen und sich dann so ihre Papiertickets erfolgen.
Das ist ja so ein Happening-Ding.
Ja gut, aber ich weiß nicht, ob jeder so einen Bock hat, da zwei Stunden lang in so einer Schlange zu stehen, allein, ja gut, was weiß ich. Aber es ist ein Auslaufmodell, sagen wir es mal so. Also es gibt sicherlich viele Dinge im Internet, die hätten nicht unbedingt sein müssen. Das gehört nicht dazu. Jetzt Incoming Pretix. Was ist Pretix? Pretix ist quasi eine Software und eine Plattform gleichzeitig. Das heißt Pretix EU ist ein Hosting für die Software Pretix, die man sich aber auch frei herunterladen kann. Es handelt sich nämlich hier um ein Open Source Projekt.
Genau, man kann das auch selbst hosten, wenn man das möchte. Und es ist kein Ruby Monster.
Ich glaube, ein Python Monster.
Schon irgendwie, also besser als so ein Ruby Ding.
Ja, your mileage may vary.
Die Tits bis hin wollen wir glaube ich gar nicht aufmachen.
Nein, da steigen wir jetzt nicht drauf ein.
Das machen wir auf gar keinen Fall.
Netter Versuch.
Sprich, wenn ihr ein Event habt, und ihr müsst Tickets verkaufen, oder wolltet sowas schon mal aufziehen, dann seid ihr erstens bei Pretix deutlich billiger am Start, als bei den anderen Plattformen, was die Themen betrifft.
Und netter und weniger spam.
Jan, komm da mal voran. Was hat denn denn denn für tolle Features jetzt? Was ist denn da jetzt? Setz mal Butter bei den Fischen hier. Kann ich zum Beispiel Tickets ausstellen, die ich auf meine Wolle draufladen kann?
Ja, das auf jeden Fall. Das ist drin. Also es kann überhaupt eine ganze Menge. Du hast halt diese ganze Flexibilität. Du kannst halt da so verschiedene Ticket-Typen machen, mit Varianten. Du kannst irgendwie Kontingente aufsetzen, das in irgendwelche Kategorien zuordnen und so weiter. Du kannst beim Anmelden halt verschiedene Fragen stellen, sozusagen so ein Polling noch mit reinholen. Und natürlich erstellt es Rechnungen, versendet die auch, etc. Und macht halt das ganze Management der Bezahlungen. Und jetzt gibt es aber hier...
Also wie ich immer so schön sagen würde, mit Sauce und Schaf.
Ja, im Moment ohne Schaf.
Ohne Schaf.
Nur mit Sauce.
Aber mit Knoblauch.
Es gibt nämlich hier einen entscheidenden Unterschied, zumindest in der aktuellen Form. Das muss nicht unbedingt zu bleiben, aber so ist es jetzt gerade. Eine Sache macht das halt nicht, was Kling-Events und eventbreit machen. Sie speichern nicht das Geld zwischen. Das heißt, die Zahlung läuft nach wie vor über dein Konto. Du musst sozusagen selber die Zahlung annehmen.
Und dann markieren, dass es da ist, das Geld.
Und dann sozusagen die Bezahlung machen. Das kann man irgendwie relativ entspannt machen, indem man halt so mit einer üblichen Online-Banking-Software mal eben die ganzen eingehenden Zahlungen...
Kann ich einfach die ganze Seite nehmen, mit Copy, und da reinpastet? Da passt mir dann, weiß ich, die Reservierungsnummern ab? Oder wie so was?
CSV einfach. Du machst halt einfach einen CSV-Export mit den Feldern. Wenn du das erste Mal da rein importierst, dann ordnest du die Felder zu, das merkt er sich. Und dann schiebst du einfach nur noch Daily oder Weekly, je nachdem, was du da für ein Modus hast.
Hat also keinen eingebauten Banking-Line?
Hat keinen eigenen, wohlgemerkt für SEPA-Zahlung. PayPal ist natürlich auch mit drin. Und seit dem Neuesten glaube ich auch Stripe, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe. demnächst kommt da auch so Geschichten wie Kreditkarten plus potenziell bei Stripe steht demnächst auch irgendwie ein Lassschriftverfahren an. Das ist aber deshalb noch irgendwie in Beta. Also wenn man sich jetzt nur auf PayPal z.B. beschränkt und SEPA komplett rauslässt, dann ist es irgendwie auch vollständig automatisch und man hat irgendwie keine extra Arbeit. Aber die Kohle landet halt bei einem selbst. Es wird nicht zwischengespeichert. Bei Xing ist ja so, du kriegst deine Kohle erst zwei Wochen nach dem Event. Was natürlich auch wiederum ein Problem ist, weil wenn du die Kohle brauchst, um den Event zu finanzieren, kriegst du die da halt nicht. Das kann natürlich schon ein Faktor sein, wenn du eh knapp bei Kasse bist und es nicht nur darum geht, deine Kosten am Ende rechnerisch gedeckt zu bekommen, sondern vor allem auch deine Vorbereitungskosten daraus finanzierst, dann hast du natürlich Arschkarte.
Aber von da her ist das doch ein Feature, kein Bug.
Ja, ist auch ein Feature, aber macht halt unter Umständen auch nochmal extra Arbeit.
Und erzeugt Reibungssitze auf dem eigenen Konto.
Spornierung und so weiter, das ist dann halt ein bisschen aufwendiger. Aber alles irgendwie relativ cool. Es gibt dann irgendwie sogar noch eine kleine App für andere Telefone, die man sich runterladen kann. Und dann kann man dann eben auch noch diese ganzen ausgedruckten Tickets irgendwie scannen und hat dann quasi auch so Anwesenheitslisten und Eingangschecks.
Und ob das Ticket auch nicht zweimal verwendet worden ist.
Das hast du nämlich jetzt nicht bei den anderen Diensten.
Doch, Eventbrite hat auch eine App dafür.
Klingt aber nicht, ne?
Keine Ahnung, das hab ich soweit noch nicht benutzt.
Wär mir neu.
Ich hab vorhin ein bisschen Angst.
Gibt's aber nur als Android ab?
Gibt's nur als Android ab, aber ich meine, da kannst du halt einfach so ein Plain Device nehmen und das sozusagen als Appliance benutzen für nix anderes. Und dann drückst du das halt einfach irgendwann am Eingang in die Hand und dann macht man noch Piep, Piep, Piep, Piep, Piep, Piep, Piep. Und ich weiß nicht ganz genau, hab mir das Ding jetzt noch nicht so genau angeschaut. Das war recht plain, als wir es das erste Mal eingesetzt haben. Aber da kommt dann halt mittelfristig, glaube ich, auch irgendwie so Rückmeldung, dass du siehst, wie viele Leute da waren und so weiter. Also ist irgendwie alles ganz nett und hat irgendwie jetzt auch Slack-Integration dazu bekommen. Das heißt, wenn da irgendwie ein Ticket gekauft wird, dann kriegst du das gleich in deinen Slack-Kanal reingeworfen und also klimpeln.
Was es nicht alles gibt heutzutage.
Ja, das ist alles ganz geil. Und natürlich auch ein relativ flexibles Gutscheinsystem. Funktioniert ein bisschen anders als bei Xing, aber ist auf jeden Fall ganz cool. Aber wenn ihr halt jetzt so einen richtigen Low-Key und ihr seid aber geile Nerds, die irgendwie eigene Server zum Laufen bekommen macht, dann könnt ihr euch halt auch einfach die Software selber installieren und das einfach selber hosten und selber machen. Und dann ist es sozusagen komplett kostenneutral. Das ist halt wirklich ein System.
Die Community Edition, wie sie heißt.
Genau, das ist ein System, das funktioniert.
Die Char benutzt zum Beispiel gerade auch Pre-Tex. Für den Vorverkauf.
Die Char verwendet das. Und gleich hier nochmal hier für Sebastian nochmal ein bisschen. Dieses Podstock hier im Sommer. Dieses Podcast-Treffen benutzt das zum Beispiel auch. Also wenn man da auch wie auf Shipp...
Mit dem großen, fetten, blauen Button.
Jetzt Ticket kaufen.
Das war zu einfach.
Genau, dann kann man das halt auch so farblich und so weiter customisieren und dann eben auch so voll in seine Webseite integrieren. Also das ist alles gut damit lösbar. Ja, macht der Rami, schöne Grüße an Rami, der den Kongress macht. Der ist für den Kongress auch, war der Kongress so ein bisschen auch der Kick-Off dafür? Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Aber Kongress benutzt jetzt nicht Pretix oder was?
Ja, ist vor allem auch so, ich liebe ja immer so Software und Dienstleistungen, wo man so eine informierte Mail hinschicken kann und das Gefühl hat die andere Seite versteht, wovon man redet. Nicht Dinge, die sinnvoll sind.
Nicht als Einfurt kommt, did you try turning it off and on again.
Ja, ne, sondern so, ah ja, interessant und so. Also wo sozusagen mitgedacht wird und wo man das irgendwie so... Ihr nächster Event mit Pretix. Wieder eine unbezahlte Werbung. So sind wir.
Und jetzt schümmen sie den Surfer und machen es kaputt.
Apropos unbezahlte Werbung, das ist doch eine gute Sache. Wir haben schon mal darüber gesprochen, über den Feinstaubsensor.
Ja, hatten wir hier einen. Wir haben hier etwas beworben.
Über diese selber Bastel-Ding oder was?
Genau, so eins hab ich jetzt gebaut.
Warst du etwa in einer Agentur, wo die so ein Event gemacht haben, wo sie irgendwie 12 so ne Dinger gebaut haben?
Ja, die Agentur hieß Republika.
Nein, die Raumfahrt Agentur.
Auf der Republika haben sie diese Dinger gebaut? Warum hat mir das keiner gesagt?
Ich hab's auch nur zufällig am Rande versch...
Einer von 1.100 Speaker.
Na ja, was heißt... Ja, das ist auch so ein Ding. Mit 19 Tracks hatten die einfach zu wenig Tracks auf der Republika. Ähm, nee, also, die hatten halt... Bauen ist auch übertrieben. Also ich meine, es sind irgendwie drei Teile und sieben Kabel und die steckst du zusammen, packst es ins Rohr, fertig.
Ich will eigentlich mal so ein Ding haben. Ich will mal den Feinstaub zwischen den großen Bösen platzieren und einen Ansetzmal vergleichen.
Wo sie so viele davon bauen.
Und wenn man mal bei luftdaten.info guckt, sieht man tatsächlich mein Sensor auch schon am Messen. Ja, so genau ist die Karte nicht. Ausgründen. Ja, ich hab einfach versprochen, noch mal Werbung zu machen.
Haben will.
Ja, wie gesagt, gerade der Unterschied zwischen Land und Stadt ist für mich schon mal...
Wie dicht ist das Netz jetzt?
Na, es geht so. Also es gibt in Berlin schon einige. Du kannst da irgendwie... Da gibt's, wenn du ein bisschen runterscrollst, gibt's irgendwo den Shotcut auf Berlin. Nur Berlin. Du kannst natürlich auch so einfach reinscrollen.
Bezomen mal.
Bezomen mal. Genau. Meine erste... Also mein erstes Gefühl, dass man vielleicht an meinem Sensor relativ direkt sehen könnte, dass da Flugzeuge starten oder landen, das hat sich nicht bewahrheitet. Also der misst nicht viel mehr oder weniger Staub als einige andere.
Mach jetzt mal ganz naiv. Wurdest du jetzt auch erwarten von Flugzeugen und von dem Treibstoff, den sie da so raushauen, dass jetzt extrem Feinstaubgeneratoren sind?
Naja, ich mein Kerosin ist noch ein bisschen schwerer als Diesel. Also ich denke mal schon, dass da auch Feinstaub rauskommt. Gut, vielleicht brennt es auch bei höheren Temperaturen und dann steht nicht so viel Feinstaub. Da bin ich jetzt ein bisschen überfragt.
Das war jetzt eine ernsthafte, naive Frage.
Warum nicht?
Da kann man diese Karte nicht ordentlich reinzoomen. Die hört an einem Level auf, wo ich schon Schwierigkeiten habe, rauszufinden, wo bin ich.
Du bist da, wo der gelbe ist ungefähr.
Du bist da, wo es gerade besonders schlimm wird. Nein.
Wie der gelbe heißt, da bin ich, oder was?
Nein.
Der gelbe heißt, guck, links ist da die... Der gelbe heißt, 50 Mikrogramm pro Kubikmeter.
Wenn du mit der Hand auf die Warbe draufgehst, dann siehst du da rechts die beiden Werte. 35 von den großen Teilchen und 31 Mikrogramm von den kleinen Teilchen.
Und das heißt, wir werden alle sterben, oder? Da geht ja noch einiges hier in Berlin.
Ja, da geht noch was. Wenn du mal ganz raus krollst, mal so ganz, ganz raus krollst, dann gibt's da einen in... Das ist in Dubai, glaube ich. Genau, in Dubai. Aber der geht einigermaßen. Irgendwo da drüben war noch einer. In der Dominikanischen Republik, der ist schon bei 50.
Der Schlag hat wieder ordentlich gearbeitet. Dann gibt's dann den Link dazu zu Abgas im Flugverkehr. Feinstaub kommt auch von oben.
Feinstaub kommt auch von oben, aber es ist...
Danke an den Schlag.
Also, ich will irgendwann mal auch das korrelieren, so ein bisschen mit dem Flugverkehr und der Windrichtung. Aber momentan sieht es jetzt nicht so aus, als würde man es bei mir jetzt deutlich sehen, dass wenn da ein Flugzeug drüber fliegt, dass der Sensor gleich mehr misst. Also, dieser Feinstopp scheint sich relativ langsam zu bewegen. Aber je nach Windrichtung sieht man zum Beispiel sehr deutlich, dass so an größeren Straßen oder Autobahnen, wenn da Leute halt neben dieser Straße oder Autobahn so einen Sensor haben, dann siehst du meistens relativ gut, dass das Zeug zum Sensor gepustet wird oder frische Luft von der anderen Seite kommt und das von der Straße quasi weggepustet wird. Und aus irgendeinem Grund ist morgens auch meistens mehr Feinstaub als abends. Das hab ich irgendwie auch noch nicht verstanden.
Das ist halt vielleicht auch mit dieser windflauten Geschichte zu tun. Aber es ist jedenfalls interessant. Ich will auch so ein Ding haben. Eigentlich will ich zwei davon haben, aber eins reicht mir schon mal aus.
Also es gibt auf der Website, da luftdaten.info, gibt es halt eine AliExpress-Playlist. Da kannst du dir halt die vier signifikanten Teile oder drei signifikanten Teile zusammenklicken und noch ein paar Kabelchen und dieses Rohr gibt's im Baumarkt.
Das ist so die mittlere Größe.
Genau, dann brauchst du noch so einen Schlauch. Und dann war's das eigentlich auch schon. Das ist wirklich super simpel. Weil man halt auch wirklich das Zeug nur zusammensteckt. Also klar, man kann da auch löten, wenn man jetzt unbedingt will. Aber manch einer will vielleicht nicht, weil er nicht so gut löten kann. Tim springt nicht drauf an.
Kinder betet, Tim lötet.
Ja, und es gibt da noch so eine zweite Kleinigkeit. Das hab ich selber noch nicht ausprobiert. Aber es gibt noch ein Ding, das nennt sich Open Sense Map. Und auf dieser Open Sense Map gibt's auch noch mal Luftqualitäts-Dinger. Angeblich kann man seinen Sensor so konfigurieren, dass er auch nach Open Sense Map seine Daten schickt. Das hab ich allerdings noch nicht irgendwie versucht.
Und Open Sense Map ist so Sensoren für allen möglichen Scheißerort?
Ich denke mal, das hab ich mir noch nicht so genau angeguckt. Das wollte ich später noch mal machen. Genau, und der Sensor macht Temperatur, Luft, Feuchtigkeit und halt diese zwei Größenfeinstaub. Interessant wäre halt Stickoxide, aber da gibt's wohl momentan keine wirklich so im unteren Bereich bezahlbaren Sensoren. Ich glaube, da geht's erst bei ab 100 oder so los. Wie gesagt, damit hab ich noch nicht so...
Aber finde ich interessant.
Also, die Stuttgarter sind da sehr, sehr emsig. Ich kann das wirklich nur weiterempfehlen.
Die haben es auch häufiger am Hals.
Ja, die haben es richtig häufig am Hals.
Mit ihrem Talkessel da.
Hat sich bald ausgedieselt.
Na ja, man hört dann so... Ich glaub, in Hamburg war das so, da haben sie dann den Verkehr einmal um den Sensor, um den städtischen Sensor drumrum geführt. Dann gehen nämlich auch die Werte runter, wenn man halt nur die Straße, an der dieser Sensor steht, sperrt. Das ist irgendwie so...
Was haben die gesagt? Die haben die Straße, wo der Sensor stand, gesperrt?
Ja, gesperrt, also für Dieselfahrzeuge, genau.
Ja, er läuft.
Ja, läuft, ne? Ja, was man halt auch wissen muss, dass die professionellen Messstationen auch nur einmal am Tag messen. Während dieser Selbstbausensor, der misst halt alle Minuten, ja, inzwischen denke ich, dass alle 5 Minuten wahrscheinlich auch reichen würde. Aber man hat halt relativ gut, zumindest zeitlich aufgelöste Daten.
Wie macht er das denn eigentlich jetzt? Wir sind ja ein Technik-Podcast, auch so ein bisschen, du hast gesagt, da ist so ein kleiner Schlauch dran, rüsselt der sich da rein?
Ich weiß nicht, ob man es in dem Bild sieht. Das ist so ein Bauteil, das passt, wie groß ist das? Vielleicht so... Halbes iPhone, genau. Da ist ein Lüfter drauf. Und dieser Lüfter saugt durch das Rohr dann Luft an. Also wenn der misst, dann geht der Lüfter an.
Also es hat mechanisch drehende Teile.
Ja, den Lüfter. Der Lüfter springt an, saugt durch das Rohr die Luft an und in dem Ding ist ein Laser drin, der dann Teilchen zieht.
Also vom Prinzip wie ein Rauchmelder. Rauchmelder funktionieren ja auch so nach so einem optischen Prinzip, dass da jemand in so einem schwarzen Raum da rein leuchtet und guckt und jede Teilchen was vorbeikommt, das gibt eine Reflektion.
Soweit ich weiß, wir machen Rauchmelder, aber auch gerne mal mit einem radioaktiven Ding da drin und so. Aber ja.
Eine Sendung mit der Maus dazu, wo Armin das erklärt hat.
Also es ist wohl so, dass diese Sensoren wohl in so Luftfiltern verbaut werden, die Feinstaub filtern sollen. Und wenn der nicht mehr filtert, dann kommt hinten natürlich Feinstaub raus. Und dann kann der Sensor das messen und sagen, mein Filter ist verbraucht.
Was ich jetzt nur wissen wollte, war, wenn der Ding eben drehende Teile hat, dann macht das A, Krach und B, lebt auch nicht.
Nur ganz kurz, der Lüfter dreht ja nicht die ganze Zeit.
Krach würde ich das jetzt nicht nennen.
Der Ding ist eh draußen. Ja, aber der hat drehende Teile.
Aber der Lüfter dreht nicht immer, oder? Nur wenn er messen will.
Der springt kurz an, um zu messen, und dann ist er wieder aus. Und das Teil hat auch eine begrenzte Lebensdauer. Irgendwas meinte er, 5000 Messzyklen oder 10.000 Messzyklen oder so.
5.000 wäre aber nicht viel, wenn du am Tag 1.440 Messungen machst.
Oh Gott, jetzt lass mich nicht festlegen. Der hat so ein bis zwei Jahre Lebensdauer. Aber das Ding kostet 20 Euro. Also das teuerste an dem Ding ist halt der Messsensor.
Nee, nee, ich will nur mal wissen, aber wenn man sich denn so ein Ding bastelt und das jetzt mal irgendwo ans Dach hängt oder man sollte sich gut überlegen, wo man es hinhängt, wo man es halt doch mal gelegentlich anfassen muss.
Ja, er meinte, am liebsten haben sie es natürlich, wenn du mehrere baust und sie so an verschiedenen neuralgischen Punkten aufhängst, um dann so Differenzmessungen zu machen. Wie weit geht der Feinstaub nach oben zum Beispiel? Also so ein Hochhaus wäre mal schön, in jeder Etage einen, um also zu gucken, wie die Feinstaub...
Das kann man diesem System dann auch sagen. Wenn man jetzt wirklich so drauf ist und sich mehrere von den Dingern baut, kann ich auch sagen, diese fünf gehören jetzt hier zusammen und liegen übereinander im Dreieck der Abstand.
Du hast so ein Freifeld, wo du einen trägst, wie du das Ding aufgehängt hast. Im Prinzip. Und dann kannst du halt auch so Sachen machen, wie, weißt du, so ein Vorshaus zur Straße und ein Hinterhaus in Graten und solche Sachen.
Insofern, ja.
So, vielleicht nur kurz, aber...
Ich hab nichts gemacht. Bin unschuldig.
Du hast mir die Prozessoren nicht mitgebracht, du Sau.
Du hast nicht gesagt, dass ich die mitbringen soll.
Ich war vollkommen begeistert, als du geschrieben hast, dass du welche hast.
Ich bin auch begeistert, wenn ich Geschenke kriege. Ja. Bevor du nicht den D-Litter hast, gibt es gar nichts. Sonst müssen wir mal mehr über D-Litter reden.
Genau, wir hatten das Thema ja schon mal angeschnitten. Kurzform ist, neue Prozessoren in den Mac Pro einsetzen, heißt, sich welche besorgen, die im Idealfall keinen Kühlkörper drauf haben. Aber wenn sie das haben, muss man diesen Kühlkörper erst mal abschaben. Wenn man das nicht hinbekommt, dann kann man den nicht einbauen.
Korrekt.
So, das heißt, mein eigentliches Problem, ich hab ja gar keine Prozessoren, die ich einbauen könnte, scheint jetzt, sofern ich da dann nochmal hub-hub werden kann, gelöst zu sein.
Ja, wir hatten, gab's dir da eine anonyme Spende.
Ja, das sind immer die besten.
Ja, und die haben aber halt einen Hitspreader oben drauf, und der muss da runter vorher. Weil du hast einen, um gleich nochmal viele Fragen aus dem Twitter zu beantworten, weil das kommt andauernd, du hast nämlich einen 4,1 Mac Pro, und bei dem hat Apple halt eben keine CPUs mit Hitspreader verbaut, sondern ohne, und deswegen ist da kein Platz für einen Hitspreader, und deswegen muss der runter, oder du müsstest 2,24 mm von deinem Kühlkörper wegfräsen. Den Tipp hatte nämlich letztens jemand, das heißt, wenn du jemanden hast mit so einer CNC-Fräse, kann man ja auch mit den runden Dingern, was man schick in den Apple-Videos sieht und so weiter und so fort, fräst man nicht da so einen schicken runden Kreis, man stellt genau ein, 2,24 mm, und dann wäre das sozusagen auch gelutscht der Drops, aber was musst du wissen, kannst ja aussuchen. Dann hast du aber eventuell deine Kühlkörper verhunzt und die will man auch nicht unbedingt neu kaufen, deswegen ist vielleicht CPU die bessere, weil wenn du da eine Hopf geht, dann ist es nicht so schlimm für dich. Na, wenn du deinen Kühlkörper irgendwie zerstörst, warum auch immer. Vielleicht ist der einfach nicht dick genug, da geht was schief beim Basteln, muss auch gerade gefräst werden. Und der ist ja auf der anderen Seite so mit Lamellen, das heißt, du kannst ihn auch nicht so einfach auf den Kopf stellen und super einspannen, weil er ja auf einer Seite mehr so wabblig ist. Das ist ja nicht so ein schick fester Block, sondern diese Blechlamellen zum Abkühlen, die sind ja nicht so stabil, das heißt, beim CNC-Fräsen musst du das ja sehr perfekt einspannen, damit sie es beim Bearbeiten dann nicht irgendwie doch bewegt, weil dann fliegt dir das Ding um die Ohren oder deine Fräsung da ist halt nicht perfekt.
Ja, alle Fotos, die ich immer gesehen habe, ist das da so ein relativ festes...
Nein, nein, nein, die sind relativ dünn, dafür halt sehr viele, so wie das eigentlich alle heute machen. Das ist nur noch so eine Art Blech. Das ist glaube ich auch gar nicht mehr der... Also unten ist es ein Stück Alu, weil Alu auch gut Wärme ableitet, aber diese Bleche, die gehören, das ist gar nicht mehr aus einem Stück, aber egal.
Ja, auf jeden Fall gibt es ja jetzt diese speziellen Schraub-Zwing-Systeme, die direkt dafür gemacht sind, die sind im Preis auch wohl gefallen. Probleme sind bloß nicht in nennenswerter Zeit lieferbar. Und es gab da wohl mal alte Modelle, jetzt gibt es irgendwie neue Modelle und die sind aber auch nicht fertig.
Ja, die CPU, die wir jetzt haben, ist ja auch schon ein bisschen älter, die ist ja von 2010, also sieben Jahre alt. Das heißt, der Markt ist jetzt auch nicht ausgelegt, irgendwie plötzlich Gerätes verkaufen für Leute, die ihre CPU nach sieben Jahren mal aus dem Keller holen und mal irgendwie plötzlich verbauen wollen. Das heißt, da müsste, keine Ahnung, und vielleicht war das auch vor sieben Jahren noch gar nicht so ein Thema mit dem Delidden oder diesem, ja, wie auch immer, wo das herkommt. Dann weiß ich nicht, ob man da so easy sowas kriegt, aber vielleicht kann man ja mal, du hast ja gesagt, Case King, vielleicht gehst du mit der CPU einfach mal hin oder wir messen die mal durch, wie groß die ist. Und vielleicht ist so ein Skylake ja gleich groß und man kann das da einfach mal kompatibel irgendwie reinlegen oder wie auch immer, also weiß nicht so genau.
Ja, oder vielleicht hat jemand aus dem Hörerkreis einfach nochmal so die entsprechende...
Oder hat schon so ein Gerät, genau.
So ein Gerät oder hat sowieso mal anderes Gerät, mit dem man sowas ohnehin gut weggeköpft bekommt.
Ich dachte der Original-Tipp-Video von mir war ja, weil so ein Typ das einfach irgendwie die CPU so leicht verkantet in den Schraubstock eingespannt hat, die eine Seite halt am Epoxy-Träger, die andere Seite halt an diesem Heat-Spreader-Metall und dann einfach ganz langsam den Schraubstock zusammen gedrückt, sodass das Ding so kurz weggeflogen ist. Und da meinte er dann gleich, das springt ganz schön, man sollte so ein Handtuch drumrum machen, damit es halt nicht runterfällt. Aber es hat funktioniert bei ihm, alles super.
Klingt aber schon so nach dieser Don't try this at home-Kategorie. Ich hab auch so ein bisschen rumgeblättert und hab dann irgendwie den Tipp gelesen, dass wenn da diese Hitzepaste dran ist, dass die Hitzepaste zwar super Hitze leitet, aber irgendwie bei Kälte komplett aus der Spur kommt. Und wenn man das Ding einfach in den Tiefkühlschrank legt für eine Weile, was ja dem Prozessor jetzt selber nicht so viel ausmachen sollte, dann könnte man danach rein jetzt durch die mechanischen Einfluss da bessere Ergebnisse erzielen bis hinzu, man könnte dann vielleicht diese porös gewordene Hitzepaste einfach mit Zahnseide wegraspeln.
Gut, aber das Problem ist, nur die nicht so heißen CPUs, die nicht so hochgetaktet sind oder nicht so viel TDP haben, Total Power Design Power, die nicht so viel Hitze abgeben, die haben diese Wärmeleitpaste, wie du meinst, die im Eisfach vielleicht ein bisschen spröde wird, die mit der höheren Wattzahl, die mehr Energie abgeben, die sind aber verlötet mit dem Heatspreader. Nicht mehr zum Lötsinn, was irgendwie bei 200 Grad flüssig ist, sondern schon bei 80, 90, aber trotzdem verlötet. Das ist die rechts unten CPU, die haut 130 Watt raus. Und nochmal Warnung, don't try this at home, diese CPUs, diese 5680 und 5690, die sind eigentlich nicht gedacht für deinen Rechner, die sind sozusagen overspec. Also dein Dual-CPU hat Apple nie was anderes verbaut, glaube ich, als CPUs, die 95 Watt irgendwie rausballern. Na, deine Lüfter haben mehr zu tun im schlimmsten Fall. Aber das Kühlsystem von Apple ist so overdesigned. Also bis da mal der Lüfter angeht, da musst du schon wirklich irgendwie, da Handbrake, aber wirklich alle CPUs. Also wenn du auch nur schon eine CPU weglässt, dann sagst du, ach was, wie ich bin gar nicht 100 Prozent ausgelassen, dann lass ich den Lüfter mal aus.
Möchtest du aber bitte auch eine Platine haben, die das überhaupt schafft, da die entsprechende Wattzahl an das Ding heranzubringen?
Ja, das kommt auch dazu. Netzteil vor allem. Das Netzteil insgesamt ist eigentlich... Das muss halt eben auch...
Eine Platine, also... Sagen wir mal, natürlich haben die auch ein bisschen Slack da drin, aber wenn du jetzt Watt hast, Watt designt ist für 65, 70 Watt und du machst da 130 rein, könnte das durchaus sein, dass da diverse andere Mechanismen gibt, die dann da noch Einspruch einlegen. Außer jetzt die Kühlung.
Wenn es schief geht, habe ich ja noch meine alten CPUs.
Das ist die Leiterbahn mit der Stelle, die den Strom anliefert, durchgedingst, weil es zu viel ist. Aber ich behaupte, das ist wirklich bei Apple, also bisher ist da alles so overdesigned, auf 90 Watt oder 130. Ich behaupte, ohne Gewehr, alle genau zugehört, ohne Gewehr, ich behaupte, das ist kein Problem.
Das klingt gerade wie das Boot, das muss der Rechner abkönnen. Also das muss einfach funktionieren jetzt.
Das ist Mac Pro, man, alter, der kann das.
Ja, siehst du, wie das Boot, das muss das Boot abkönnen. Der Rechner kann das auch, das funktioniert einfach alles jetzt.
Muss alles ran, Spoiler.
Das wollte man halt sagen, der 5,1 Mac hat mit Dual-CPU und wilder Upgraden, da hat Apple dann die mit dem Heatspeeder benutzt, der muss das nicht machen. Das ist der Unterschied zwischen 4.1 und 5.1, wenn es um die Dual-CPU-Boards geht. Single-CPU ist bei beiden immer mit Heatspeeder.
Ich muss köpfen.
Ja, du musst köpfen, weil du hast 4.1, Dual, da muss man köpfen. Es gibt auch bei eBay Leute, die diese Dienstleistung anbieten. Das gibt es auch. Da schickst du dann die CPUs hin und kostet dann 50 oder 80 oder 90 Euro, keine Ahnung, und dann machen die dir das auch runter. Aber wahrscheinlich haben die auch einfach nur so ein Tool, spannen das da ein, drehen da ein bisschen, hitzen ein bisschen die Oberfläche an, damit das, womit die da verlötet haben, nicht ganz so hart ist, und dann machen das ab und schicken sie dir zurück.
Die haben alle die Werkzeuge gekauft?
Wahrscheinlich, ja. Es gibt auch welche, die verkaufen dir die CPU irgendwie schon fertig, und es gibt auch welche, da schickst du dein ganzes Board hin und die schicken dir das schon modifiziert irgendwie wieder zurück und so weiter. Also da gibt es eine Industrie mit diesem Mac Pro, das ist unglaublich. Ganze Menschen leben davon.
Okay, also nochmal, da ja immer so viele kreative Leute unter euch sind, ich bin mir sicher, irgendjemand hat irgendeinen passenden Hightech-Park, um irgendwie hier CPUs ordentlich zu köpfen, falls irgendjemand eine gute Idee hat in Berlin.
Ansonsten, was ich letztens noch guten Tricks gesehen hab, ist, dass man vier Rasierklingen nimmt, die außen so ein Blech drum haben, also die man von einer Seite anfassen kann, wie Industrierasierklingen, so mäßig, was von allen vier Seiten sich so ein bisschen um diesen äußeren Gummik- oder Plastikring da unter diesen Deckel so runterschiebt, der dann aber immer noch fest ist, weil er ist ja festgelötet. Und wenn man sozusagen von allen vier Seiten die Klingen da drunter hat und die Spannung erzeugen, dann geht man mit so einem Hitzelötkolben, also so einem Heißluftlötkolben, hitzt man kurz diesen Heat Sprayer von oben an, bis er halt diese 80, 90 Grad hat, und das kann die CPU ja abhaben für kurzen Moment, und dann macht es springen und dann fliegt er einfach ab und dann ist es auch fertig. Die Klingen, indem du sie seitwärts unter diesen Heat Sprayer außen so drunter machst, so für 1-2 Millimeter, du kratzt dich da sozusagen so ein Stück rein, weil außen ist der ja nur so mit so einem Plastikzeug da festgeklebt. Da drückst du von allen vier Seiten diese drunter, das erzeugt Spannung, dann hitzt du von oben mit dieser Heizpistole sozusagen, heizt du so die Mitte an, da wo das verlötet ist, und dann springt er ab, wenn es soweit ist. Da muss man aber auch diese Klingen erstmal haben und so. Und sich nicht in die Finger schneiden dabei.
Und sie nicht die Meter eben abfackeln. Na ja Moment, Tim kann nicht mal mit einem Lötkolben löten, da willst du jetzt vorsichtig sein mit anderen heißen Werkzeugen.
Willst du vielleicht nicht alleine machen, das kriegt man schon auch zu zweit irgendwie hin.
Und vielleicht draußen.
Ne, nicht im Wald.
Gut, Tim und Mark abgeschlossen.
Gibt es einige Wege, wie man das machen kann.
Ich will jetzt auch noch mal mein kleines Spielzeug, ich hab's extra mitgebracht.
Dann machen wir ein paar Spielzeuge.
Er hat auch was bei Star Wars, weil wenn er nämlich mal guckt...
Er wollte mal sagen, sie sind ein bisschen auf.
Die sind Imperialet-Ding.
Erst mal jemanden im Chat verlinken, damit die Leute wissen, was das ist.
Ja, jetzt sag ich halt gleich einen. Ich muss ja erstmal den üblichen Disclaimer von wegmachen, ich hab immer noch keine Aktien von AFA-M.
Hätt ich mal welche.
Lass mich raten, das ist ein GmbH.
Ich bin mal wieder an ein Gerät dieser Firma gelangt, was mir diesmal echt Spaß gemacht hat, weil es ist auch irgendwie anders. Nämlich eine Fritzbox 6820 LTE. Ich hab ja schon länger diese Fritzboxen im Fritzbox-Style, dieser Kuchen da, der rote Kuchen. Merkwürdige Form. Jetzt haben sie diesmal einen, was so aussieht wie so ein Imperialet-Offiziersschiff. Also das so, wo Vader mit rumfliegt und so.
Wo Vader immer mit abhauen muss.
Abhauen muss mit so einem Ding, ja. Klein, ein bisschen größer als ein Handteller vielleicht. Aber doch nur, ja, okay. Ist eine LTE-Fritzbox. Das heißt, man schiebt dir eine SIM-Karte hinten rein. Und bin recht begeistert davon. Ich hab ja nun jede Menge auch andere Geräte, die man so auf Reisen hat. So diese ersten MyFires wie ich damals sogar für UMTS natürlich auch alle müsste ich mal aussortieren und mal hier zur Ausschreibung geben oder so. Wer solche Dinger noch haben will, hab ich so weit noch. Natürlich auch für LTE. Aber das ist alles. Wenn man mal guckt, die kommen nur aus ein, zwei Schmieden diese Dinger. Die kommen alle irgendwo aus China. Das ist jetzt entweder ZTE oder Huawei oder wie auch immer. Und die haben alle den ähnlichen flachen Funktionsumfang. Und dann irgendwelche obskuren Begrenzungen. Wie hier kannst du bloß über WLAN nur fünf Devices anmelden. Oder zehn jetzt ist der Neujahr. Und das ist halt eine richtige kleine Fritzbox. Die ist wie gesagt klein, handlich. Und benimmt sich auch wie eine Fritzbox. Das heißt, sie spricht auch zum Beispiel IPv6. Was für mich ja durchaus auch wichtig ist. Das nutze ich ja auch sehr gerne. Und du kannst da halt eben auf der WLAN-Seite beliebig viele Leute vom Prinzip auch einbuchen. Macht natürlich irgendwann keinen Sinn mehr, da 200 Leute auf so ein Ding einzubuchen. Aber du hast keine komischen Beschränkungen. Und verhält sich auch sonst rechts und links wie eine Fritzbox. Was ich auch sehr nett finde, ist, sie unterstützt, im Gegensatz zu ihrem großen Bruder, gibt ja auch so eine andere in dieser alten Kuchen- oder Brotform, eine 6840 LTE. Die unterstützt ja nur drei Bänder. Und die hier unterstützt auch zum Beispiel UMTS und sogar Edge, wenn man das nur hat. Das macht die große nicht. Das ist eher so ein Universal-Ding hier, die kleine. Und unterstützt auch LTE Band 8. Das ist jetzt nämlich neu im Spiel. Die Telekom hat vor ein paar Wochen bekannt gegeben, dass sie jetzt auch Frequenzen im 900 MHz-Spektrum, also da, ich sag jetzt mal GSM, wo sie mit GSM darauf angefangen haben, GSM 900 jetzt auch für LTE umwidmen und haben das auch schon echt umgesetzt. Also ich hab jetzt schon häufiger an Stellen hier in Berlin, wo sonst mit LTE nicht zu rechnen ist, also Souterrainz, Keller oder Hinterhöfe oder sonst wo es sonst LTE-mäßig mau ist, hab ich jetzt plötzlich etliche Bars und das funktioniert auch. Da krieg ich natürlich keine 150 Megabit drüber runter, aber ich hab trotzdem LTE so mit 20, 25 Megabit. Symmetrisch, auch gerade hier mit dem kleinen Ding. Und das find ich eigentlich sehr schick. Da hab ich jetzt auch zum Beispiel eine Karte drin, die jetzt gerade mit Dayflat Unlimited läuft, also für 5 Euro, weil ich da noch eine Veranstaltung morgen mitmache. Und da ist jetzt ein Gigabit Ethernet-Port hintendran, den kann man jetzt einfach anmachen, dann kommt da Bits raus, bis der Arzt kommt, für 5 Euro am Tag.
Also es ist eigentlich gedacht für LTE-Karte rein und der haut nur das per USB raus, per WLAN raus.
Da ist ein kleiner Schwachpunkt an dem Ding, die haben bloß einen 2,4 GHz Access Point drin. Also eigentlich für so... Das könnte man doch verkraften. Nee, kannst du den Prenzelberg nicht verkraften. Aber in der Regel für unterwegs, meine Idee ist das Ding zum Beispiel einfach am Auto mitzunehmen.
Das ist der Open Air Access Point.
Kann man da so einen Battery Booster ranpacken, weil ich hab da nur so einen runden Klingelstreck.
12 Volt kannst du auch aus dem Auto.
Aber du kannst doch nicht einen Battery Booster hier so in so einem USB Akku dranhängen einfach. Der braucht 12 und nicht 5.
Ja, aber da gibt es auch Konverter für. Also gerade in dem Fall zwischen 5 und 12 und 24. Da gibt es doch zwei Folgen.
Ja, aber von den anderen hat man halt schon so viel. Das wäre halt praktisch gewesen. Schön klein ist er ja.
Klein, leicht, wenn ja nochmal. Und wie gesagt unterstützt auch hier so alle aktuellen Bänder. Und macht Spaß, finde ich. Ist jetzt mal ein nettes kleines Ding. Ich weiß gar nicht, was die kostet. Das ist leider glaube ich auch dreistellig.
Sagen wir nochmal 68.
68, 20 LTE. Ja, mit dem Strom ist es nicht. Aber ist mal ordentlich. Also wie gesagt, gerade für solche Sachen ist natürlich die Leute sagen immer, IPv6...
200.
Wie viel? 200?
Was hast du gedacht gerade?
Ich hätte jetzt eher so 120, 130 gedacht.
Aber okay.
Also ist jetzt, ich sage es ausdrücklich nochmal, ist jetzt keine Empfehlung, weil die Leute will nicht immer hören, du hast dir aber gedacht, das soll ich nicht mehr kaufen. Nein, das sage ich nicht. Aber ich mag das Ding. Und habe die jetzt schon ein paar Mal im Einsatz gehabt. Und werde die dann auch mal im Urlaub im Auto mitnehmen. Weil ich dann auch Mitfahrer habe, die haben zum Beispiel ein iPad ohne Dings.
Weil das ist ja mit einem Auto überhaupt kein Thema.
Aber kann man da eine Antenne auch anschließen für das LTE?
Guter Punkt. Die großen Brüder, die 68, 40 oder so, die haben externe Antennenanschlüsse. Das war einer der Kritikpunkte für dieses Ding. Es gibt, kann man auf Amazon klicken oder so, es gibt eine oder zwei Anbieter, die Umrüst-Kits anbieten für um die 20 Euro.
Für diese Dinge?
Für diese Dinge. Weil die intern auch die Stecker schon alle drauf haben auf der Platine, die haben bloß keine externen Dingsen. Das heißt, es ist halt irgendwie so ein kleiner Schnösel. Dann kannst du dir einen externen SMA-Connector da draußen ranbauen an das Ding. Ist wie gesagt ein total kindersicheres Umbauset oder so. Dann kann man sich da auch einen externen Connector dran machen an das Ding. Ich verstehe, warum das hier keinen hat, weil das ist halt eben kompakt, da kommt jetzt keine Batterie. Also bei meinen 6840, ich hab da ein paar von für Event-Kram oder sowas, da sind inzwischen die ganzen Antennen-Stecker-Kupplungen so ein bisschen ausgenuckelt und die Antennen auch schon alle verbogen und alles. Deswegen verstehe ich das, warum sie hier für so ein Ding sagen. Das ist, das lass mal weg. Ist auch interessant für stationären Betrieb. Der von dem, dem ich es habe, der sagte mir auch, der nutzt sowas gerne für so Situationen wie Familie. Irgendjemand ist im Krankenhaus.
Kriegt er so ein Ding hingestellt und fertig.
Kriegt er so ein Ding hingestellt und fertig. Dann kriegt sie halt ein T-Mobile-SIM-Import. Entweder, dass dein normaler Tarif reicht oder wenn die da wirklich YouTube'n wollen oder sonst irgendwas.
Wenn man mal im Haus krank ist, dann muss man halt mal die Tasche geben.
Das sind 35 Euro, dafür hast du unlimited Bits und das ist schneller als das, was jede DSL rausliefert.
Das kenne ich schon, wenn ich manchmal mit Streamer ein Bild hochlade. Bei mir zu Hause 2 MB Bild, 20 Sekunden, mit LTE, 2 Sekunden.
Genau, also kann man machen. Und wenn man das jetzt noch kombiniert mit so Zeugs, wenn wir beim nächsten Thema sind, Reizthema, Stream On, alle diskutieren darüber, schlimme, schlimme Netzneutralitätsdiskussionen. Aber ich hab das einfach mal, weil ich kann das auf meinem Tarif kostenlos mit anklicken. Ja, dann kannst du halt eben auch der Netflix drüber laufen lassen, auch ohne D-Flat Unlimited. Dann stellst du dir das Ding halt eben in ein Krankenhaus und kickst Netflix leer. Pang! So, finde ich jetzt okay. Also mit einem Telekom-Sim. Klar, wenn man da so Arma-O2-Kunde ist, dann hat man da andere Vorteile oder Nachteile, aber...
Aber die Freiheit.
Ja, genau, die Freiheit. Wie gesagt, wollte ich nur mal sagen, finde ich sehr nette Ding, macht Spaß. Also vor allen Dingen, weil man sieht auch mal was, das ist halt AVM-mäßig. Ich gebe denn diese Diagnose-Dinger für Leute, die sich dafür interessieren, das zeig dir mal was an. Diese ganzen MiFi-Dinger, selbst wenn die ein Display drauf haben, dann machen sie da irgendwie einen roten Punkt oder einen grünen Punkt. Und wenn es rot ist, dann heißt das, irgendwas geht nicht. Ja, so genau werden wir es dann auch gar nicht wissen. Aber... Und hier bei dem Ding gibt es halt dieselben Diagnosen, die man von den großen Fritzboxen kennt oder auch von der DSL-Fritzbox, dass man sich das anzeigen lassen kann. Mit welcher Zelle redet der jetzt, mit welcher Bitrate. Man gibt auch so Ausrichtshilfen, denn wo du dein Ding hinstellen kannst, kannst du mit live im Browser zugucken, wie die Empfangslage ist, und dann drehst du das Ding halt ein bisschen rum oder stellst es woanders ins Fenster und holst dann nochmal, weiß ich, 10, 15 Megabit raus und so. Das finde ich halt eben schön und eben nicht diese komischen Begrenzung mit maximal 10 Devices einbuchen oder so ein Blödsinn, will ich nicht hören. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, welche Bänder sie überhaupt unterstützt. Ich werde das mal ausprobieren, wenn ich mal wieder außerhalb Europas bin. Nehme ich sie trotzdem mal mit und gucke mal, was da so mit ausländischen Netzen auch geht. Aber in Europa ist das auf jeden Fall ein guter Reisetipp, denke ich. So, das war dieser Werbeblock.
Zum Thema Akku. Ich habe gerade mal so ein bisschen geguckt, weil ich dachte, mir kann nicht sein, dass da nichts gibt. Und da gibt es irgendwie so einiges, habe ich so den Eindruck. Ich habe mich jetzt gerade...
Voltakkus meinst du?
Ja, und zwar gibt es halt so diese typischen Laptop-Verlängerungen oder so. Ja, genau, solche Akku-Packs.
Oh, von Anker. Warte mal, da war doch was von Anker drüber.
Ja, weiß ich nicht, von Anker? Nee, das ist nur so ein Werbeding. XT-Power habe ich jetzt hier gerade entdeckt, keine Ahnung. Aber auf jeden Fall steht hier, irgendwie USB, Powerbank für Laptop, Tablet, etc. 12 Volt bis 24 Volt.
Der Anschluss, damit kannst du das laden.
Nee, nee, DC-Anschluss. Nee, nee, das ist schon für Laptops, diese Dinger. Kannst du dann einstellen, irgendwie über einen Switch oder über unten Display und so? Ja, die kannst du jetzt nochmal in richtig groß kaufen.
Und keine Ahnung, wie viel Strom das Teil zieht, sieht jetzt nicht so aus, als ob das Ding jetzt besonders viel Dauerbetrieb von Geräten bei 12 Volt.
Von Konrad, der gute Bleiakku.
Ja, ich meine, kannst du dir auch eine Autobatterie da hinstellen, das geht natürlich auch.
Das war krass, so eine riesen Bleiakku und dann hat der nur 12.000 mAh.
Das ist nicht viel. Wir könnten ja Spaßes halber mal anmachen, wenn es hier noch Strom gibt auf dem Tisch. Ich will nur mal gucken, wie denn hier so das LTE in deiner Hütte gerade so ist.
Also, 12V Akku ist das Thing. Da muss man mal hier so ein Sonderding kaufen. Kostet irgendwie auch nur 60 Euro. Keine Ahnung, wie lange das dann hält, aber sieht so aus, als ob man dann mal so ein Wochenende Open Air Party durchaus sich sein Netzwerk rauta...
Da hat man mal Karte rein, Batterie an das Ding geschlossen, das Ding auf eine Stange, irgendwie Selfie-Stick, drei Meter in die Höhe und dann hat man da irgendwie seinen Totem, um den man drumherum Party macht.
Genau. Und hast einen Akku, der voll ist und den du vielleicht woanders, noch in der Hütte, irgendwo noch einen zweiten immer nachlädst und wenn es halt irgendwie zur Neige geht, dann...
Gleich irgendwie noch ein Solar-Dings als Schattengeber oben drüber und dann bleibt das sogar voll, das wär's. Steckst du so rein und gehst weg, musst nie wieder kümmern.
Gibt's schon so Solar zum Mikro-USB?
Das gibt's sowieso für Telefon-USB mit Solar.
Aber ob da so viel bei rausfällt?
Naja, so viel wird das Ding jetzt auch nicht verballern, oder? Hat keine Anzeigen, kein Nix. Also außer die paar LEDs macht der nichts.
Keine Ahnung, Solar-LTE.
Solar-LTE.
Ja, warum nicht?
Das Wolkenfunkloch.
Tja, wollte ich mal anbringen. Macht mir Spaß. Finde ich okay. Und auch gute Feature Telekom hat echt Delivert an dieser Stelle. Wir sind ja mal so ein bisschen angemautzt worden, gerade im städtischen Bereich, dass sie eben nicht in jeden Hinterhof hineinreichen. Jetzt reichen sie seit 4 oder 5 Wochen in jeden Scheiß Hinterhof. Das richtet 900er. Das war ein guter Schachzug von denen.
Sehr schön. Fällt mal.
Aber der Preis war nochmal wie viel? 200.
200 für die Kiste und dann nimmst du nochmal 50 Euro für den Akku an.
Und dann hast du aber nicht schon.
Schon eine Investition. Ich bräuchte den nur im Feld.
Ich kann dir den auch gerne mal leihen, wenn du mal eine Aktion hast, wenn du mal campen gehen willst. Ja, finde ich, ist durchaus okay. Diese Stream-On-Geschichte bringt noch so andere Sachen mit sich. Wenn man das haben will, gibt es ja auch diese Entertain TV Mobil. Aber es ist auch bloß das selbe Scheiß lineare Fernsehen. Ja, da ist auch ein Anrufband, ein Videorekorder im Netz mit drin oder so was. Aber vom Prinzip, ich hab mir das mal geklickt. Fax Gateway? Ja, Fax Gateway. Ich hab mir das mal geklickt, weil in meinem Tarif kriegt es kostenlos mit dazu. Und über diese Stream-On zahle ich noch nicht mal was dafür. Aber es ist ja gnadenlos bloß Live-TV. Also ist das was du aus dem Kabel kriegst oder aus dem Entertain, eben auch dieselben Sender und alles. Und die wären nicht besser. Ja, aber geht. Kann man sowas zum Beispiel echt gut machen. Kannst du dir so ein Ding dann dahinstellen, kleine Kästchen dran in deinem Zelt und wenn du unbedingt Tatort gucken willst, am Sonntag oder so, kannste machen damit.
Star Wars, super. Wir haben uns ja so einen Star Wars-Fan eingetreten. Wie nennt man die Leute?
Haben die einen Namen?
Wasis?
Nee, solche Namen haben wir nicht. Ja, ich bin ja auch erst recht frisch Star Wars-Nerd geworden. Ja, das war der letzte Kongress, da war ich ja nicht da. Ich kam auf der Couch und mir war langweilig.
Hast du mal alle Folgen geguckt in der Machete Order?
Nee, Filme hab ich ja eh alle gesehen. Da dachte ich mir so, weißt du was? Liest du mal die Romane. Der neue Kanon ist ja jetzt da, ist ja nicht groß. Kannst ja alles nur nacharbeiten.
Willst du mir erzählen, du hast jetzt erst vom anderthalb Jahr angefangen, dich irgendwie...
Letzten Dezember.
Das letzte Dezember. Also nachdem wir das hier schon episch diskutiert haben, ohne dass du diese Diskussion mitbekommen hast. Okay, kann man auch machen. Man muss seine Leitkultur nicht aus der Freak Show holen.
Ich hab ja auch früher die alten Romane gelesen gehabt, aber das ist halt der alte Kanon, der jetzt gelöscht worden ist von Disney. Disney hat ja einen Lucasfilm gekauft, dann kommt man so, ach wisst ihr was, das ist alles ja nicht konsistent hier, ich schweiß das mal alles weg.
Wie alles?
Na ja, die ganzen alten Romane, Comics, Filmnacherzählungen, das ist alles nicht mehr gültiger Kanon und Star Wars jetzt.
Ach, also nur die Filme gelten?
Nur die Filme, die The Clone Wars Serie, die zweite von denen, also es gibt ja zwei Clone Wars Serien, die zweite ist gültig, ist Kanon Rebels, die Serie, den neun Filme und halt jetzt dann alle Sachen, die seit dem ersten Da-Small-Comic erschienen sind.
Und die sind aber jetzt, du redest jetzt Animation, diese Animation-Series.
Ja, auch.
Und halt die Clone Wars und Rebels.
Genau, das ist eine Animationsserie, die ganz gut sind. Ich finde übrigens Rebels erstaunlich gut und allein die Teaser, wenn man sich den Trailer anguckt, ist es schon ziemlich krass gut geschnitten, alles auch, also es ist fantastisch. Ja, und dann kam irgendwann, also das erste neue Kanon-Comic war dann noch bei Dark Horse gewesen, es war ein Darth Maul-Comic, der auch gar nicht mal so gut ist. Und der erste neue Roman war dann auch dem Start von der Rebels-Serie A New Dawn. Und seitdem ist irgendwie alles konsistent und es funktioniert plötzlich alles. Also es gab halt früher irgendwie, George Lucas sagte eine Late-Night-Show, dass irgend ein Planet so und so heißt, und da mussten sie Bücher einstampfen und neu drucken, weil der Planet nachher falsch war. Weil das Lust- und Launus-Universum umgestaltet hat.
Ach so, wie bei Trump irgendwie so. Der sagte irgendwas und dann mussten alle sofort die Realität anpassen.
Und dann geht es zwei Tage so und dann sagt Trump, nein, nein, es war doch anders.
Ja, so ungefähr. Also so Sachen passieren, da sind früher auch passiert. Und dann hat ja, wie gesagt, George Lucas dann zum Glück Lucasfilm verkauft an Disney und hat Kathleen Kennedy an die Spitze von Lucasfilm gesetzt und die macht alles richtig zusammen mit Disney. Die hat erstmal irgendwie Star Wars Nerds genommen und hat die die Lucas Story Group bilden lassen, die jetzt also für die Konsistenz des Kanons zuständig sind. Also alle Dialoge, alle Bücher, alle Comics, gegenüber denen ihren Tisch. Und die müssen es abnehmen und sagen ja, ne, ja oder nein. Also auch die achten darauf, dass eine Person konsistent spricht. Also die Wortwahl ums Ergleichen. Und das ist schon ein bisschen cool. Und es funktioniert plötzlich. Ja, und jetzt füllen sie gerade Lücken, die wir so in den Filmen ja hatten. Also jetzt Blue-Gone hat ja eine große Lücke geschlossen in Star Wars.
Also du willst mir jetzt sagen, Disney fixt Star Wars?
Ja, Disney hat Star Wars gefixed und ich bin total schockiert davon. Und sie haben dafür 4 Milliarden Dollar bezahlt und sie haben alles richtig gemacht.
Du hast vorhin auch gesagt, du erhältst Episode 3 für gelungen.
Nein, ich sag dir, das ist inhaltlich super. Nicht, dass der Film gut ist. Der Film ist total schlecht gedreht und die Dialoge sind grauenvoll.
Ja, das stimmt. Wie auch Episode 1 und 2. Also 3 ist so ein bisschen weniger langweilig.
Das ist richtig.
Also 1 macht mich aggressiv, 2 schläfert mich ein, 1 ist dieses Kinder-Ben-Woe, oder? Das mit dem Podrace, muss ich sagen, das ist noch ein echtes Highlight. Das hätte man einfach in einem guten Film wunderbar unterbringen können.
Du weißt aber, für was das da war in der Geschichteentwicklung. Warum Darth Vader so ein verdammt guter Pilot ist. Ja, ist er der beste Pilot der Galaxie. Ja, genau. Dafür ist dieses Podrace da. Episode 2, die Stelle I Hate Sand, ist der schlimmste Dialog aller Zeiten. Es ist total wichtig, warum man nicht richtig für ihn nach Luke sucht.
Episode 1 und 2 und 3, das ist ein permanentes AB-Schnitt von Leuten, die auf Sofas sitzen. Also es ist einfach so was von furchtbar...
Lucas ist ja auch kein guter Filmemacher. Er ist ein guter Geschichtenerzähler, aber kein guter Filmemacher.
Insofern ist es ja auch ganz cool, dass jetzt sozusagen ihm das außer Hand genommen wurde.
Ja und halt gute Filmemacher mit guten Leuten jetzt die neuen Star Wars Filme drehen. Also Rogue One fand ich fantastisch, ich fand Episode 7 großartig. Jetzt dieses Jahr Episode 8, ich bin gespannt. Ich freue mich sehr drauf. Der Trailer verspricht viel.
Der Trailer ist genauso wie der letzte.
Nein, das ist übrigens neu geschnitten worden. Ich hab das mal nachgelesen, Tim. Das ist nicht wahr? Das tut mir leid. Ich hab das nachgelesen.
Ich hab ja letztens auch Rogue One gesehen. Englisch.
.
Und der Roboter da, ich weiß jetzt habt ihr den Namen schon vergessen, aber der war ja gar nicht so witzig, wie du gesagt hast.
Der ist total witzig.
Der ist total lustig.
Hast du kein Humor?
Doch, aber vielleicht habt ihr meine Erwartung zu hoch geschraubt schon.
Das kann sein.
Ich hab die ganze Sache gedacht, der macht jetzt da als Slapstick eins nach dem anderen.
Hat er doch gemacht.
Nee, nicht wirklich. Er kam mir auch fast gar nicht vor.
Hast du zwischendurch geschlafen oder so?
Ich fand jetzt richtig gut den Film. Der Spaß gemacht, hat noch besser.
Mir hat Rogue One auch deutlich besser gefallen als Episode 7. Ja, Episode 7 war so aufgebrühter alter Kaffee. Ah, ein neuer Todesstern. Ah, eine neue Methode, den Tod zu machen. So nach einer halben Stunde wusstest du, okay, jetzt sind alle alten Charaktere noch mal vorgeführt worden. Jetzt können wir die alte Story noch mal abnudeln, fertig. Also es war irgendwie so übel.
Und der männliche Held in Rogue One hat mir nicht gefallen. Vorhin hast du das noch auswendig 5 Mal runtergebetet.
Ich weiß, vorhin, also Mittag wusste ich das alles noch.
Lampenfieber.
Ja genau, das wird's sein.
Bei 5 Flyförern.
Bei Rogue One waren halt einfach Freaks als Charaktere dabei. Also dieser Roboter, dieser Strangel und dieser blinde...
K2SO und der Guardian of the Worlds. Was übrigens spannend ist, wie sie gerade auch lauter...
Du meinst die beiden Quoten Asiaten, dann willst du den Film auch nach China verkaufen können.
Was übrigens nicht geklappt hat.
Ihn nach China zu verkaufen?
Das ist total gefloppt.
Wie auch immer.
Keiner Star Wars?
Nee schon, aber die beiden Figuren waren dafür nicht ausschlaggebend, dass sie es in China geguckt haben.
Die bauen jetzt in alle Filme asiatische Darsteller ein, weil sie jetzt den asiatischen Markt, also China, entdeckt haben, aber es klappt anscheinend nicht überall. Das siehst du jetzt in mehreren Filmen.
Ja, da ist den Quoten-Chinesen-Anführungszeichen drinne.
Da waren sogar zwei in dem, oder?
Da waren sogar zwei, die auch in China sehr bekannt sind, in dem Fall. Die Schauspieler, ja. Aber hat so nicht funktioniert. Was ich halt jetzt auch gerade schön finde, ist, dass irgendwie sie so da und nach jetzt in den neuen Veröffentlichungen für Star Wars, die alten, also die Lieblingscharaktere aus dem alten Star Wars-Universum wieder hervorholen und da reinpacken, so nach und nach. Also gerade ist ein Roman erschrien über Thrawn, da gab es früher einen Dreiteiler als Romanserie. Das waren die besten Star Wars-Romanen, die damals irgendwie da waren. Und die Figur haben sie jetzt wieder zurückgeholt in das neue Universum rein. Und das fand ich halt ziemlich gut.
Obwohl das Konvent den rausgestrichen hatte, oder wie?
Na, das war halt, da der Kanon ja gekriegt worden ist, gab es die Figur halt nicht mehr. Eigentlich ein Kanon. Und dann haben sie den Rebels wieder reingepackt und einen Romanenzug jetzt geschrieben und ja.
Zwei Hinweise aus dem Chat. Erstmal Cassian Andor.
Ja, genau.
Und zweitens, in China nennen sie das asiatische Schauspieler reinpacken, um nach China zu verkaufen. Ah! Buying soy sauce.
Ja, ich machte Cassian übrigens.
Also mir gefiel so der gesamte Vibe von Rogue One eigentlich sehr gut, aber ich finde schon Star Wars 7 hat einfach viel mehr inhärente Epik. Und grandiose Hauptdarsteller.
Keiner der Filme hat eine Story schuldig.
Star Wars ist emotional.
Genau, es ist ja auch übrigens kein Science-Fiction-Film, es ist ein Space-Opera.
Nur bei Rogue One hatte ich das Gefühl, das ist was genuine Neues.
Ja, war es ja auch.
Während ich bei Episode 7 das Gefühl habe, es ist more of the same. Neuer Todesstern.
Ja, aber es ist die fucking Skywalker-Saga, die sie weitererzählen. Es muss doch wieder genauso ablaufen.
Nee, muss es nicht.
Hast du nicht die Ring-Theorie dazugelesen?
Es gibt Stimmen, die sagen, dass die Ring-Theorie einfach...
Totaler Pulschütze natürlich.
Da kann man sich auf jeden Fall ganz ordentlich drin verlieren in diesem ganzen Star Wars-Dingsy. Ich bin auf jeden Fall aufpro, wenn der nächste rauskommt. Ich muss sagen, mich hat die 7 wirklich total gerockt.
Ich fand den super.
Wer uns hier noch nie halt über Star Wars reden hört, dem seien auch noch mal unsere Folgen von in den letzten Jahren empfohlen. Nur irgendwie auch diese ganzen... Wie heißen denn jetzt noch mal diese Mixer? Warte mal, ich muss doch kurz noch mal nachschlagen. Ich komm mich selber gerade nicht drauf. Du weißt schon...
Ja, ich glaub, das ist du meinst, aber nachhebe gerade nicht ein.
Genau. Du weißt es doch bestimmt gleich wieder. Ja, müsste ich gleich eigentlich wissen. Steht das hier nicht dabei? Also es gibt ja von DDSpecialized Edition.
Genau, das ist die alten Fassungen, aber mit bester Farbgebung und...
1609 und einfach korrekt gemacht und ohne diesen ganzen Schmuck, den George Lucas da später einbauen wollte, was wirklich noch mal so als der größte Fail der Filmbeschichte, glaube ich, noch mal so in die...
Da muss ich leider widersprechen.
Wieso?
Ich finde ja die Special Editions ziemlich gut.
Du hast die alten Originale nicht gesehen.
Noch damals auf Sat.1 im Fernsehen mit Werbeunterbrechungen war drauf.
Sat.1, da warst du ja schon alt, als Sat.1 gestartet wurde.
Ich hab dir das Panini-Heftchen zur Episode 4.
Ja, aber da hab ich das erste Mal gesehen.
Fast voll, neun Sticker haben gefehlt. Der Todesstern, vier mal vier. Das ist eine ganze Seite und da fehlt unten die Ecke.
Kannst du jetzt teuer bei eBay nachkommen?
Das sind die Dramen.
Nee, ich glaub nicht.
Ich hab jetzt im Comic-Laden Comic-Abos abgeschlossen für Star Wars Comics.
Gib mal noch mal so ein, zwei Empfehlungen. Was muss man denn irgendwie kennen, jenseits der Filmgeschichte? Dass man sich da jetzt beliebig tief mit irgendwelchen Comics und Büchern reinlöten kann.
Die Serien sind wie gesagt auch nicht schlecht.
Wann wird Lando Calrissian wieder auftauchen und Boba Fett?
Lando Calrissian taucht auf im Film Nächstes Jahr, ein Solofilm. Eigentlich ist er halt in Jung gespielt von Glower, der früher bei Community mitgespielt hat. Ist gut bei Schauspielern, großartiger Typ. Ich freu mich sehr drauf. Weil das wird, glaub ich, eher so wässernartig, der Han Solo-Film. Vom Gefühl her einfach so bisher. Genau, die haben den geklont und nochmal großgezogen.
Die machen das jetzt nicht alles mit CGI?
Nein, nee, nee, das da jetzt nicht. Und sie werden auch ja Lea nicht in Episode 9 mit CGI machen.
Wie war jetzt in dem Rogue One das CGI kurz?
Das war ja mit ihr abgesprochen gewesen.
Rogue One ist am Anfang, wo sie sagt, was bringt uns das? Und sagt ja, New Hope.
Nur Hope einfach.
Und dieser Peter Cushing war ja auch...
Der ist ja auch schon lange tot.
Irales Marketing, kennst du ja, oder?
Aber warum darf denn Lea nicht wieder?
Sie ist gestorben und sie haben bei Lucasfilm entschieden, dass sie das nicht machen wollen, weil auch die Familie dagegen war mit. Sie haben gesagt, wir wollen das nicht, und dann machen sie es halt nicht.
Unglaublich tief. Die US-Filmindustrie respektiert den Tod.
Und Episode 8 war ja schon komplett abgedreht, weil sie gestorben ist, von daher ist Lea auf jeden Fall noch drinne.
Also der war schon komplett fertig.
Da war zumindest die Szene mit Carrie Fisher sind abgedreht gewesen, das war auf jeden Fall erledigt. Deswegen wird sie noch in Episode 8 zu sehen sein, und dann ist es leider auch vorbei.
Das kommt jetzt hier wieder so im Weihnachtskino-Ding.
Also Weihnachtskino. Und werden dann aber der Han Solo-Film Mitte nächsten Jahres erscheinen sollen. Und nicht erst im Dezember.
Der Han Solo ist jetzt so wie Rogue One, wieder so ein paralel Ding. Ich glaub, die könnten mir glatt besser gefallen.
Und der Han Solo-Film wird halt erst erklären, wie Han Solo Schmuggler geworden ist.
Warum er bei Jabberzahar Schulden hat.
Und danach kommt Episode 9. Und dann gibt es noch einen unvertitelten Star Wars Story-Film. Und da gerüchtet ist halt sehr laut vor sich hin, dass es ein Han Solo-Film wird. Schon wieder? Obi-Wahn-Film meine ich. Also das ist halt die Zeit von Obi-Wahn auf Tattooine.
Dann wieder mit John McGregor?
Ja, der schon seit jung hat, ich steh bereit, ich mach das. Und jetzt hat Kathleen Kennedy es so fallen lassen in die Richtung, dass sie da sowohl Gespräche führen. Und das ist schon mal ziemlich gut. Und wenn ihr was gucken wollt, abseits von den Filmen, guckt euch die Rebels-Serie an, die ist ziemlich gut. Das sind akut, momentan haben wir drei Staffeln, die vierte kommt im Herbst, danach ist auch vorbei die Serie, also wird nur vier Staffeln haben. Das ist eine Animated-Serie, die ist sehr, sehr gut.
Sie erklärt eben auch sehr viel, sie geht viel in die Tiefenreihen, auch noch mal SIS zum Beispiel, da gibt es mehrere Episoden, die sich dann da drum drehen, so Darth Maul und so. Und dann die Holocrons und bla bla bla.
Genau, und auch wie das Imperium eigentlich funktioniert, da sind wir auch voll mit Versagern und korrupten Leuten. Und das kommt ja in den Filmen so nicht durch, eigentlich. Also das kann ich sehr empfehlen.
Du hast auch gesagt, dass das Imperium spricht britisches Englisch. Wenn man sich jetzt den Brexit anschaut, dann weiß man ja, wie es steht um das Empire.
Britisches Englisch mit deutschem Akzent.
Ja, so ein bisschen.
Das ist ja nicht umsonst, dass sie da so Gestapo-Uniformen anhaben. Das ist ja schon so Wehrmachts-Design.
Ja, das war ja auch...
Ja, auch der Vader-Helm ist sehr wehrmachtlich.
Brexite, das Imperium bricht zurück.
Ja, also guck durch die Serie an. Ansonsten empfehle ich sehr die Darth-Vader-Comics. Die gibt es als Sammelbände, die sind großartig. Sind die besten Darth-Vader-Geschichten ever. Besser als die in den Filmen, besser als in irgendwelchen Serien.
Fantastisch. Ach ja, wie gesagt, wenn du gerade Rebels empfohlen hast, gibt es ja noch diese anderen, die Clone Wars. Die sind finde ich auch richtig wichtig. Die ziehen sich aber.
Die ziehen sich, das sind sieben Staffeln.
Ich weiß, die ziehen sich, aber die erklären auch eine ganze Menge. Die erklären gerade nochmal diese Verhältnisse, zeigen eben auch den Anakin etliche Male oder ausgiebig. Ich weiß nicht. Zu ausgiebig vielleicht, aber vor seinem Fall an die dunkle Seite.
Obwohl die Anlagen schon da sind dann auch. Obwohl natürlich auch meine Lieblingsfigur eingeführt wird in The Clone Wars, nämlich Asuka Tano, die in Rebels ganz, ganz großartig ist.
Und eben die ganze Sache mit den Clone Wars, also mit den Klonkriegern selbst. Wo kommen die Typen alle her? Also klar, die kommen aus einer Clone Factory, aber die kommt auch mehrfach vor. Und da sieht man auch zum Beispiel taucht der Typ auf, der ja sozusagen der Uhr, der Klongeber ist, Boba Fett.
Ne, Django Fett.
Boba Fett ist ein so... Ja genau, Django Fett.
Ja, und das ist sehr viel Liebe gemacht. Ich mag das sehr. Und wie gesagt, wenn man dann nichts mehr gucken mag, dann wirst du die Darth-Wader-Sammelbände. Gibt's irgendwie für 30 Dollar in Hardcover, wunderschön. Und lohnt sich sehr, weil das einfach gut... Weil Marvel Comics sind einfach gute Comics. Die können Comics zeichnen und da Marvel Disney gehört, macht also jetzt gerade alles Marvel.
Ach so, Marvel gehört auch Disney?
Marvel gehört schon lange Disney, ja klar.
Lange schon?
Ihr habt das nie mit gewusst. Ja, seit Marvel Disney gehört, gibt's die ganzen Avengers und so ein Kram. Das ist auf Disney Mist gewachsen. Ja genau, das Ganze ist wegen Disney.
Ja, auch die ganzen Netflix-Serien.
Aber das ist ja auch nicht gerade um die Alles-Piloten in Disney und Marvel.
Nö, aber so insgesamt, wenn du alle Filme und die Serien auf Netflix in einer bestimmten Timeline guckst, dann gibst du es eine lange, große Geschichte.
Was macht ihr das eigentlich mit diesem Netflix? Ich hab mir das ja mal so testgeklickt und...
Hat damit nicht umgehend, wa?
Nee, das hat mich einfach gar nichts interessiert davon.
Du musst halt wissen, was da so drauf ist.
Da ist ja ein Algorithmus noch nicht genug.
Der Algorithmus ist übrigens scheiße von Netflix.
Genau, der ist richtig scheiße. Du musst wirklich wissen, was du suchst. Dann deliberate, weil es halt einfach geht. Im Gegensatz zu fucking iTunes.
Genau, und dann klimmst du einfach drüben auf die Play-Taste und dann läuft das Ding halt und dann läuft es auch in...
Ich hab mir das gleich wieder weggemacht. Das war nix.
Tim kann nicht so mit Technik, ne?
Ich hab's auch nicht so mit Fernsehen.
Muss ich ehrlich gesagt sagen. Ich hab's ja schon mit Serien.
Ich war ja früher auch so ein Fernsehjunkie und so.
Netflix kannst du inzwischen noch offline machen. Geht's auf dein Pad drauf für einen langen Flug oder so.
Ich find da halt immer nur so alberne Scheißdreck und alle Filme, also alle Filme, die ich auf meiner Liste hatte, die ich mir schon immer mal angucken wollte, nicht da. Und ehrlich gesagt, mit so einem Dienst kann ich nichts anfangen. Ich bin beim Fernsehen wieder dabei, wenn es endlich mal die Suchmaschine gibt, wo einfach alle Filme drin sind, und dann kann man sich alle Filme auch angucken. Ich zahle auch gerne pro Film, aber das macht mich bei Altions wahnsinnig, das macht mich überall wahnsinnig. Ich geh scheiß auf dieses Wehrgewebe.
Max schießt mich da unten.
Ich will einfach nur jeden Film finden können.
Ich nehme halt Netflix vor allem für Serien, das ist eher weniger für Filme. Und für Serien, da haben sie halt eine sehr gute Eigenproduktion, einfach. Da gibt es jetzt gerade eine portugiesische Produktion, drei Prozent. Science Fiction großartig, fantastisch. Also ein bisschen low budget, aber großartige Story.
Ich guck ja gerade, tote Mädchen lügen nicht. Und der ist gar nicht schlecht gemacht?
Ich hab das Buch gelesen und die haben die Dramaturgiefehler des Buches in der Serie behoben.
Verstehe. Ich hab das Buch nicht gelesen und von der Serie erst drei Teile, deswegen weiß ich noch nicht, was da so kommt. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht so ganz plump, wie manchmal so Highschool-Serien immer sind, wo halt die Klischee-Geschichten so erfüllt werden. Das ist da so ein bisschen anders. Aber wie gesagt, ich kann noch nicht sagen, wie es endet, deswegen...
Aber das ist auch nach der Folge gemerkt, dass es echt gut produziert ist.
Ja, also das war auch bei der ersten schon gemerkt. Also ich fand's gut.
Gute Produktion und ja... Ja, jetzt sind wir an Star Wars zu Serien gekommen.
Gut, kommen wir ja an der Stelle auch abschließend. Wir müssen heute übrigens wirklich um Mitternacht so, oder spätestens mal...
Bei den Expired, dein Baby-Sitter?
Ja, dann komm ich vielleicht irgendwann mal vor 2 Uhr ins Bett.
Ich kann ja kurz nochmal das Ergebnis unserer Aufstellung der Fritzbox hier bekannt geben. Also ich hab jetzt hier mal den Ding einfach nur mal rumgedreht, auf den Tisch. Haben jetzt hier mehrfach gemessen, so Downlink, so sagen wir mal 32, 33 Megabit. Ablink, kurz unter 12. Jetzt hier aber mitten auf dem Tisch, wenn wir den Ding da hinten auf dem Fenster weit stellen, haben wir noch mehr. Einfach nur durch so ein bisschen rumdrehen, getunet. Was ganz spannend ist, ist noch die...
So wie man das früher bei den Fernsehern gemacht hat.
Was noch spannend ist, ist, die Fritz Bock zeigt einem halt eben auch eine schöne Netzliste, also man sieht, wer hier noch so rumsendet, in welcher Mobilfunkart. Telekom reicht hier auch rein. Zuerst, bevor ich sie gedreht hatte, war das nur auf 900 MHz. Jetzt hat das noch eine Telekom Zelle mit 1800 gefunden, also die auch ein bisschen breiter ist. Vodafone leuchtet hier wohl ganz gut rein. Alle anderen nehmen sich mehr oder weniger nichts.
Hast du deine Erfahrungen, bei wie viel dBm da überhaupt was rüberkommt?
Empfangsstärke ist jetzt nicht notwendigerweise, nur entscheidend, wichtig ist immer Qualität, also auch Single Noise Ratio. Es gibt natürlich Empfangstärken, die sind so weit hinten runter, also bei LTE, was jenseits von minus 120 dB ist, also was ist denn nicht mehr so sexy. Aber du kannst auch, was ich wie 60, 70 haben, die Qualität ist aber scheiße. Oder die Zelle ist voll. Kannst du dir teilweise auch anzeigen lassen, wie viele Leute das Ding jetzt hier nutzen, diese Zelle? Mal schauen, ob das schnell funktioniert. Aber das finde ich schon mal ganz okay, dass man da so, ne, finde ich jetzt nicht.
Man sieht, wie viele Leute die Zelle benutzen?
Ne, wie gut sie ausgelastet ist.
Woran?
Das gibt hier irgendwo einen Parameter, der wird übertragen von der Zelle mit. Die Fritzbox zeigt dir doch an, wenn ich das nur noch wieder finde, wo das war. Irgendwo zeigt der mir das an. Egal, aber funktioniert ganz gut. Und man kann selbst hier, Metaebene, wir sind jetzt gerade nicht im fünften Stock, sondern wir sind eher so im Erdbefraß.
Ich sehe Open-Air-Veranstaltungen mit Internet. Also nicht Nerd-Open-Air-Veranstaltungen mit Internet.
Ja, ist möglich. Hab ich auch schon vor ein paar Jahren gemacht. Mit den großen Dingern und externen Antennen.
Das ist genau das, was man in so einen Wohnwagen reinstellen will.
Das kleine Ding ist jetzt eher für den Privatgebrauch. Wenn du das für eine Veranstaltung machen willst, gib dir lieber eine 6840 mit den Richtantennen. Oder explizit hingehst und sagst, ich suche mir jetzt mal eine Zelle aus, nimmst eine zweite Box, die eine zweite Zelle anpeilt und so haben wir ja so Open-Air-Veranstaltungen gemacht. Mit ein paar Leuten, aber so für so die kleine Get-Together, du könntest jetzt über das Locker-Podcast live machen und tra la la uploaden und so. Du könntest deine ganze Metaebene, das Ding hier...
Cool, lass uns einen Live-Podcast machen.
Das Mobiltelefon hat ja schon zu Hause meinen Festnetzanschluss gekillt. Wenn sie so weitermachen, dann kilt das auch meinen DSL-Anschluss, weil schneller ist es ja schon. Mit der Traffic-Menge müsste man jetzt halt noch mal gucken.
Das ist so mein Problem mit dem Traffic immer. Ja, 5G-Arbeit und für wen soll das reichen?
Mir hat ja mal einer geschrieben über Twitter, auch auf irgendwas hin, was wir hier so gesagt haben, der hat sich total bitter und böse beschwert. Weil die böse, böse Telekom ihn höflich, aber bestimmt angeschrieben hat, dass sie doch da leichten Abuse vermuten, weil er irgendwie über seinen LTE-Anschluss jeden Monat 20T macht. Fand er jetzt irgendwie scheiße, weil er hätte ja extra diesen teuren Vertrag, damit er das machen kann und so, verstehe ich ja auch, aber 20T ist echt eine Menge. Kann ich euch mal verraten, wir haben jetzt bei der Republika-Inclusive-Video-Upload und halalala im Pipapo haben wir gerade mal die 10T gerissen und das waren ein paar Tausend Leute auf dem Gelände. In drei Tagen, ja. Aber trotzdem, die, also 20T im Monat ist schon, sagen wir mal, außergewöhnlich genug, dass man da auch als Provider mal nachfragen kann. Was machst du da eigentlich, Alter?
War das aber nicht so, dass ein Rechner voll mit irgendwie Schleudersort, der war, sondern er hat die tatsächlich generiert oder gemacht oder benutzt.
Seine Gründung war, weil ich denn auch meinte, das wär schon durchaus ungewöhnlich. Ja, er macht halt Video-Editing, 4K und hin und her, und schiebt die Videos da und über LTE rein oder raus. Ja, aber trotzdem. Gibt's halt eben auch.
Na ja, gut, aber auf der anderen Seite, ich meine, wenn du Unlimited verkaufst.
Aber wie ich schon sagte, ohne in den Treffink reinzugucken, ich machte ja auch bei diesen Veranstaltungen, dass sie da so Sicherungen einbauen. Weil, was du nicht willst, du willst jetzt nicht eine wahnsinnige Infrastruktur machen, nur damit ein Typ wie ein verseuchter PC da dran hängt und sagt, geil, ein Gigabit. Na, let's scan the net. Und deswegen finde ich es durchaus okay, wenn man da mal sozusagen, ohne reinzugucken, eben einfach nachfragt, sag mal, Hallo, geht das eigentlich mit rechten Dingen zu, was du da machst, oder ist da was kaputt bei dir?
Clemens, du hast noch so zwei Dinge hier, glaube ich.
Ah ja, kann man mal kurz und schnell erwähnen. Ich bin ja auch Fan, ist auch bekannt, habe schon mehrfach erwähnt, dass man jetzt nicht, schon lange nicht mehr mit 3,1 Kilohertz nur telefoniert mehr. Also vor allen Dingen nicht in HD oder schlimmer. Ja, ja, in HD oder schlimmer. Der neue heiße Scheiß an diesem Spiel heißt EVS. Entschuldigung, Enhanced Voice Services. Ja, ich weiß, da kam ich nicht schnell genug dran.
Deiner würde funktionieren.
Immer in meinen Finger. Räuspertaste immer in den Finger haben. Ich hab mich an den Nusskrümeln.
Jetzt noch mal kurz testen. Na, mit Husten.
Das war der immer noch mit Nusskrümeln im Hals. Nimm mal die Nusstasse. Der neue heiße Scheiß.
Ich liebe diese Gewichte von den Nusskrümeln, wenn sie prickeln in meinem Hals.
HD hab ich inzwischen so häufig, dass mir schon echt auffällt, wenn ich mal mit welchen armen E-Plus-Schweinchen telefoniere, die noch ein Nokia-Telefon haben. Das hört man dann sofort. Ansonsten hab ich eigentlich in meinem Lebensumfeld fast nur noch HD. Also inklusive Facetime und Blah und Blub, wie sie alle heißen. Aber der neue heiße Scheiße am Start ist auch EVS. Auch da gibt es in Deutschland Vodafone, die hatte letztes Jahr mal angeknipst in ihrem Netz. Die Telekom jetzt gerade vor kurzem. Das heißt, die können jetzt auch richtig so mit 20 oder 22 Kilo als Bandbreite und so weiter. Also so Hifi, wenn du so willst. Was man vorher so Hi-Fi genannt hat. Das Spannende ist der Link, den kannst du einfach einmal anklicken und zweimal in den Chat schmeißen. Jetzt hat sich nämlich jemand mal die Mühe gemacht und hat mal die Interoperabilität zwischen den Netzen, und zwar jetzt nicht nur zwischen Mobilfunknetzen, sondern auch zwischen Mobilfunk- und Festnetzen, mal dokumentiert. Also wenn man vom Telekom 2G-Netz nach, was ich nach Vodafone anruft, ins DSL-Netz, um mal zu gucken, wie die Interoperabilität da ist. Ja, da gibt es noch jede Menge Flecken, wo da noch Bedarf besteht, da zu korrigieren. Aber man sieht, es wird auch schon mehr. Man kann also jetzt auch schon Cross-Network, man kann jetzt schon mal von...
Ist aber im Wesentlichen alles innerhalb der Netze, muss man sagen.
Ja, ist im Wesentlichen alles innerhalb der Netze. Was jetzt schon sehr häufig gemacht wird, ist halt zwischen den VoIP-Netzen, also wenn du Telekom DSL hast, oder Vodafone DSL oder so, da gibt es jetzt auch schon Übergriffe. Das wird auch mehr, weil die Telekom, als der Incompent hier in Deutschland so das Kornett-Star betreibt für diese Geschichten, die bieten schon länger an, dass sie ihre Leute dort, ihre Mitbewerber eben auch per VoIP anbinden und nicht mehr nur per Standard. Was ist dieses EVS? EVS ist jetzt sozusagen, wenn du jetzt Marketing-Poolschitter wärst, das wär sozusagen HD Plus oder sowas. Also HD ist ja so diese Geschichte G722, so 7 Kilohertz Bandbreite oder so.
Was eigentlich auch schon seit Anfang der 90er Jahre spezifiziert ist.
Ja, weiß gar nicht, ob das auch schon G722 war. Das haben ja auch nur diese Leute mit diesem Rundfunk-Kodek da betrieben. Und ja, aber das ist ja auch schon ganz schick. Es ist jetzt nicht nur eine Bequemlichkeit oder ein Luxus-Ding, sondern das macht halt wirklich einen echten Unterschied. Und damit wird es inzwischen auch beworben, weil die haben es auch verstanden. Also die Netzbetreiber, die EVS haben, bewerben es. Auch damit, glaube ich, Vodafone nennt es in ihrer Werbung so Clear Voice oder Clear Channel oder irgendwie sowas. Hat halt den Vorteil, dass man eben auch in geräuschvolleren Umgebungen noch ordentlich telefonieren kann. Was ganz natürlich ist, du hast halt einfach mehr Informationen fürs Ohr. Und unser Ohr ist ja darauf dressiert, Sachen rauszufiltern. Bloß wenn halt deine ganze Information in den guten alten 3,1 Kilohertz Telefonkanal quetscht, dann hat es nicht genug Informationen, um das ordentlich aus dem Grassel drum herum rauszufiltern. Das heißt, je besser das Audiosignal ist, desto eher kann man es halt eben auch in ungemütlichen Umgebungen ordentlich benutzen. Ja und diesen Link, den hast du reingeschmissen, in den Slack, ja genau. Da kann man mal gucken, da können auch Leute mit dran arbeiten. Also es sind noch offene Flecken, insbesondere 1&1-Kunden werden gesucht, um da mal ordentlich Tests zu machen, wie das so mit der Interoperabilität dort stattfindet. Das wollte ich da nochmal zum Besten geben.
Noch einen?
Dass jetzt der MP3 Codec patentfrei ist?
Nicht ganz, da fehlt noch ein kleiner Teil, der erst Ende des Jahres frei ist.
Aber das ist jetzt keine große Sache, über die wir reden müssen, oder?
Na ja, sagen wir mal, so ist es zumindest so weit, dass Fraunhofer sein Lizenzierungsprogramm eingestellt hat. Also selbst wenn man jetzt noch dafür zahlen wollen würde, würde man gar nicht mehr können.
Sind die so nett, dass sie es nicht mehr nehmen wollen?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das heißt, du kriegst jetzt keine Lizenz mehr. Das heißt, du kannst es bis Ende des Jahres nicht benutzen. Oder Lizenzieren. Oder?
Ich glaube, das ist im Wesentlichen so let go. Also it's over.
Der Fauchel ist tot.
Ich fand die Berichterstattung ganz interessant. Weil auf einmal ganz viele so mich sagen, MP3 ist tot. Ich dachte mir so, wo kommt denn der Spin jetzt her? Habt ihr das irgendwie nicht verstanden? Aber wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, dann ist der Spin der Fraunhofer, der mir das Ganze gegeben hat.
Ja, die wollen ja gerne ihren neueren Trickchen geben.
Genau, nach dem Motto, ja das ist jetzt irgendwie abgelaufen. So wie Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum. Das darf jetzt nicht mehr in freiem Verkauf. Also darf man es auch nicht mehr essen. So, und wir haben noch hier unser geiles AAC. Und nimmt auch das. Was ja eigentlich auch weitgehend schon geschehen ist, wenn man mal ernst ist. Der MP3 ist jetzt nicht weg. Aber es ist sicherlich sehr hilfreich, dass es quasi lizenzfrei und damit ja de facto eigentlich gemeinfrei ist. Also zumindest spricht jetzt nichts dagegen, dass die Wikipedia MP3 aufnimmt. Zum Beispiel.
Was in Ihren, dass man jetzt mal dokumentiert, was MP3 ist, gibt es keine MP3-Artikel?
Nein, dass man zum Beispiel ein Audio in MP3 in der Wikipedia abwägen kann. Ja, weil jetzt hat es ja alles Vorbes.
Was natürlich jeder auf seinem Endgerät drauf hat.
Oder vielleicht auch. Das ist ja kein Problem. Dann gibt es ja so einen Java-Blob oder so. Ich weiß nicht, mittlerweile gibt es ja auch Java-Script-Player, die halt auch wirklich den ganzen Kram tatsächlich schon im Browser abfeuern. Kann man alles machen.
Die das in JavaScript transportieren.
Rekurrieren? Echt?
Ja, ich meine, mittlerweile sind die Rechner schnell genug für den Kram. Kann man auch gerne machen. Nur meine Frage war halt, ist es sozusagen frei genug, um auch als frei zu gelten? Es ist natürlich nicht frei im ursprünglichen Geburtssinn dieses Formats.
Ist es b-frei? Nein, auch nicht.
Na ja, aber ich denke...
Ist es in Rente gegangen?
Ja, ich wäre mit Opos ehrlich gesagt dann auch glücklicher. Weil dieses MP3, das ist zwar sehr handlich und was für wirklich... Ich glaube, das Beste an MP3 ist eigentlich dieses Tagging-System. Weil das hat eigentlich sehr gut funktioniert. Das merkt man ja jetzt auch gerade in der aktuellen Entwicklung, so der Podcast-Landschaft, schau dir diesen Scheiß an mit MP4 und Metadaten. Und das ist wirklich ein Drama, weil das ist eigentlich dafür gemacht gewesen. Aber ich glaube, das kann man eigentlich fast auch Apple irgendwie anhängen. Das ist einfach alles viel zu kompliziert gewesen. Zum Beispiel Kapitelmarken bei Podcasts. Was für ein Elend! Apple hat irgendwann mal ein Format rausgebracht, hat das dann über die Zeit, als das nie dokumentiert, hat es dann über die Zeit verändert. So dass wenn ich jetzt, das ist ja so, wenn ihr die MP4-Version zum Beispiel dieses Podcasts jetzt nehmt, da sind Kapitelmarken drin, in einer Form, wie die iPhones das heute gerne haben wollen. Damit das auch die Standard-Podcast-App kann. Diese Art von Kapitel bringt einen iPod-Shuffle von ein paar Jahren, dieses weiße Teil, was man sich so um den Hals hängt, einfach zum Absturz oder zum Spiel nicht abkriegen.
Wie ist das mit so einem iPad Classic? Mal mal ausprobieren.
Keine Ahnung. Ich hab jetzt explizit immer wieder vom Shuffle gehört, dass die sich an diesen MP4-Dateien verschlucken. Hab ich halt gesagt, hier nimm MP3. MP3 ist halt einfach auch universell problemlos.
Das ist der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner.
Das ist der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner. Leider ist er halt auch qualitativ in vielerlei Hinsicht der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner und das ist halt problematisch. Von daher will ich ganz gern los. Aber es hat sich einfach gezeigt, dass dieser komplexe Media-Container, der so theoretisch eine ganze Menge tolle Sachen kann, so einzelne Spuren für Tracks und Untertitel und ist ja irgendwie alles wie ein Film, ist ja eigentlich im Prinzip auch ganz gut. Aber es ist ihnen dann auch einfach gelungen, einfache Dinge so kompliziert damit zu machen, wie zum Beispiel Kapitelmarken. Wie, was weiß ich, du willst halt gleich loslegen und bei MP3 kommst du halt sehr schnell einfach an diese Kapitelinformation drin, weil die liegt am Anfang der Datei. Und das tut sie dann halt in so einem MP4-Ding nicht, weil sie halt richtig über die Timeline verbunden ist. Das heißt, der Kapiteltext steht genau an der Stelle in der Datei, wo auch dieses Kapitel anfängt. Logisch für Streaming und so weiter. Ist das ja so eine Information, aber dass man vielleicht manche Metadaten auch schon vorher haben möchte, hat sich jetzt auch nicht so...
In irgendeiner ATP-Folge vor zwei oder drei Folgen, weiß ich nicht genau, meinte Arment ja auch, das ist so schlimm, weil man muss einmal durch die gesamte Datei durchsiegen, um alle Kapitel einzusammeln.
Genau.
Und dann hat man sie vorliegen und dann kann man irgendwie anfangen.
Das ist einfach nicht schön.
Nee, das will man nicht.
Das will man nicht. Ja, und dann so limitiert MP3 eigentlich ist.
Und er hat sich sogar dazu hinreißen lassen, zu sagen, dass Potluff Simple Chapters eine wunderbare Idee ist. Würde nur leider so wenig unterstützen.
Ja, du Nuss, fang an damit. Was glaubst du, wie viele das auf einmal unterstützen werden?
Die übliche Schwanz beißt Hundnummer. Warum sollen wir ein Gerät bauen, für ein Netzwart nicht existiert? Warum sollen wir ein Netz bauen, für Geräte, die nicht existieren?
Wie soll denn ein Schwanz ein Hund beißen?
Hat der Lummer den Schwanz in der Hand? Oder war er nicht auf dem Sitz?
Ich bin gespannt.
Ich weiß nicht, also meine Fantasie, aber egal.
Okay, also MP3 ist jetzt frei, Spaß dabei.
Viel Spaß am Codec.
So, ich merke schon, wir sind eigentlich durch, ne?
Ja, es gibt noch so Kleinigkeiten. Sitzlos Aufreger, warum ja nicht.
Doch, einen kleinen Aufreger noch hinterher. Ich bleib nochmal ganz blubig, aber vielleicht zwei Hinweise. Haltet euch doch mal den 1. Juli 2017 frei. Was, du?
Ich schüttel schon mit dem Kopf.
Ich auch.
Du schüttelst auch mit dem Kopf?
Warum?
Weil ich da in den Ferien bin. Mit meinen Kindern an der Ostsee.
Dann kommst du kurz mal eingeflogen.
Könnt ihr es nicht verschieben?
Kann man die da nicht abgeben, gibt's da nicht so ein paar Kinderbetreuung.
Es gibt eine fucking Ostsee.
Müssen wir da wohl nochmal drüber diskutieren. Ich hatte das in Erinnerung. Hattest du nicht gesagt, dass du Zeit hast?
Wir hatten über dieses Datum noch nie gesprochen.
Nein?
Nein.
Der war beim letzten Mal nicht da. Da haben wir ja nur mit Huckel zu dritt gemacht, oder?
Mich hattest du mal provisorisch angefragt, aber ich bin da leider sehr vergeben.
Du warst in einem Moment nicht da, und dann hab ich vergessen, diese Information reinzuholen. Ja, müssen wir noch mal schauen. Also das ist, sagen wir mal, so eine Idee gewesen. Gewiss. Vielleicht ist es noch eine.
Du hast gerade um wahrstes Wort ins Wasser gefallen.
Nee, weiß ich noch nicht so ganz genau.
In die Ostsee.
Eigentlich wollte ich die Gelegenheit nutzen, unsere 200. Sendung abzufeiern.
Jetzt ist hier niemand da.
Ja, wenn keiner da ist, dann geht's natürlich nicht.
Man sitzt immer alleine auf der Bühne und macht das halt alleine.
Das kann ich auch.
Mach mal Studio-Links von überall.
Ich weiß nicht, ob oder wie viel ich netzig da hab.
Ist glaube ich für so eine Live.
Nimmste mit?
Nimmste mit, ne? Dann?
Ich geh mal auf das Angebot ein. Nein.
Ich hab noch mehr davon. Also nicht von denen, aber das ist ein lösbares Problem.
Kann ich alle bewerfen.
Also wir erwägen mal unsere Optionen. Wir müssen das nochmal besprechen.
Aber sag mal, sonst hatten wir immer so Spezialgäste mit Spezialthemen. Wo war das jetzt bei dem Tomate? Ach, Buchhaltung oder was?
Da hast du gepentigst.
Da hast du geschlafen. Das war, das war da, ja.
Ja, weil Tim das ja auch macht. Aber sonst haben die ja so ihr eigenes Thema. Verstehe.
Ja, sorry, dass ich nicht mehr zu bieten hab.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Wir könnten das jetzt noch beliebig vertiefen, aber wir sprechen das jetzt erst mal so auf so einer Meta-Ebene. Man muss die Leute ja auch langsam da ranführen.
Das ist wie Mate. Die erste Mate schmeckt immer scheiße. Also die erste Buchhaltungssendung.
Tomate?
Ich fand die erste Mate hat nicht scheiße geschmeckt. Jetzt schmeckt die Mate scheiße. Weil sie zu süß geworden ist.
Hat zu viel Flora gesoffen.
Die haben eine Prokose reingemalt jetzt in die Mate.
Sollten wir nicht Feierabend machen?
Nee, auf der Republik haben wir noch. Am Ende hab ich die Sully-Mate getrunken. Die fand ich ganz lecker eigentlich. Aber das nur am Rande.
Das nur am Rande. So, da jetzt der intellektuelle Quotient nicht weiter ansteigt, sagen wir einfach Tschüss, wa? Tomate, vielen Dank.
Welche Sendung war das heute? 97?
98. Der Kontern läuft. Wir lassen uns was einfallen. Bis später.